ch bienvenue pour ce Championnat
d'Europe des
nations comment tu
vas bah salut Yosa ça fait ça va très
bien ça fait super plaisir de de te
revoir de de commenter avec toi à
nouveau un grand tournois où nos joueurs
et joueuses sont sont présents et
présment présent et en forme euh ça ira
beaucoup mieux si on me dit que la
technique ça va que on te voit qu'on
t'entend qu'on m'entend parce que comme
toi tu le sais mais pas encore les
spectaturis euh j'ai encore fait takyosa
c'était la panique au moment de lancer
le stream on ne voyait pas on
t'entendait pas tu voyais pas mon écran
il y avait rien qui n'allait
et bon j'ai fait des
bidouillages c'est tout bon on entend
bien nous dit Quentine je l'ai
tap'appelé à l'espagnol qutin priori
donc donc bonjour à tous et à toutes
bienvenue venez N nombreux nombreuses
soutenir les équipes de France avec au
menu nana de France Allemagne euh donc
on verra si si les Bleus euh les Bleus
qui est dans l'équipe open ou dans
l'équipe féminine peuvent battre nos
voisins amis M Rivau allemands ou alors
s'il a de Ch qualitate va faire parler
d'elle
aujourd'hui donc au programme là vous
avez la partie de Pauling Guichard qui a
commencé il y a 12 minutes mais qu'on
aura seulement les premiers coups dans 3
minutes mesure antitriche oblige il y a
15 minutes de
délai j'ai les autres parties on a au
troème échiquier
euh Joséphine einman Josephine
probablement à l'allemande qui affronte
notre championne de France Mitra et
jazip pour au deuxème échiquier la sex
tuple championne de France Sophie mer
affronte la jeune Allemande Dinara
Wagner et au premier échiquier le choc
entre Elizabeth P un grand maître
international qui joue contre Démé d'lit
cornet ça c'est pour l'équipe féminine
et dans la section
donc France Allemagne
bis Maxime Lagarde affronte Alexander
donchenko Mathias blobum affronte notre
techfess Laurent
fressiné Jul Moussard à les blancs
contre Swan rasmous et au premier
échiquier un choc de prodige que sépare
quelques générations Etienne bakro
l'ancien plus jeune grand maître au
monde qui affronte Vincent
Gamer pour un match choc
euh vous êtes dans le chat alors moi je
peux voir plus ou moins les chat parce
que j'ai ma bidouille voilà mais je
crois pas j'ai même pas de compte en
fait je suis pas certaine que je puisse
parler euh nana toi tu tu suis quel chat
les deux un seul rien
euh les deux chats c'est-à-dire c'est
lequel le deuxième YouTube et et twitch
je crois même qu'on est je crois même
qu'il y a trois chat hein il y a YouTube
ch
24 youtubechess.com twitchess.com mais
je suis pas tout à fait certaine de ce
que j'avance donc il est 14 les partie
devrai commencer
insensément si si elle suit tout elle
suit tout non y elle suit tout n attends
euh
multitask juste pour compléter ce que tu
disais Yosa euh alors dans le la
compétition open donc la France qui est
actuellement classé 4e affron la
l'Allemagne je vais dire la Germanie
l'Allemagne première execo avec 11
points la France à talent avec 10 points
donc gros gros match en fait les
Français ont fait une sacré rantada
comme on dit tout à fait l'armontada ào
malgré ouais Alamo ouais malgré leur
leurs deux défates les deux matchs
qu'ils ont perdu ils sont là ils sont
juste au pied du podium il reste deux
matchs r 8 r 9 tout peut encore arriver
chez les filles on est un peu sur un
tableau un peu différent la France est
2e après la défaite hier contre la
Bulgarie la Bulgarie est première avec
12 points la France 2e avec 11 points à
égalité avec l'Azerbaïdjan l'Allemagne a
un tout petit peu plus loin elles sont
euh 6e avec 9 points donc juste bon
malgré le fa pas d' hier ben les
Françaises si elles gagnent leurs deux
matchs déjà bon on est assuré d'un
podium à minima d'une seconde place mais
euh la Bulgarie ça va pas être si simple
hein le gagner ses les deux prochains
matchs je pens il me semble il me semble
tu me corriges si si je me trompe que
euh si la Bulgarie fait un faux pas même
juste un match nul la France pourrait
repasser devant ouais ouais ouais bah la
France a fait le parcours euh a fait la
course en tête
comme on dit euh donc première défaite
hier euh malheureuse et ça s'est joué à
pas grand-chose vu les parties la France
a perdu 3-1 mais bon çauraitêre 2 2 31
dans l'autre sens bon c'est le jeu aussi
de toute façon il faut il faut une part
de réussite pour gagner un tel
championnat alors attends évidemment
j'ai pas les coup qui jouent tout seul
mais c'est bon donc les parties ont
commencé et comme tu le dis si euh notre
belle équipe de France féminine remporte
ses deux dernier match à minima 2e et de
très bonnes chances de finir sur la plus
belle des places du podium la première
c'était vraiment l'objectif affiché
euh de cette équipe de France euh
nouvelle formule on va dire avec
plusieurs joueuses qui sont françaises
depuis uis peu et et ça ça donna un
nouvel élan une nouvelle nouvelle
dynamique à l'équipe de France avec
aussi on a cité toutes les joueuses on a
cité également Sébastien Mazé le
capitaine de l'équipe de France mixte et
évidemment on n'oublie pas Sylvia
alexevia la capitaine de l'équipe de
France féminine et là aussi je pense que
son capitain et sa présence sur place
apporte forcément de la fraîcheur du
dynamisme du team spirit la combativité
euh donc voilà bref la si tu as quelque
chose à rajouter avant qu'on passe au au
parti mais oui tu as tu as tout à fait
raison de relever le fait que maintenant
que Sylvia euh est la capitaine de de
l'équipe de France féminine euh
habituellement on avait plutôt ben un
rôle de joueur euh comment ça un rôle
plutôt de capitaine entraîneur donc
avait eu Mathie cornette Yannie godzoli
donc là c'est tu as raison je suis
complètement d'accord avec toi le fait
de de partager ce rôle d'avoir
l'entraîneur d'un côté le préparateur
d'un côté et la capitaine c'est vrai que
ça en alors j'étais présente en Pologne
donc Sylvia avait le le rôle de de
capitaine on avait pas d'entraîneur à
proprement parler même si on a reçu de
l'aide vraiment de l'aide de la part des
des entraîneurs de l'équipe de France
jeune Yannick bien sûr qui jetait un œil
qui était toujours présent de loin qui
qui regardait qui conseillait de loin et
euh de faire cette
différence ça apporte quelque chose de
je sais pas c'est je sais pas ah
aide-moi je sais pas comment dire mais
c'est vrai que ça ouais ouais ça apporte
bah de la fraîcheur de l'esprit d'équipe
de la convivialité enfin après c'est toi
qui étais sur place donc juste petite
précision la Pologne c'était le
championnat du monde où la France a
brillé c'était le premier pas en avant
dans dans cette dynamique ben de
victoire espérons-le où vous avez
terminé 3e du championnat du monde
c'était s format partie rapide mais
c'était le Championnat du Monde par par
équipe et c'est une 3è place historique
à noter
que j'avais oublié totalement mais si la
la France ce qu'on espère tous et toutes
remporte ce championnat d'Europe ça sera
pas la première fois en 2001 il y avait
eu dans un tout autre format c'était des
équipes équipes avec même des guillemets
mais des équipes de deux
joueuses en 2001 la France avait
remporté le championnat d'Europe avec
une équipe composée de la très jeune
Marie cebag et de Maria le
comte Marie avait d'ailleurs fait une
norme de Grand Maître voilà donc 2001
premier titre mais c'est vrai que la
compétition m'a été moins prestigieuse
avec des des matchs sur deux échiquet
seulement donc on va faire un petit tour
des des
parties en se concentrant a priori plus
sur les filles en tout cas aujourd'hui
et on verra demain ce qu'il en est euh
juste pourquoi et puis après on promis
on va vraiment parler des Chac rentrer
dans le vif du sujet
euh en fait en voyant
que avant il y a quelques jours rien
n'était prévu pour suivre ces
championnats d'Europe ni ni la section
open ni la section féminine et en voyant
la France caracolé en tête moi je me
suis dit ben c'est quand même trop
dommage qui qu' se passe rien euh que
Ben aucun
acteur des échecs en France ne propose
une retransmission direct alors que
potentiellement on va avoir
un podium et un titre de de championne
d'Europe et donc je voulais commenter et
j'ai proposé à chess.comfance qui a
accepté tout de suite de qu'on commande
toi et moi la section féminine et puis
tout d'un coup la remontada de l'équipe
de France mixte a fait que bah
évidemment il y a il y a un intérêt à
les suivre aussi on va pas les oublier
mais on va se concentrer avant tout sur
sur nos Jos et puis bah demain on verra
qui joue pourquoi mais et on espère être
de retour demain pour poursuivre nos
belles équipes de France donc Pauline
réfléchit ici elle a joué son coup
habituel des quatre et c'est la défense
viennoise défense partie viennoise en
tout cas bon elle connaît parce que elle
en a joué même avec les Noirs donc a
priori elle est dans son élément
euh et je vois que le petit déchiquier
CIT le il y a un un live board qui va
bugger comme d'habitude que je vais
oublier comme d'habitude mais en
attendant on va passer à la partie de
Mitra
euh juste pour oui avant de finir sur
petite petite parenthèse donc Pauline
c'est sa 7e partie qu' joue pendant la
compétitions et c'est sa 5è partie avec
les Blancs donc elle a joué deux parties
avec les Noirs CIN parties avec les
Blancs joueuse extrêmement solide qui a
5 et demi sur 6 5 et demi sur 6 et euh
voilà enfin merci d'avoir hello là elle
est en train d'enchaîner entre le grand
Suisse et cette compétition championat
d'Europe B Pauline Guichard C enfin on
verra bien ce qu' en est mais pourquoi
pas plus 2004 au prochain prochain hlo
oui oui ça fait vraiment plaisir de de
de la voir revenir bah au niveau auquel
elle nous a habitué elle a eu une
mauvaise passe qui a duré plus plusieurs
moi mais elle a continué à s'entraîner
avec la régularité que lui enfin que lui
autorise son son métier de de médecin et
et donc là elle revient elle revient au
top niveau et ça fait plaisir 5 et demi
sur 6 un deuxème meilleur score de
l'équipe de France bah c'est justement
Mitra qui elle a les pièces noires elle
joue sa défense sicilienne alors
peut-être c'est toi qui va plus euh nous
en parler soit de Mitra soit de de cette
défense sicilienne est-ce que
l'ouverture t'inspire quelque chose
est-ce que Myra t'inspire quelque chose
nana alors oui Mitra est très inspirante
mais je t'avoue que moi je suis plutôt
milieu de jeu les ouvertures bah si
j'aimais ça si les ouvertures m'aimaient
ça serait depuis des années mais après
je crois qu'on est dans un j'appelle ça
une CAN 6 allez c'est la C 6 je sais
jamais c'est une
c'est ça
la je nai aucune idée
paulsenanov dites-nous dans le chat
aidez-nous moi je pas JUSE de 4 pas j de
sicilienne la seule sicilienne que j'ai
joué c'est la Dragon celle que tu
connais aussi pas mal
la Dragon hybride c'est ça
can can on nous dit
ccilian merci ou
différen c'est aucune idée elles se
ressembleent toutes euh mais donc là les
blanss ont donc à Notter que
Mitra un répertoire fixe hein elle joue
tout le temps des Quates les grandes
lignes avec les blancs sur sur4 elle
joue tout le temps sa sicilienne donc
elle va se prendre des prépas mais
parfois c'est pas grave parce que un peu
comme Maxime à l'époque quand il jouait
que sa neidorf combien même il était
préparé c'est toujours des positions
dont il a l'habitude et qui qui maîtrise
parfaitement et donc voilà ouais et ciel
bleu qu'on salue nous nous explique en
pratique canov transpos souvent l'une
dans l'autre ouais c'est pour ça que je
sais jamais qui qui est qui euh
donc donc désolé mais à noter le grand
rock des blancs les noirs eux spoiler
ils vont pas faire grand rock très
souvent le roi noir reste même au centre
parfois évidemment il fait petit rock
donc on va avoir forcément une partie
tendue enfin potentiellement en tout cas
avec soit ro opposé et donc attaque
chacune vers le roi de l'autre soit
attaque à l' d'â sur le roi blanc pour
les Noirs contreattaque au centre pour
les blancs sur le roi noir qui ne va pas
Roer donc ça va être
tendu un petit mot sur sur cette
on passe à à la partie suivante je pense
qu'on peut passer à la prochaine après
je suis juste un peu surprise dis-moi
que Mitra se mette à réfléchir alors
est-ce que on est toujours dans dans la
théorie je pense que oui ouais je pense
que lui aussi alors vu qu'elle joue que
ça je pense qu'elle peut aussi connaître
très bien mais donc voilà là la jou fou
B4 ce qui paraî assez logique ça tout de
suite des grosses menades donc ça je
pense par que c'est le le coup principal
mais donc parfois même dans les
positions on connaît bien quand on sait
que
l'adversaire c'est bien préparé on va
passer du temps à réfléchir est-ce que
je joue le coup principal est-ce que je
joue une autre ligne est-ce quelle
quelle partie j'ai j'ai dans la base à
quel point on a pu se préparer et cetera
donc parfois on se retrouve à réfléchir
alors même on connaît très bien la
position qu'on a le coup principal ah là
mon cour cheessble petite publicité mon
cour cheess il recommand ça mais mon
livre il recommande ça et cetera donc
qu'est-ce que je vais choisir j'ai joué
ça récemment et cetera et cetera et puis
on passe 5 minutes 10 minutes et c'est
c'est tout à fait standard mais donc une
partie prometteuse
ou c'est aussi un moment où où les
joueurs et joueuses prennent le temps
pour se concentrer se mettre dans la
partie c'est déjà arrivé enfin je pense
à plusieurs d'entre nous aussi dans le
chat on connaî par cur on joue on joue
on joue et tout d'un coup quand il faut
qu'on commence à réfléchir bah comme on
s'est pas échauffé comme on s'est pas
mis dans dans le mood de la compétition
de la partie et ben là tout d'un coup on
se retrouve désarmé et c'est là souvent
que la première erreur est faite dès
qu'on sort de l'ouverture dès qu'on sort
de
ouais ouais je suis bien d'accord B et
c'est c'est horriblement frustrant
qu'est-ce que qu'est-ce que je me suis
déjà senti nul mais quand quand tu jou
genre 15 coup de thorie et que tu fais
une erreur au 16e mais tu te sensis
ridicule quoi ok bravo tu sais réciter
tu es un espèce de de singe savant qui
récite ses coups et puis après dès qu'il
faut réfléchir par soi-même il y a plus
personne mais bon
euh Sophie met donc Sophie depuis
quelques années et
ça ça lui a porté bien bien des
bénéfices elle s'est mise à alterner
entre E4 et D4 entre des catalanes et
bah des des grandes lignes de4 ou des
petites lignes de4 elle s elle a
vraiment diversifié son apertoire avec
les Blancs et elle aussi ben elle est
elle est plutôt en forme de manière
générale là elle elle avait fait un un
un très bon un grand Suisse à lofman et
donc là une Sicilienne avec un ordre de
coup un peu bizarre mais
peut-être non peut-être je peux pas qu
donc parce qu'elle va jouer k C3 d'abord
avec Dame prend D4 alors qu'est-ce que
ça autorise qu'est-ce que ça empêche de
jouer C3 d'abord et non pas
ça sur cavalier C6 parce qu'elle va
mettre la dame D3 et donc peut-être ici
elle avait peur que les Noirs jouent
avec autre chose que cavalier
F6 je sais pas si genre E5 tout de suite
est un coup je
suis vraiment pas spécialiste mais en
tout cas elle a choisi un N de C
original elle joue cavalier C3 tout de
suite et sur cavalier F6 elle joue D4
donc potentiellement après qu' les prend
ça
retranspose dans dans les grandes
variantes à noter que ça autorise quand
même des choses hein ici on peut jouer
E5
donc donc ça ok il y a pe probablement
une idée maline mais ça c'est pas non
plus sans conséquence il y a des
variantes en plus à apprendre sinon tout
le monde jou ça et donc sur k C6 non pas
le coup de développement naturel fou B5
ça c'est un peu je l'ancienne grande
ligne où les blancs se développent comme
ça avec fou G5 grand RCK assez rapide on
a donné la paire de fou mais bon en même
temps le fou fite pour l'instant il fait
pas trop peur on va jouer fou G5 grand
rock tour1 ou même parfois H4 H5 assez
rapidement ça c'était ce qu'on voyait le
plus souvent et donc là Dame des TR
garde toutes les pièces sur les chiquier
mais c'est vrai que c'est quand même peu
conventionnel la dame qui rejoue une
deuxième fois qui bloque son fou et sur
G6 cavalier D5 donc c'est très concret
propose un changement de structure qui
serait favorable au blanc si on voit ça
on reprend du pion et le cavalier doit
rejouer le pion7 arrière sur la colonne
ouverte il y a du dame D4 à nouveau un
nouveau coup de dame qui peut arriver et
donc donc ça ne va pas donc le cavalier
est imprenable fou G7
C3 bloque la diagonale du fou et petit
rock fou G5 a été joué menace de casser
la
structure par des prises successives en
F6 et donc sur qu'er prend des5 on
reprend du pion
ok petit commentaire sur les temps oui
dismoi je pense qu'on est euh à 100 %
dans une prépa de Sophie
ben d'ailleurs on peut voir le temps
joue entre chaque coup les temps de
réflexion 10 secondes 11
secondes toute façon même le plan avec
cavalier C CER C3 D5 puis jouer le pion
en C3 c'est pas quelque chose de
d'intuitif qu'on jouerait naturellement
sur
les donc on attend de voir quelle est la
surprise que que Sophie nous a préparé
ce qui est très bien c'est qu'elle prend
l'ascendant au temp déjà c'està dire que
son
adversaire et et surprise son adversaire
est obligé de réfléchir son adversaire
doit créer doit
oui doit créer son propre plan doit
oui c'est ça
exactementou réfléchit avec ses neurones
face à la
prépa d'ordinateur de de Sophie donc ça
c'est c'est toujours toujours difficile
bon mais à noter quand même dinaraviner
elle est vraiment jeune gen 21 22 ans
peut-être et encore en pleine
progression c'est quand même une super
Jose donc il suffit pas d'une d'une
belle idée dans l'ouverture aussi
original soit telle pour pour la la
renverser mais ça peut au moins la
bousculer un peu donc ça c'est c'est
plutôt cool dis-moi et ce qui est plutôt
marrant c'est que je sais pas oui vous
avez la jauge donc d'une certaine façon
intentionnellement sophie va dans une
variante qui est un tout petit peu euh
qui est jugée un tout petit peu moins
bien par l'ordinateur h mais pour autant
ça veut pas dire que c'est que c'est
perdant ou ça ne ça ne prédit pas la
suite de la partie parce que comme on a
dit Sophie
elle connaît la position son adversaire
ne la connaît pas et en fait on est plus
sur une gestion de
euh euh on est plus sur une comment dire
B un choix volontaire dansç c'est c'est
c'est un choix volontaire d'entrer dans
dans ses complications de toute manière
combi même on joue les grandes variantes
la théorie combi même on joue à chaque
fois le meilleur coup d'ordinateur on va
pas réfuter le jeu d'échec si
l'adversaire fait pas d'erreur c'est
match nul à la fin donc pour que
l'adversaire fasse une erreur bon si on
joue tous les coups l'ordinateur à un
moment il va en faire une mais mais
sinon ça peut être pas mal de jouer un
coup suboptimal que l'adversaire ne
connaît pas euh pour inciter à la
faute et donc ouais bonjour à tous et
toutes on a vu Sérafina on a vu stouf ça
fait plaisir de vous
voir de vous voir tous et toutes présent
euh
ouais alors ouais les postites ouais bon
c'est taocha encore mais là c'est pas de
ma faute c'est que je ne suis pas chez
moi je suis chez une amie scénariste et
qui s'amuse souvent à
à créer des postites pour pour céder à
dans l'écriture de ces scénarios parce
que je n'ai pas la fibre chez moi voilà
c'est bon c'est toute une histoire un
coup je la raconterai quand tu auras un
creux pourquoi jeai je nai toujours pas
la fibre chez moi c'est
euh assez lunaire comme histoire mais
c'est pas de ma faute alors démter
eu ah ben j'espère mais non parce que je
moi je suis vraiment en plein Paris ça
oui je vois tess.com se déconnecte et se
reconnecte sur sur twitch donc ouais
c'est oh god on est on est bon ça marche
bon euh
ok normalement demain euh je serai chez
moi il y aura pas de postit j'aurai la
la fibre qu et et ça sera parfait donc
un peu une petite ouverture reti euh
enfin
reti en tout cas est indenne système est
indienne en premier on va voir ce ce sur
quoi ça va déboucher est-ce que ça va
être une attaque estindienne est-ce que
ça va être une RTI plus avec double
chanketo et cetera est-ce que ça sera
une vraie euh est indienne en premier
c'est possible parce qu' après eu 5
euh ellzabeth n'a pas jouer C4 E5 menace
D5 entre guillemets mais euh ellzabeth a
choisi de laisser les Noirs jouer des 5
ce qui est pas forcément conseillé
d'près l'ordinateur mais en même temps
si on réfléchit couleur inversée les
blancs sont juste en train de jouer une
Neste indienne avec un tempo de plus
donc ça peut pas être totalement
mauvais mais l'ordinateur c'est vrai
qu'il déteste l'est indienne en fait
malheureusement ça fait partie de ces
ouvertures qui étaient des grandes
lignes quand Kasparov les jouer et puis
même ficher avant lui et maintenant
l'ordinateur affiche assez souvent un
gros avantage blanc quand c'est les
noirs qui la joue et donc là il préfère
déjà légèrement les Noirs mais
évidemment humainement ça peut pas être
mauvais d'avoir cette position là ou
c'est une position qui existe avec un
temps de de moins pour les blancs dame
C7 et
[Musique]
oui donc donc là on voit que le cavalier
a 3 donc les BL jouer cavalier A3 l'idée
c'est de rediriger le cavalier vers la
ce C4 donc ça ne peut pas être mauvais
de jouer cette position avec
les avec les Blancs
h mais j'ai l'impression qu'il y a un
souci avec tu.com j'ai l'impression que
ça bug ça se déconnecte puis reconnecte
sur twitch ah bah je sais moi j'ai le
chat dans le chat personne se plein
alors c'est revenu noici cel bleu
ah
ben je ne ce sont des microocoupures
euh ben je ne sais pas parce que pour le
coup je suis bien en wifi euh j'ai j'ai
testé la connexion ça allit moi je vois
le temps qui repart de zéro de la la
vidéo
donc bon ça vous pose pas de
souci je sais pas parce que en plus je
suis chez une amie en en en commun avec
avec lib qui a souvent fait des streams
ici alors c'était peut-être pas lui qui
hit mais normalement
internet suffisamment bon alors je sais
pas si on se prend en plus un truc
internet rambolaesque ça ça ouais ça
coupe de temps en temps ok micro coupure
bon et ben
écoutez déso je fais je fais avec le
moyen du bord
euh C TR ça fait
partie de ce plan pour jouer à l'aldame
c'est ça va pas forcément
euh dire que les blan ne vont pas jouer
avec LC4 comme tu l'as dit c'est c'est
clairement une des idées l'autre idée
c'est de jouer pour F4 mais donc là bon
elle a commencé par C3
ok à noter qu'on veut pas prendre parce
qu'on peut se dire je prends je crée ce
pion euh des arriéré sur la colonne
ouverte mais on a donné un pion central
contre un pion B seulement et donc les
blancs vont finir par réussir à jouer
des quat et ça va pas du tout aller donc
on ne prend pas et peut-être que c'est
les blancs qui vont prendre mais
peut-être pas parfois il y a cette
tension qui reste assez longtemps
ok bon on a fait le tour de de toutes
nos je faire
nana on peut aller voir les gars ça peut
être sympa de jeter un petit coup d'œil
ride chez les gars et euh il faudra
aussi qu'on jette un petit coup d'œil
sur les parties des
joueuses la partie des joueuses du en
espérant qu'elle passe ouais des
Bulgares en espérant qu'elle fasse des
faux pas ouais alors je je les ai pas là
mais mais on verra après après la pause
et
tout alors ça c'est Maxime la garde je
vais pas changer le
Petitier à chaque fois on
va
donc une carocane d'Alexander
donchenenko c'est son ouverture à
Alexander Maxime qui joue au 4 ça c'est
fréquent carocan
d'avance
ah si je crois que c'est même même ici
c'est
plutôt c'est non qu est CCI ça doit être
le coup ok non ben je je suis un peu
surprise de de ce coup ass 6 quand même
euh je vois pas trop pas trop l'idée
pour être
franche si on joue Caval si on joue
d'ame B6 juste sur qu 7 il avait
peut-être
prise
al la Jae elle a l'air de se ouais la je
naime pas du
tout on va jouer F3 et ensuite on bloque
bien la case D4 à 6 et ben dis donc je
me coucherai moins bête
oui mais dans ce CASL ça change quoi oui
tu forces ah oui par rapport à l'ordre
de coup par la F 3 B6 puis on prend C5
il a là il y a la prise en
B2 non
d'ord bon prendre en B2 c'est toujours
un double tranchant parce que ben si la
question c'est est-ce qu'on veut
vraiment prendre en un au coup d'après
eu et la réponse c'est c'est pas clair
parce que quand même on fait prise en et
euh je sais pas même si les blancs
passent leur tour bon passer leur tour
c'est peut-être optimiste mais je veux
juste montrer que la la dame est
enfermée et
elle peut se faire attaquer assez
facilement donc en fait même après même
un coup aussi stupide que H3 on me
laasse pas vraiment de prendre donc
l'ordi a l'air de dire que sur fou E3
euh dame B6 surprise maintenant il
reprend et donc il a cette
menace et euh et donc là là ça va en
fait toute cette
structure c'est pas qu'elle est bonne ou
mauvaise pour quiconque en soit c'est
elle est très bonne pour les blancs si
ils peuvent s'installer en des4 et si
les Noirs ne peuvent jamais faire F6 de
manière à casser vraiment ce qui reste
de la la chaîne de pion et puis je 5 un
jour et donc là le pion5 a l'air plus
faible et la case D4 ben les blancs nont
pas accès alors que dans la variante de
tout à l'heure si on jouait dame B6 trop
tôt prise prise B4 obligé de jouer un
coup comme ça et donc là après un coup
comme fou 3 ou ou autre on voit que les
Blancs ont accès à à la case des4 mais
ok c'est quand même subtile mais bon
j'imagine que les joueurs étaient dans
leur prépas et
euh
et donc on en est là et Maxime réfléchit
à noter que Maxime réfléchit beaucoup
son adversaire n'a pas encore réfléchi
donc Alexander est dans sa prépa et
c'est peut-être le coup à qui peut jouer
et
que que Maxime ne connaissait
pas je alors je saute un peu du cocalan
je vois lae qui qui s'affole un peu dans
la partie de Mitra
c'est pas bien c'est juste la non non
mais allons voir allons voir ce a dit
qu'on était
assez alerte sur les parties des filles
allons voir ce qui se
passe donc Mitra à noir je mets le
livebard également donc
c'estilien on sétait quitté à F B4
menace de prendre le pion profitant du
clouage F3 très logique cavalier E5 ok
cavalier B3 et
euh cavalier C4 un coup assez typique
parce que ça prend la paire de fou mais
peut-être qu'on aurait aimé que les
Blancs perdent d'abord un tempo en
jouant le fou avant de le faire mais
quel C4 c'est vrai que ça a l'air assez
humain mais l'ordi n'aime pas du tout
euh alors que
bon on a pris la paire de fou on peut
casser le RO comme ça et potentiellement
je des5 donc ça a pas l'air si idiot euh
mais leord dit déteste son adversaire
Jos finman a joué fou des4 pour
protéger le cavalier C3 et pouvoir
reprendre avec des pièces et
potentiellement prendre en F6
également et donc là je pense qu'on peut
pas jouer D5 parce qu'il va y avoir
prison F6 prison D5 et euh et le roi et
le roi au centre va
est beaucoup trop faible et donc
qu'est-ce qu'il faut jouer
ici juste si on fait un point juste un
arrêt sur image sur cette position les
blondcs ils ont fait le grand rock ils
ont développé toutes leurs pièces h ils
occupent la colonne semi-ouverte d les
noirs n'ont pas encore roquet il leur
faudra à minima deux coups pour pouvoir
développer leur fou C8 donc il y a quand
même un retard de développement h et
euh voilà donc
même s'il y a en l'absence de
considération tactique ou quoi que ce
soit on sent que les Blancs ont quand
même sont sont mieux KAV C6 E5 C4 comme
tu as dit pour Scher contre le fou F1
qui n'avait pas encore bougé finalement
on échange une pièce qui aura bougé
trois fois k B8 C6 E5 C4 contre une
pièce qui euh va bouger qu'une seule
fois donc c'est les deux tempos qui
manquent au noir ouais deuxième coup de
Dam également HM
ouais il y a il a ce coup est très
menaçant avant ou après le rock
ouais et donc ça c'est ça c'est
problématique donc ben rock d'ailleurs
il va pas y en avoir et ouais en fait
c'est tout de suite très dur quoi alors
bon si on se recroque viille et qu'on
joue F 7 pour pouvoir euh recapturer
avec une pièce là potentiellement au
coup d'après je peux je peux Roer quand
même
mais bon ça a pas réglé le le manque de
développement c que ouais après pe être
un coup par exemple comme
E5 j'attaque le cavalier donc je gagne à
nouveau tempo suivi de je pensais à des
coup peut-être comme cavalier E4 ou même
c'est vrai qu'avalier prend D5 ne paraît
pas
abérrant comme coup avec un contrôle
total pour les blonds des cases noires
ouais pourquo pas ouais ouais et puis
bon enfin c'est ce que tu as dit sur le
le fou C8 qui va avoir du du mal à
bouger parce que B5 fou B7 c'est long et
puis en plus même là quand bien même on
y arrive c'est pas non plus le meilleur
des
fous euh D6 ou D5 ça a l'air compromis
ouais donc c'est bon c'est une mauvaise
position c'est une mauvaise position
alors après il y a encore rien en moins
euh bon si ce n'est l'évaluation et du
temp la pendule mais euh il y a pas de
matériel en moins il faut encore pour du
côté des blancs il faut transformer
cette avance de développement en un
avantage plus tangible plus durable
parce que l'avance de développement elle
est réelle et c'est pour ça que les
blancs sont probablement même gagnant
déjà sur un jeu parfait mais c'est un
avantage éphémère donc si on l'arrive
pas à le transformer il disparaît les
Noirs vont jouer fou7 vont jouer si je
peux jouer plein de coups avec la noir
euh je je fais ça et c'est bon il y a
plus de avance de développement mais
ouais ça me fait penser tu me dis oui il
faut faut transformer c'est comme si que
les blanc devait tirer une pénalité sur
le bord de la ligne au 60 m voilà la la
rugby woman c'est possible de prendre
des trois po mais c'est vraiment
vraiment pas simple
ouais c'est c'est peut-être ils vont
tenter leur chance he bien sûr mais ils
vont continuer de jouer et peut-être
qu'il y aura des des essais des
pénalités qui seront un peu plus proches
et plus accessibles tout à fait belle
métaphore rugbyistique de de notre
commentatrice toulousaine ne comptez pas
sur moi
pour pour faire les références Sportiv à
force au
rugby on nous a demandé
si si pourquoi on jouit pas en gros vous
ne faites pas partie du S France nous
demande X de bon euh ben Natacha bien
plus que moi vu que étaé justement
Pologne au championnat du monde où
l'équipe de France grâce à toi a terminé
enfin grâce à toi notamment euh a
terminé 3e de ce championnat du monde
mais euh bah après c'est c'est des
sélections hein donc euh donc euh le
sélectionnaire Yann gozoli en
l'occurrence fait sa sélection et puis
euh et puis après soit on y est soit on
y est pas mais à noter quand même euh
donc d'ailleurs ce petit point sélection
euh euh française il y a les deux
joueuses actuellement les mieux classées
mais ça risque de pas durer très
longtemps si elle continue à prendre des
points nos joueuses mais les deux
joueuses les mieux classés sont en
retraite semi-retraite à savoir marie
soag à la grandmître internationale qui
est désormais psychologue avec elle
ouvert son cabinet euh donc elle se
consacre plus à son métier qu'au échec
et Almira skipchenenko elle ça fait
quand même quelques années qu'elle joue
beaucoup moins elle a participé par
exemple la dernière fois que j'ai vu ce
championnat d'Europe des clubs où elle
n'était pas joueuse elle était capitaine
de son équipe capitaine non joueuse donc
elle joue beaucoup moins et sinon après
c ces deux premières hloos à moitié en
retraite B c'est les CIN éloos suivants
qui ont été sélectionné quoi et Natacha
et moi on est on est juste en dessous
même si moi je enfin je sais pas pour
toi je parle pour moi euh avant le
tournoi je dans M je suis pas très loin
et puis quand je les ai vu écrasé tout
sur les premières rondes j'étais ok en
fait il y a quand même une énorme classe
d'écart euh mais bon peut-être un
jour on retourne chez les garçons on
avait commencé notre tour donc Maxime
Lagar c'était sa carocane allons voir
notre tech frress euh
allez je change je change quand même le
petit tchique finalement
je donc ta fress qui a les Noirs mais ah
c'est un gambidame j'avais peur je
reconnaissais pas l'ouverture j'étais
surprise qu'il a quelque chose
d'agressif non un gambidame avec fou F4
le coup plus joué c'est fou G5 mais F F4
très fréquent aussi C5 alors là il y a
eu plein de parties Carsen Naka et
cetera je crois que c'est vraiment le
répertoire de Naka avec les pièces
noires petit coup de dame cavalier B4
attaque la dame mais c'est vrai que ce
coup il il choque un peu parce que le
cavalier risque de se faire attaquer
ensuite euh la dame est venue en B3 et
euh ça
réfléchit
ok
euh très surprise de ce coup cavalier B4
qui fait vraiment coup de débutant tu
sais genre je rejoue une deuxième fois
la même pièce de l'ouverture alors que
j'ai pas sorti toutes mes pièces et que
j'ai pas fait le rock mais j'attaque
tadame donc peut-être c'est cool et j'ai
vraiment du mal à à comprendre pourquoi
il a juste pas roqué
euh
mais mais ok t fr ça s raison que que ma
raison il y
a cavalier B4 si en jouant cavalier B4
donc on attaque la dame mais aussi le
cavalier regarde en D5 ouais
c'est-à-dire que sur une prise en D5 ça
sa possibilité de reprendre avec le
cavalier donc admettons qu'il avit B5
dame B3 moi moi en fait je voulais plus
jouer dame B1 mais dame B1 pour pour
pouvoir pardon je menace A3 B4 que je
menace pas quand j'ai la dame en en B3
du coup mais donc ton idée ça serait de
potentiellement prendre et à noter aussi
qu'on contrôle la case de 3 peut-être
pas prendre mais en tout cas mon idée
c'était c'est que si tu prends en D5 je
peux reprendre avec un
CER donc là pourquoi pas petit rox alors
il faut voir à 3 B4 ça gagne de l'espace
mais aussi ça crée des faiblesses est-ce
que c'est plus affaiblissant ou est-ce
que c'est vrai que bon quand le fou
estant C1 3 B4 suivi de fou B2 c'est
très bien avec le fou F4 on peut on peut
regretter
mais je sais pas après les noir aussi
peuvent regretter mais ok original ce en
tout cas pour ma compréhension un peu
surprenant à noter que sur dame B3 il y
a quand
même un cou à regarder
c'est pris en
4 et je voulais
faire j'ai l'impression que ah non mais
je vais me prendre dam en fait je
voulais prend tour des1 je je voulais
faire ça mais j'imagine qu'il prend
juste et et tourd1 ou un truc comme
ça j'ai gagné la paire de fou mais je
vais mais je vais perdre la partie quoi
oui les pièces blanches sont sont
beaucoup trop Activ ouis
ouais ouais je suis d'accord après ce
qui est intéressant c'est que par
exemple après un coup comme petit rock
donc ici h ouais à 3 est-ce que je peux
prendremédia ouais ou dame pr n'est pas
possible à cause de cavalier C2
fourchette et là sur ouais exact et
sur c'est la version améliorer on a
roqué les blancs on jou à 3 et donc
maintenant cette
idée doit marcher enfin doit marcher les
Noirs ont la paire de fou et c'est au
blanc de montrer que il y a suffisamment
de dynamisme pour la compenser et en
plus peut-être que sur tourd on peut
garder la dame sur cette diagonale pour
empêcher le RO et si les blanc on arrive
à rien dans les deux trois prochains
coups les noirs sont super bien ok donc
c'est peut-être aussi un argument en
défaveur de dame
B3 vu
que ici dame B3 c'est la la seule case
on va se prendre à 3 d
après ok mais après oui sur dame B3 il a
pas d'urgence à jouer à 3 ouais sur ro
on est pas obligé de jouer à 3 mais en
fait sur fou E2 on joue on peut jouer
aussi DEP pr
C4 le fait que les Blancs jouent A3 ou
pas si fut prendre C4
ça par exemple un coup utile après
est-ce que tour D1 pourrait être un coup
utile bah clairement ouais clairement
sûrement même le meilleur
coup
et d'ailleurs sur DESP 4 on fait juste
pas non mais là avec les no on a
vraiment envie de bouger la
dame et donc là maintenant tu as plus
qu' TR échecs donc je peux peut-être
jouer à 3 pr Pr et tu as plus d vu que
c'est la cas par le fou et par la
tour peut-être que à 5 c'est pas la
bonne ce parce que ici sur cavalier C je
me dis ah c'est dommage je voudrais
avoir des TH de
cavalier bon
ok à noter aussi quand même je veux
juste dire un point sur la
structure c'est pas du tout impossible
que ces deux pions s'échang qu'on
obtienne une structure symétrique et
potentiellement des échanges massifs et
un match nul avec les noir évidemment
est dans son rôle de bloqueur il a pour
mission faire match nul en espérant
qu'un des buteurs avec les Blancs
marque cela dit peut-être que on va y
avoir un pion
désolé toute autre chose mais alors je
sais pas ce que ça vaut mais c'est V que
tu dis si on échange les et C par
exemple a prè d prend C4 on a une
position symétrique au niveau des pions
ok par contre on a on va dire des pièces
de qualité un peu différente on a un fou
en F4 qui a réussi à sortir derrière sa
structure de pion donc le fou qui était
typiquement supposé être mauvais qui est
très très bien placé qui est actif à
l'extérieur de sa structure de pion de
de pion et à l'opposé les Noirs ont
toujours leur fou en C8 donc position
symétrique structure de pion symétrique
mais c'est l'activité des pièces c'est
la qualité des pièces qui fera la
différence
ouais ok non je suis tout à fait
d'accord pardon j'étais concentré sur
monbard qui avait disparu mais tu
pensais à quoi à mon live qui avait
disparu mais je suis entièrement
d'accord avec toi oui c'est pas parce
que la structure de P est symétrique et
qu'il y a des colonnes ouvertes que ça
ça mène au match nul direct
évidemment OK et ben on passe à au
deuxème échquier notre Jul Moussard qui
a les pièces blanches justement qui lui
est dans ce rôle de de buteur dont on
parlait alors après évidemment ces rôles
peut changer en peuvent changer en cours
de match mais donc oh juste yocha
j'avais pas réalisé que Maxime Lagarde
avait 6 points sur 7 6 sur 7 il fait un
super tourno ouais ouais ouais ouais
j'avais absolument pas réalisé que
ouais ouais c'est c'est c'est l'hom
l'homme en forme
euh c'est même dommage qu'avec un
quelqu'un d'ussi en forme il y ait eu de
défaites mais bon après la remontada et
et belle est peut-être qu'à son début
alors mais oui
Jul petite espagnolle une berlinoise
avec des trois fou C5
prise à fou C5 a pour idée de jouer
cavalier D4 et changer ce cavalier
souvent mal placé donc les blancs rentre
maintenant dans une pseudo variante
d'échange avec le cavalier pas forcément
bien placé en F6 pourquoi j'ai pas les
cou tout est bizarre aujourd'hui H3 euh
empêche des fou G4
éventuel à noter je crois que c'est ici
que Y a eu une partie Aronian kramni
candidat pe-être 2013 non pas du tout
2013 un des candidats bien après
mais un des derniers candidats de de
kramnick où aronan avait roqué un peu
naïvement et il s'était pris H6 G5 très
rapidement je crois H6 même là et et G5
au coup d'après si je dis pas de bêtis
je pense dans cette position mais donc
Jul a joué fou
G5 clouage dame de 6 et on en est là les
deux joueurs qui réfléchit quand même
pas mal de coups pour une position qui
devit être théorique encore de trois
coups
euh ah ouais c'est vrai que Jules Jules
est
jeune Jul est jeune sur la photoouis euh
non il a pas 11 ans mais ouais il en a
il en a 18O ouais ouais ouais ouais
ouais bon il faudra le dire au aux
admin.com
h qu'est-ce qu'on peut dire sur cette
position B à noter que les personnes n'a
roqué encore et potentiellement alors le
grand RCK chez les Blancs j'ai du mal à
y croire mais peut-être pas impossible
le grand RCK chez les noirs est lui tout
à fait crédible donc potentiellement
rock du même côté si les deux font petit
rock potentiellement ro opposé si les
noir fond grand rooc euh ce fou pas
forcément une très bonne pièce parce que
Ben H3 empêcher fou G4 et euh le on
pourrait dire on le met en E6 mais c'est
souvent la place du cavalier le cavalier
on le voit souvent comme ça faire sa
petite triangulation pour aller en E6
d'où après il est magnifique il contrôle
toutes les cases
importantes
h donc je sais pas est-ce que les Noirs
veulent juste jouer fou D7 un grand rock
pas impossible à Noé que cette histoire
d' G5 que j'ai mentionné tout à l'heure
à la crvnique c'est pas impossible si
les blancs roquent un un peu tôt par
exemple ici ro on peut tout à fait
imaginer même achis tout de suite sur
foupran on peut même peut-être reprendre
de la dame à priori on va reprendre de
la dame mais euh et sur un coup comme FO
H4 là on envoie G5 et euh attention quoi
le fou peut se retrouver vraiment
mauvais en G3 et puis il peut y avoir
une
attaque une attaque de mat sur le roi
blanc parce que le petit pion en H3 sert
dans le
crage ah
oui on a tendance à penser que les
blancs et les Noirs vont se regarder les
blancs vont pas donner l'adresse de leur
roi avant que les Noirs le fassent tout
simplement parce
que si les Noirs font petit rock les
blancs vont pouvoir faire le petit ro de
manière plutôt sereine parce que c'est
un peu compliqué de jouer H6 G5 et de
s'affaiblir le roi euh h du côté des
Noirs dans cette situation donc c'est
vrai que le le centre on peut dire ouais
que c'est plutôt une position
semi-fermée j'aurais tendance à dire je
sais pas si est d'accord avec moi donc
les Blancs ont la possibilité encore de
temporiser un peu avant de roquer
souvent on dit au débutants il faut se
dépêcher de mettre le roi à l'abri c'est
juste c'est mieux mais parfois on peut
temporiser on peut attendre on peut
observer son adversaire savoir s'il veut
aller à droite ou à gauche et nous on va
voir si on le prend de côté ou voilà je
suis d'accord avec toi une question
concrète c'est euh ce cavalier j'ai
peut-être plus envie de le mettre en D2
qu'and qu'en C3 je sais pas ce que tu en
penses en D2 il peut aller en C4 3 par
exemple h
donc là la C C4 a l'air assez C C4 a
l'air intéressante fait pression donc
attaque D6 mais surtout fait pression
sur le pion E5 et si euh par pur hasard
ben un are fou de case noire arrivé en
G3 on aurait donc le cavalier C4 le
cavalier F3 et le fou G3 qui ferait
pression sur le pion5
ouais ouais ouais et c'est c'est que
dans saette structure euh si le cavalier
é en G8 c'est là aussi c'est on explique
toujours que la la meilleure place de
cavalier c'est vers le centre donc c'est
C3 c'est F6 et tout dans C structure on
préfère souvent avoir le pion F6 pour
justement protéger le pion F5 et donc là
si les Noirs pouvaient jouer F6 les
pièces qui l'attaquent de Mir
concentrique ça serait
totalement obsolette
euh et
juste avant de passer à Baki je voulais
je voulais lire cette anecdote de Bobby
Moran qui nous dit j'ai croisé le Mitr
dans le 14e de Paris par hasard il y a
un mois environ très sympa elle a eu
l'air étonnée d'être reconnue dans la
comme une Velette de cinéma smiley
smiley
euh ok on passe à Baki
ouais allons voir Baky donc Baky premier
échiquier premier échiquier qui
a qui affronte le
prodige allemand
euh il est très jeune je sais même pas
s'il a 18 ans mais on entend parler de
lui depuis assez longtemps depuis qu'il
sétait qualifié un grin que là en
gagnant en super foren avec il avait 13
ans il y avait je sais pas combien de
joueurs à 2700 donc B qui il a les noir
au premier échiquier a priori là aussi
sa mission c'est de faire nul mais bon
qui sait
euh ce qui va se pour répondre à ta
question Yosa donc Vincent keer est né
le 15 novembre 2004 donc il a fêté son
euh son anniversaire c'estes 19 ans il y
a pas très très longtemps ah oui ok et
ben j'ai rien suivi donc donc
ok
Vincent et donc un gambidame accepté par
Baky cavalier F3 cavalier F6 E3 donc le
but c'est surtout pas de s'accrocher à
ce pion on le rend on échange un pion
central contre un pion latéral mais le
plus souvent on va jouer C5 pour faire
de même elle aussi peut-être obtenir
cette
structure symétrique avec les colonnes
ouvertes don don on parlait tout à
l'heure
euh mais E4
ok
euh j'aimerais pouvoir dire quelque
chose de très intelligent tout de suite
sur qu'est-ce qui se passe sur qu mais
je suis pas sûr je suis pas sûr de ce
qui se passe euh ce n pas ce que by a
fait he mais donc 4 le ption est en
prise
Vincent oui oui oui tu regardais hein
quand on nous laisse un pion bah ouais
un un pion du côté je regarde pas trop
un pion central regarde je me pose la
question en tout
cas donc oui tour 1 paraît logique hein
les blancs sacrifient le pion E4 pour
ouvrir les colonne sur le roi noir qui
n'a toujours pas roquet et donc paru tu
fais ça
ouais carrément je profite du fait que
le pion ici soit cloué ouais oui
surprise on
prend surprise on
prend c'est le clouage chat c'est le
clouage chat euh Noël avant l'heure
merci ouais donc peut-être d'ailleurs
plus ça que ça parce que là j'attaque le
fou donc des5 n'est pas
possible les blancs j'ai pas d'autre
ch fou B3 h parce que tu tu veux pas te
laisser échanger les pièces he parce que
tu as sacrifié un pion tu joues pour
l'attaque l'activité
ouais après c'est vrai c'est vrai que
c'est très chaud un truc comme ça ça ça
s le sacrifice par là qui qui va arriver
mais bon le pion aussi c'est en plus en
attendant donc je sais pas mais a priori
Baki
ouis réfléchit 52 secondes pour jouer B5
donc il devait pas être surpris plus que
ça donc prend4 dites-nous si c'est qu'
un Gambi ultra connu que Ch on us on ne
connaît pas donc 5 le fut attaquer il va
en D3 protège le pion fou B7 l'attaque à
nouveau E5 le pion
rebouge donc ce coup5 c'est toujours le
prélude à une attaque potentielle à l'
roit parce que ça enlève le cavalier F6
mais en même temps là le cavalier F6
s'en va mais sur une case magnifique au
centre et ce fou il peut il peut envoyer
du rêve aussi cavalier C3 cavalier D7 A4
pour taper les affaiblissement
C4
ok alors B not Vincent il est il envoie
tout à tempo il est dans sa prépa
ça probablement des coups sur la case G5
à toutes les pièces blanches peuvent y
aller H6 assez logique et il envoie
encore H4 donc Vincent 1h34 à la pendule
B plus que 45 minutes la position la je
nous dit que ça va mais on aimerait que
Vincent sorte le plus vite possible de
sa
prépa sans que bcky fasse de mauvais
coup parce qu'videmment si tu fais un
mauvais coup il est pas travaillé parce
que c'est c'est mauvais c'est pas le
coup de
l'ordi mais si c'est trop
mauvais donc juste pour information le
pion H4 il est pas il est pas prenable
ouais par que le F E7 protège la case D6
et donc après fou H4 il y a cavaill D6
fourchette roi fou B7 donc H4 l'idée des
blancs prendre de l'espace je pense sur
sur l'aileri ils vont jouer H4 H5 HM et
euh voilà tranquillement en fait on
assoit juste notre
domination notre ouais notre domination
sur les chiqu on contrôle le centre on
occupe les roi eTTH bon là pour le
moment c'est pas possible parce que le
frou est E7 mais pourquoi pas des thèmes
plus tard à un moment un autre tour à 3
tour qui transit ouais ouais ouais non
mais tu voilà il peut avoir des idées
comme ça donc c'est
oui ça peut être une autre idée de4
parce que c'est vrai que sur A4 au début
j'étais en mode ah ok A4 il a envie de
de provoquer un coup comme B4 créer des
affaiblissement à la dame genre la 4 C4
qui est maintenant faible et tout mais
en fait c'est tu peut-être raison par
que sur A4 C4 je me suis dit B en fait
avoir joué à 4 peut-être pas terrible
euh bon le pion 5 peut être en prise un
jour mais ça ça m'avait moins l'air
Fichon mais peut-être que a il peut y
avoir
un un un tour à TR à un moment
d'ailleurs surprise on prend C3 c'est ça
ouais surprise donc là-dessus les blancs
échangent les tours et galent le pion B5
mais les Noirs prennent intermédiaire en
C3 et donc là il y a plus de capture de
P B5 et il y a plus de tour à 3 donc
plus donc il a rest toujours le gros
problème de la case D5 pour la case D5
qui est juste royale c'est un siège
royal pour pour les cavaliers
noirs h donc si les blancs si pardon
j'ai juste dire si les noir n'avait pas
la case des5 on pourrait dire que la
position blanche est est parfaite en
fait ce cette concession de la case
D5 permet au noirs ben de rester tout
simplement dans la partie et voilà case
des5 et cette diagonale A8 Hin qui
grosse transversale sur les chiquers qui
coue vraiment les
chiquers euh
ouis je suis d'accord avec toi
euh je me demande juste comment
concrètement les blancs mènent leur
attaque après rock on n pas rocké a
priori on a envie de le faire euh je
pense pas que les sacrifices genre fa
prend un ch ça puisse marcher
tout de suite est-ce que c'est des plans
plus l comme je sais pas ça ça faire
passer la tour G4 à un
moment est-ce que c'est tour à
3 parce que bon alors B qui n' pas roqué
il a joué dame C d'abord
ouais ouais
pourquoi pas ça peut être pour justement
tu mentionnais cette belle diagonale
pour doubler sur la diagonale on parle
souvent de doubler sur les colonnes mais
on peut aussi doubler sur la diagonale
avec une batterie fou d'â je mettrai
plutôt le fou en avant de la
dame ça peut être une idée bon et ça
surprotège la case des sis et ça donne
peut-être pas tout de suite l'adresse au
roi même si a priori on va quand même
brquer ok même si l'adversaire vient de
faire H4 mais c'est vrai que c'est il un
côté un peu provocateur à H4 ouais je
m'en fiche je
ro donc bon puis d C7 ça va servir à
connecter les tours aussi après le rock
donc h ça peut être juste un coup pour
prendre de
l'espace que ça peut être pr comme une
attaque mais ça peut être aussi juste
pour prendre de l'espace et fixer le
pion le pion G7 par
exemple as H5 petit rock tout d'un coup
ben la diagonale B1 H7 devient très
dangereuse pour les
noirs et voilà on peut plus défendre
alors peut-être pas de suite mais en
tout cas cette idée là et on a plus des
coups comme G6 pour bloquer ce qui était
déjà un peu compliqué avec le F enc donc
voilà c'est c'est juste des idées et
souvent c'est en additionnant les idées
qu'on arrive à trouver les les bons
coups
y je suis entièrement d'accord avec toi
nana alors est-ce qu'on on rejetterait
pas un petit coup d'œil à à nos joueuses
avant de faire une première pause
ouais oui oui bien sûr on veut on veut
pas rater une miette de leur partie
alors retournons voir
popo notre popo qui a les blancs
contre Yana schneeder donc comme tu l'as
dit euh Pauline Guichard double
championne de France 5 et demi sur 6
c'est la joueuse la plus en forme de
cette équipe de France et donc là elle a
les blancs et face à une joueuse moins
bien classé donc elle a clairement pour
mission de
l'emporter on s'était quitté ici on
maintenant la paire de fou
potentiellement des difficultés à roquer
et après c'est aussi concret c'està-dire
si on prend un B2 on dévie la dame mais
il y a cette histoire de clouage et donc
sur ro on peut juste jouer E5 a
PR E5 ou et là il y a pas cette histoire
de H6 prise prise parce
queend en G7 en plus la dame qui protège
le pion quand bien même elle serait pas
là ça serait grave mais là c'est juste
foutu donc en fait très
concrètement pour l'instant les Noirs
ont un pion de
plus mais ces deux pions sont faibles
sur en cas de pris en B2 pris en B2 on
voit que il est pas fol chant et il y a
cette histoire de pair de fous de
clouages qui sont
désagréables donc on peut comprendre
pourquoi l'ordi aime tant les les blancs
h
oui et après un coup basant comm H6 H6
ça paraît plutôt logique pour les noir
tout de suite ou euh là où pu on prend
oui H6 avec les Blancs on n pas envie de
jouer fou prend F6 on veut pas rendre la
paire de fou ouais surtout pour jouer
une finale B qui serait qui serait pas
mal euh on a la meilleure structure les
meilleures pièces mais c'est une vraie
concession je suis d'accord avec toi
même moi je crois non moi j'accepterai
la fin mais je saurais que c'est pas le
meilleur coup ah donc en fait voilà H6
en par exemple fou E3 tout simplement
pourquoi pas avec idée de jouer fou C5
mon fou C5 donc admettons coup comme
petit
rock pour mettre le roi à l'abri et et
là bon F prend C4 est possible qui2 pour
surprotéger le pion E4 est possible
aussi sachant que les Blancs qui avaient
un pion de Mo en fait vont le récupérer
en C4 et finalement on se retrouve dans
une position ouverte avec la paire de
fou pour les blan donc un gros avantage
durable je vois aussi une énorme
faiblesse en A7 pour les noirs avec
potentiellement pion B5 qui ouais run
baby run peut
devenir très dangereux et pour compléter
ce que tu disais sur cavalier D2 euh ça
peut aussi servir à jouer F3 une fois
n'est pas coutume je conseille de bouger
le pion F mais là ça endorme bien ces
deux pièces le fou B7 et le cavalier F6
et c'est beaucoup moins grave que
l'habitude de jouer le pion F parce que
on a le fou de cas noir et les Noirs eux
ne l'ont plus et donc ça ça pere une
position de Rê
en plus bien dans le style de popo
positionnal tranquille donc pour
l'instant on en est là et cette partie
se présente bien
ouis
ah et Yan qui nous dit première phase de
popo ce matin allez les bleus avec en
criant à
priori et ben c'est c'est cool ouais
mais à noter il y a une vraie bonne
ambiance
dans de ce que je comprends prendre dans
l'équipe de France sur place mais même
aussi nous on peut le dire nana on a on
a un groupe avec avec popo moi j'ai
changé aussi avec Mitra euh il y a
vraiment les
c'est ce team spirit qui va bien au-delà
des des joueuses sur place et des
capitaines secondant mais donc c'est il
y a voilà il y a une vraie volonté de
voir cette magnifique équipe de France
l'emporter mais donc passons à Mitra ça
allait pas du
tout Yosa àentendre dire j'ai des
frissons j'ai des frissons c'est vrai en
fait il se passe quelque chose il se
passe quelque chose là-bas qu'elles Arve
que les joueuses arrivent à nous
transmettre ici et c'est ça qui est
complètement fou
et c'est pour ça vraiment
vraiment on a envie enfin je parler pour
moi dire j'ai envie qu' qu'elle gagne
cette compétition enfin je sais pas je
ouais ouais non mais bien sûr c'est
c'est c'est épidermique quoi
c'est quoi c'est une
vraie AC un grand eu ouais et et que les
euh parce que j'ai mentionné ben nous
deux comme Quoand on était juste avec
des guillemets peut-être sur le juste
derrière au classement ho bon ben voilà
on est là à échanger avec elle on est là
à les commenter on est là à vouloir les
voir gagner euh j'ai oublié euh de
mentionner Andrea navrotescou qui elle
aussi est juste derrière qui a été
membre de cette équipe de France qui
fait des vidéos pour commenter euh les
plus belles parties euh des euh des
Françaises là on en a fait on en a fait
deux euh au moins et puis je pense
qu'elle va continuer sur sa chaîne
Youtube alleer la voir si quelqu'un ou
quelqu'une peut poser un lien d'ailleurs
à allez-y mais donc voilà il y a ce
dynamisme ce team spirit il va même bien
au-delà de
euh de boudva au montengro là où sont
les joueuses
ok alors Mitra on s'était quitté ici en
fait il y a eu un seul coup de jouer
elle a réfléchi 35 minutes probablement
le temps de se ressaisir le temps de
faire le deuil de cette ouverture eu mal
négocié on avait expliqué
pourquoi cette manœuvre de cavalier pour
venir prendre la paire de fou était trop
coûteuse en tempi en temps de
développement et du coup mauvaise
maintenant comme on l'a dit c'est au
blanc de transformer cet avantage
éphémère en en en essai c'est ça de de
marquer l'essai de marquer la
transformation je sais pas comment on
dit et et donc d'avoir un avantage
tangible durable en échange une
meilleure structure un op de plus je ne
sais quoi mais si les blancs sont trop
mous dans les prochains coups les Noirs
vont pouvoir compléter leur
développement potentiellement même
mettre le RO à l'abri et tout ira bien
dans le meilleur des mondes donc à voir
comment joseéphine va agir
ok voyons la la partie suivante on fait
un petit tour rapide des des
stades
[Musique]
hop
Sophie qui
est blanc je la mets sur le petit
échiquier qui qui disparaît souvent auss
ce petit tchi qui est bon déso pour la
technique donc on s'était quitté ici et
on appréci euh la prépare c'était
vraiment un hord de cours rare pour
commencer suivi d' d'une variante rare
avec d' Prek suivi d'une sous-variante
de la sous-variante de l'ORD de coup
chelou suivi d'un coup encore étrange et
on expliquait qu'ici il y avait cette
volonté de prendre F6 et surprise on est
cont tente de reprendre du pion e pour
créer cette faiblesse pion arriéré sur
la colonne ouverte en
E7 cavalier E5 il a eu des échanges A4
empêche B5 fou D7 et donc je pense que
les blancs sont bien à cause de cette
faiblesse est-ce que ça suffit à avoir
un avantage vraiment conséquent je ne
sais pas mais le F E5 un tôt ou tard il
va se faire chasser ou échanger
et euh donc la colonne sera vraiment
ouverte on va pouvoir attaquer le pion7
plusieurs fois s'il avance on va pouvoir
prendre il y aura pas de recapture
parfaite et donc les blancs sont juste
structurellement mieux à noter que nous
il y a pas l'équivalent hein il y a une
colonne semi-ouverte pour les Noirs mais
qui tape sur un un roc ces pion ce pion
C3 protégé lui par le pion
B2 donc qu'est-ce que tu en penses de
cette position
alors si on prend toutes les
informations c'est-à-dire temps et
cetera on voit que Sophie a réussi son
Paris de l'ouverture elle a une position
légèrement mieux avec un avantage
d'espace avec un fou G5 actif elle a un
avantage de temps qui est considérable
les joueus ont joué 14 coups il ne reste
que 36 minutes à la pendu à son
adversaire Dinara Wagner Sophie a 1h28 à
la pendue c'estàdire que vraiment elle
est en full contrôle pour le moment h
donc euh si on regarde juste le hlo ben
Dinara est un peu mieux classé donc très
bon choix d'ouverture de la part de
Sophie qui avec les blondcs un petit
avantage un léger avantage un léger
avantage d'espace et un avantage au
temps donc Sophie est en contrôle ouais
tout à fait et donc ben après avoir
selon le le match aussi euh
c'est en open on jouera à fond pour le
gain en équipe ça va dépendre de comment
se déroule les autres parties mais pour
l'instant c'est vraiment la situation
plaisante où en avantage on a l'avantage
sans trop de risque quoi il y a
évidemment si on finit par pousser les
Noirs vont avoir des chances mais on
peut aussi jouer vraiment au contrôle
cette partie à
ce cette défense est indenne avec un T
de plus joué par Elizabeth
P on s'était quitté à C3 je
3 hop c'est bon j'ai mis du bon côté ici
oui tu veux
expliquer oui je voulais dire oui on
s'était quitté ici et donc tu avais
parlé de de plan avec cavalier H4 ce que
tu avais dit il me semble Cali H4 en vis
F5 et on menass également de pousser le
pion
F d'ouvrir la colonne sur la colonne F
ou
un petit passement jambe fou G4 F3 fou6
alors pourquoi pas F6 tout de
suite peut-être ça transpose juste après
F4
oui mais tu gagnes un temps de plusin tu
gag tu te rapproches de
40 tu te rapproches de 40 ch non mais
peut-être c'est ça alors après on peut
dire oui le pion est moins bien placé en
F3 donc là on s'assure que l'adversaire
joue vite F4 c'est probablement plus
précis et même au-delà de de se
rapprocher de 40e
et là-dessus donc on a pas le temps de
jouer avec F6 si on pouvait jouer deux
coups d'affilé il y aurait cette enin ça
qui serait possible pour jouer avec F6
mais donc là ça perd une pièce on n pas
eu le temps de créer la case de repli
donc
elle a pris en
F4 et donc c'est vrai que
d'habitude
envie de prend F4 mais j'ai prend4 la
cavalier H4 en prise ou donc est-ce
qu'on peut jouer cavalier prend 4
prend4 F4 alors l' nime pas pourquoi
oui F5 F4 et les pièces blanches sont
beaucoup beaucoup trop actives en fait
faut pas oublier que notre roi il est
toujours ouais dame G4 aussi
ouais dame G4 F6 non ah oui dame G4
pardon dame G4 FO
F6 moins mais ok F F4 comme tu as
dit d'ailleurs F F4 su de cavalier B5
oui il la case D6 C1 ouais c'est euh
ouais
donc c'est bien de regarder ce ce coup
parce que parfois ça gagne juste un pion
mais là ce n'est pas le mieux
h donc je sais pas après c'est vrai que
c'est toujours très affaiblissant pour
les blancs aussi hein d'avoir à jouer
les pions g et F les noirs n'ont pas
encore
roquet
mais il y a un monde où on oui dis-moi
tu as vu qu'est-ce qu'on a dans le chat
ah Maxime c'est cavalier B5 dira qui
gagne ah euh Maxime qui bah qui doit se
reposer de de son périple en blitz
rapide à Saint-Louis ou sur le fil il
s'est fait voler la vedette par par Fabi
et mais donc là il vient soutenir lui
aussi les équipes de France et donc
qu'est-ce qu'il nous disait sur cavalier
prend4 on disait ça ça et donc là
cavalier cavalier B5 tout suite euh
[Musique]
ok peut-être c'était après F5 FA ça qu'
B5 tout de suite et ben salut à toi
Maxime ça fait plaisir de te voir on
espère que tu te reposes bien
entre Natacha et yocha on voit qui est
la joueuse positionnelle et qui et qui
est la joueuse d'attaque euh non est-ce
que tu peux préciser cel bleu ouais non
mais Natacha aussi c'est attaqué il faut
pas le croire hein c'est pas parce que
évidemment j'éblouis souvent le public
par mon talent tactique que Natacha est
à sous-estimé hein
euh mais donc sur j'ai pr je voulais
dire peut-être qu'on peut prendre en C
TR et alors tout à l'heure je voulais
pas parce que j'ai exppliqué que ça on
échange un pion central contre un pion
latéral ça donnait le centre mais là ça
ouvre vraiment la position alors que le
roi blanc n'a plus ses défenseur en en
en G3 F2 on va dire donc c'est peut-être
envisager
mais ça me paraît pas évident et cela
dit ça doit pas paraître évident non
plus à ellisabeth qui n'a toujours pas
jouer ici qui n' toujours pas joué ici
fou prend
F4 est-ce que c'est possible ou est-ce
qu'il y a juste cavalier5
ou là pas du tout pas du tout cavalier 5
après le le problème de FPR F4 c'est que
sur le long terme on a cette case de 5
qui appartient ouis mais alors sur le
long terme parce que visiblement sur le
court terme l'ordi n'aime pas du tout
non il nime pas cavalier E5 mais on n
pas obligé de l'occuper immédiatement
c'est un peu enfin un peu bizarre en
tout cas dans cette situation là ça
c'est très risqué de se clouer de
manière de manière consciente son son
cavalier ouais je pensais que j'avais le
temps de jouer ça ou ça en cas de besoin
mais c'est vrai avec le pion déjà en C 3
c'est peut-être un bon visiblement c'est
très mauvais en tout cas euh
il a cette histoire de cavalier F5 aussi
qu'il faudra gérer un
toard donc je sais pas qu'est-ce qu'on
joue
sur4 juste bouger la
dame DD7
ou7 contrôle aussi au passage cas h
contrôle la case F5 exact
OK et puis bon ça surprotège la la case
des casasses ça peut être utile
aussi
ah puis on prend de jouer donc ouais
grosse réflexion elle a réfléchi 10
minutes 30 secondes la grandmtre
allemande et on peut comprendre
pourquoi il y a les complications alors
l'ordinateur donne un avantage en noir
plus
050 mais bon euh on sait qu' qu'il aime
beaucoup jouer contre les systèmes
estindiens euh en pratique c'est surtout
un un joyeux bazar quand même cette
position
oui oui oui c'est ouais un bazar pour
être
poli C B5 ro nous dit Freebird bah oui
oui c'était le coup de Maxime tout à
l'heure euh je pense qu'il est
thématique dans beaucoup de positions
euh alors est-ce qu'on se ferait pas une
première petite pause histoire de
souffler un peu je crois que j'ai une
scène commerciale qui sera pas pas
forcément adapt je désolé j'ai pas eu le
temps de faire les choses bien est-ce
que tu veux faire une pause ou est-ce
que tu as un petit mot avant non non je
suis d'accord faisons une pause et
revenons en forme pour la suite la suite
des parties si j'arrive à mettre l'
grand de pause à tout de suite quel est
le meilleur moyen de suivre n'importe
quel événement échikien sur plus du
monde au tournois des candidats en
passant par le speed chess ou les title
Tuesday
chess.com/events C tous les plus grands
tournois d'éch il se déroule en
présentiel ou en ligne vivez et
comprenez en direct les parties des
meilleurs joueurs de la planète avec les
commentaires en français de nos experts
notre moteur d'analyse l'explorateur
d'ouverture et les tables base
retrouverz toutes les infos essentielles
comme le programme les horaires des
rondes les prix les résultats les contre
rendus quotidiens les bios des joueurs
les règles dé partartag et plus encore
vous pouvez même participer à la
compétition en pronostiquant les
résultats pour tenter de gagner des
abonnements premium alors rendez-vous
dès maintenant sur
chess.com/events aussi bien sur le site
internet que sur nos applications iOS et
Android pour vivre votre passion comme
nul part
[Musique]
ailleurs
et nous
revoilà pour
cette avant-dernière ronde des
championnats d'Europe mixte et féminin
Championnat d'Europe des nations on suit
les deux matchs France Allemagne en
compagnie de Natasa belmesba ça va nana
petite pause de
retour
ouais ouais ouais ça va très bien
toujours très contente de de partager
cet instant avec toi et avec avec avec
les milliers de personnes qui nous
suivent
surard sur twitch
YouTube donc a bienvenue à tous et
toutes si vous nous rejoignez à la pause
donc on avait terminé par les joueuses
place au joueur avec au 4e échiqu Maxime
Lagarde qui a joué E4 face à Alexander
donchenko qui le répondu par une défense
carocane on s'était quitté il y a
quelques
coups par là fou E7 attaque le cavalier
H4 il ne l'a pas bougé il a joué F3
contre-attaque sur le
fou4 prise intermédiaire oh là là tout
est en prise ils veulent me
torturer mais bon ça va en fait les
complications sont que passagères pris
en des4 toujours cette histoire le
cavalier en l'air le fou aussi le fou
bouge le CER prend le fou plus personne
n'est en prise mais la colonne h s'est
ouverte et
potentiellement au bénéfice des Noirs vu
qu'ils n'ont pas encore
roquet dame B3 propose peut-être du coup
une petite finale qui n ni été refusé n
accepté vu que donchanko réfléchit ici
avec les noir alors est-ce que tu veux
jouer dame pr B3 est-ce que tu veux
jouer un coup de dame un autre
coup qu'est-ce que tu
ferais alors c'est vrai qu'il faut que
je prenne une décision avec Madame alors
battre en retrait ça paraît un peu
bizarre un coup par exemple une dame
C7 ça paraît assez passif parce que
Notre Dame en C7 ne fait pas grand-chose
donc euh est-ce qu'on a vraiment le
choix est-ce qu'on a vraiment d'autre
choix que de jouer dame prend
B3 et après euh ben je ne sais pas mais
en tout cas après il y a une décision
aussi
euh est-ce qu'on reprend du pion
peut-être pas surtout que le pion est en
A6 donc la ouverture de la colonne A
sert pas à grand-chose et les pions
doublés isolés eux peuvent être faible
est-ce qu'on reprend du cavalier
peut-être plus surtout que le pion est
en A6
et du coup si on vient en C5 ou en A5 un
jour on peut taper sur le P7 qui pe
avoir plus de mal à bouger si ça va été
l'inverse B si à 7 sûrement qu'on aurait
fait à pr B3 et non pas cavalier pr
B3 mais pour l'instant don chenko
réfléchit je crois que ça fait quelques
temps déjà qu'il réfléchit ici
donc il faut monter un peu le son de
Nana ah ah c'est que je suis peut-être
un peu loin du micro ouais désolé ok bah
dites-nous si ça va mieux ouais est-ce
que c'est mieux ou pas moi je t'entends
mieux en tout cas je je sais pas si
public t'entends mieux aussi mais je
vais rester coller au micro alors là je
t'entends très très mieux euh beaucoup
mieux même hein
euh ok donc on est ici on mise sur un
échange de dame mais
ouais bon il a pas encore eu lieu en
tout cas alors 3è échiquier notre tech
fress qui a les pièces noires face à
bluebom c'était un gambidam avec ce
cavalier B4 qui m'avait un peu surprise
alors Touc Touc Touc je le mets sur le
petit échiquier
également VO
là attends je vais couper le
ouais donc la position s'est vraiment
transformée donc là on est passé sur une
une position les Noirs ont un pion isolé
en D5 al oui pard parti euh attends je
je revient juste où est-ce qu'on en
était on était par là euh cavalier 4 on
avait mentionné cette possibilité de
création de pion
désésolé mais vas-y je te je te rends la
parole
oui voilà donc en fait les les Noirs ont
un pion isolé en
D5 donc c'est un pion faible mais les
blancs aussi de faiblesse ils ont les
pion C3 et les pions A3 qui sont
isolés et très faible et en prise le P à
3 est en prise donc la question est de
savoir c'est quelle
est donc
ouais quelle va être la faiblesse la
plus difficile à défendre parce que les
blancs vont faire pression sur le pion
D5 les noirs peuvent essayer de faire
pression sur les pions C sur le pion
a
ouais c'est marrange j'ai l'impression
que les en terme de faiblesse c'est plus
les pions blancs qui sont vraiment
faibles parce que le pion d on va
pouvoir jouer F 6 une des tours en D8
mais c'est peut-être les pièces aussi
les pièces blanches qui sont préférables
parce que bon le pion à3 par exemple il
est déjà en prise on a on va pas jouer
FPR à3 pour pass un clouage dame prend
à3 déjà ça donne tout de suite le pion
des5 et même plus tard expose la dame et
c'est peut-être les pièces blanches
alors est-ce qu'il va y avoir un coup de
cavalier des4 pour laisser F F3 ou
mais au-delà des pions les pies on l'air
préférabl mais vas-y dis-moi oui moi je
suis d'accord avec toi j'ai l'impression
que les pièces blanches sont préférables
et j'ai l'impression quand même que les
pièces noires sont assez loin du roi
noir avec la dame en A5 le cavalier en
C6 il y a juste le fond E7 pour le
moment qui est potentiellement présent
pour défendre l'aileri et euh je
regarder
même des coups comme k G5 fou des tro
des des petites choses comme ça qui
créeraient des petites faiblesses à
l'roi avec les pièces noires éloignées
je sais pas voilà c'est peut-être un
tout petit peu
ambitieux mais je garde quand même l'
roiun d'un œil
ok en tout
cas le à la pendule c'est euh c'est plus
ou moins égal faut aussi ce SCO de
développement protège
des5 bon je suis pas spécialement
inquiète quand même pour euh pour
Laurent c'est c'est une partie assez
technique quand même bien bien dans son
style donc euh donc ça va on passe au
deè échiquier Roulio ouais on voir Jul
ouais
donc
et j a les
blanc il s'est passé quelque chose de
marrant on qué ici on parlait du coup on
disait sur H4 il peut y avoir du
G5 les Noirs encore la possibilité de
faire grand les blanc déjà jou H3 G5 G4
pas grave et le fou G3 après G5 G3 il
euh il peut se retrouver enfermé surtout
si le noir arrivve à jouer F6 à un
moment donc la fou des deux pas du tout
euh et fou C3 et c'est vrai qu'on avait
mentionné une idée c'était de jouer
cavalier D2 cavalier C4 et on parlait de
si on pouvait mettre le fou ici on
attaquerait trois fois le pion5 en fait
il fait un peu ça pour l'instant il vaut
attaquer le pion E5 mais avec le fou en
C3 plutôt qu'en
G3 euh et je voulais est-ce qu'on peut
revenir juste ou j'ai une idée je sais
pas si elle marche alors on pourrait se
dire au lieu de faire petit rock les
Noirs pourrai jouer G5 h qu'est-ce qui
se passe s font G5 et donc là sur G5
peut-être que Jul a pensé à fou C3 h et
sur un cûp comme cavalier D7 on a
peut-être cavalier prend le5 avec la
menace de jouer en al ah ouais mais là
on est non en fait tu voulais jouer de
jouer D4
ensuite h bah ouais ouais c'est un coup
alors je sais pas ce que ça ce que ça
vaut
h non non mais c'est c'est très
intéressant ouis c'est très
intéressant alors après G5
Sansin de temps et avec le fou sur cette
diagonale c'est vrai que ça donne moins
envie mais donc là leordi dit que c'est
égal
mais de sacrifice mais là il donne un
avantage et on peut comprendre quoi he
tout à l'heure quand on jou G5 le fou
dev jouer il se retrouvait pas terrible
ici le Fou est très bien placé
maintenant il a des thèmes alors
peut-être qu'on est même pas obligé de
sacrifier ça bloque oui7 ça bloque le
fou C8 qui et F6 c'est le coup qu'on a
envie de jouer positionnellement mais
avec le roi enfin du point de vue de la
structure et des pièces mais alors avec
le roi encore en 8 c'est quand même
optimiste un échec en peut être plus que
dévastateur
ouais donc on comprend que
sagement
Rasmus donc on disait
potentiellementosé tout finalement non
de petits chacun le Fou est V quand même
T8 tranquille et donc sur cavalier D2
est l'idé
calier
c'est pas mal ça quand même non
ouais ça l'air très bien pour les blanc
il y a même des thèmes genre ça on veut
prendre des jouets
F4 bon l'ordi ne sait plusù donner de la
tête mais la jauge aussi mais ça a l'air
pas mal quand même cavalier D2
ouais ce qui est bien dans cette
position pour les blonds c'est que
toutes les pièces ont un rôle euh le fou
fait pression le fou C3 fait pression le
5 le cier C4 fait pression le 5 le
cavalier F3 fait pression le5 donc
vraiment toutes les
pièces il y a une harmonie des pièces
les pièces jouent ensemble et ça a l'air
assez agréable pour les blancs de voir
que tout le monde ou ouais non je suis
d'accord avec toi et c'estte sa pierre à
l'édifice et et c'est dû à cet échange
fou prend cavalier donc à savoir le fou
qui est le fou espagnol qui était venu
en B5 s'échanger contre le
C6 ça fait quelque chose de très concret
les Blancs ont trois pièces mineures qui
peuvent contrôler les cases noires et
bon c'est criant quand on joue qu'av les
C4 comme tu l'as dit toutes les pièces
attaquent de manière concentrique le
pion E5 tandis que les Noirs parce
qu'ils ont la Peire de fou on parle
souvent de l'avantage de la paire de fou
mais il y a aussi des inconvénients on a
que deux pièces mineures qui peuvent
contrôler euh les cases noires et donc à
forceie après avoir joué H6 on a moins
envie euh de jouer avec a F6 parce que
si on pouvait jouer enfin même ici
concrètement ça marche pas parce que là
c'est en prise mais quand bien même on
prendrait pas
euh ici on peut prendre le pion5 on le
ferait mais admettons je sais pas je
fais jouer un coup inutile ici est-ce
qu'on a vraiment envie de jouer F6 en
sachant qu'on a déjà joué à6 c'est moins
sûr quand même ça fait des trous là
cette fois-ci sur case blanche à à l'roi
donc donc ais pas mal ce petit plan fou
de fous C3 toujours plaisant quand on
fait un coup un peu surprenant de de
recul mais après on se rend compte que
toutes les pièces sont comme tu l'as dit
harmonieusement placé il y a un côté
esthétique très très plaisant donc on
aime bien la position de Jul bon après
l'ORD dit vous voyez il est pas aussi
vindicatifin il dit que les noir ont une
position tout à fait
jouable encore un petit mot ou on
regarde by non non oui passon sur la
partie deé tienne je suis je suis
d'accord tournons
Tournon toc toc B qui qui allz noir je
mets le petit échi quiier
également ça a l'air d'être une position
complètement surprenante voà on va
encore rien comprendre enfin moi en tout
cas
difficile alors bon il y a une bonne
nouvelle c'est la Jae pardon je t'ai
coupé oui oui oui il y a une bonne
nouvelle c'est la jauge mais après avec
nos prvres petits yeux d'umain c'est
vrai que c'est une position qui est
complètement déséquilibre et ro opposé
mais les blancs ils sont allés les Noirs
ils ont poussé tous les pions devant
leur roi donc on aurait tendance à se
dire que c'est hyper faible pour les
noir mais le truc c'est qu'en fait les
pions C4 et B4 ils faut une sorte de mur
ils sont c'est une sorte de mur ouais
c'est une sorte de mur et et ben les
blancs faut qu'il franchissent ce mur
ouais ça
ça pardon ça rappelle certaines variant
de la semilave mais mais vas-y euh je te
laisse oui j'allais dire et d'une
certaine façon mais en fait ce fou B7 il
est tellement monstrueux quand on voit
que enfin sur cette diagonale que si les
Noirs arrivent à ouvrir la colonne g
tout d'un coup ben c'est le réveil du H
du dragon j'allais dire le dragon de
l'autre côté c'est le réveil du
hérisson on est pas c'est un dragon à un
hérisson
quoi al c'est pas le même animal ma
chérie il y en a un qui fait un peu plus
peur que l'autre d'habitude
mais il y en a un qui pique il y en a un
qui
pique le le dragon a ses écailles aussi
mais donc ouais bah non c'est blan de
jouer mais G5 c'est c'est une menace ais
G5 c'est c'est le Clement une menace et
surprise peut-être qu'on peut reprendre
mais peut-être même tourg vite
d'abord on é lge là c'est recosé donc
alors on peut juste peut-être voir quel
coup parce que l'ordinateur aimait
plutôt bien est blanc ici euh et donc
cavalier E1 il déteste cavalier1 il
déteste donc peut-être qu'il fallait
prendre pour empêcher le grand rock et
ensuite peut-être faire ce coup de
cavalier E1 ou euh euh mais alit si on
essaie de oui vas-y c'est hyper dur de
se dire je vais empêcher les noirs de
faire Grand Roc dans cette position avec
les Blancs par que tu dis grand ROG
c'est pas possible il a poussé tous ses
pions devant son roi mettre son roi elle
est le dame pour les Noirs c'est enfin
je sais pas je pense que
conceptuellement c'est assez
compliqué mais il a d'abord joué B4
avant de faire grand rock mais c'est
vrai que c'est assez compliqué de se
dire que les Noirs vont oser faire grand
rock dans ce genre de position oui oui
puis juste j'ai fait l'erreur mais mais
ici évidemment là on prend donc c'est
pour ça qu'il faut jouer B4 avant et
ouais alors c'est vrai que il y a on a
poussé t nos pion littéralement il y a
plus un pion à côté mais il y a toutes
les pièces qui sont bien placées ces
pions ils sont poussés mais ils sont
encore là donc il y a quand même pas de
colonne ouverte donc ça c'est bien aussi
et après concrètement làall les blancs
regrettent d'avoir jouer H4 si le pion
blanc était en H2 l'évaluation de la
position serait radicalement différente
ici ce pion va nous servir d'ancrage euh
pour pour attaquer et on pourrait se
dire oui dis-moi non non vas-y je t'en
prie finis ton je en train de me dire si
on fait un
coup d'attente je sais pas ce que va le
Jolet blanc et d'ailleurs je comprends
toujours pas quelle était son intention
Jean cavali est-ce que c'était pour
préparer F4 mais je ne sais pas mais si
on joue un coup d'attente on pourrait
dire sur G5 peut-être H5
pour garder le truc fermé mais peut-être
justuse cavalier F4 un truc comme
ça
libère libère ce fout et surprise on a
quand même l'ouverture de la colonne je
pense qu'on a pas envie immédiatement de
jouer cavalier F4 dans l'idée que on
aimerait bien pouvoir quand on bouge le
cavalier de D5 pouvoir le remplacer
assez rapidement si on compare la force
des pièces tu vois mon C D5 qui il
domine complètement le fou le fou des
deux donc j'ai quand même un peu de
temps avec les blanches j'ai un peu le
temps de peut-être d'améliorer la
position de mes pièces avant de proposer
cet échange de
cavalier je voulais te faire remarquer
notamment après un coup comme H5 bah que
maintenant bah les Noirs les Blancs ils
ont quand même des faiblesses ils ont le
pion H5 qui est faible le pion A5 qui
est faible le pion D4 qui est faible
donc sur du long terme donc c'est
Natacha la joueuse positionnelle qui
parle sur du long terme les Blancs ont
beaucoup trop de faiblesse qui seront
plutôt facilement attaquables par les
Noirs cavalier B8 qui C6 j'attaque le
pion des4 je fais pression sur
A5 mais oui après voilà je pense comme
je te disais que on a pas intérêt à se
lancer trop trop rapidement sur cavalier
F4 ça peut se préparer dans de
meilleures conditions non
puis ça ça me va je suis d'accord avec
toi et il y a un coup aussi que je
voulais quand même mentionner alors
est-ce que ici ou pas c'est le bon
moment mais c'est le coup F5
euh parce que en cas de repli bon on a
quand même des pions qui sont mélassant
C il y a pas toujours pas de colonne
ouverte mais à un moment les pions qui
vont avancer ils vont faire des dégâts
et en cas de prise c'est un changement
radical de structure mais ça ça ouvre la
position et potentiellement quand même
au
bénéfice bénéfice des Noirs donc ouis
une position ultra complexe avec toutes
les pièces sur sur les chi qui est juste
un échange un pion chacun qui ont été
échangé mais l'ordinateur adore les
noirs et plus on regarde plus nous aussi
donc c'est c'est quand Mme la bonne
nouvelle et surtout c'est d'autant plus
une bonne nouvelle que il y a pas si
longtemps avant
cavalier1 je crois qu'il avait tout son
temps la pendule il avait 1h34 et c'est
exactement ce qu'on ce qu'on disait
alors on a réussi à poisser Vincent
grand bien nous face on a parlé de ce
scénario exact où on joue 14 coups bon
on avait dit 15 mais là c'est 14 coups
de préparation sauf que on a blitzé on
n'est pas dedans et le premier coup hor
prépa c'est une grosse erreur et donc là
c'est exactement ce qui s'est passé dans
cette partie du prodige allemand de 19
ans et euh 4
jours j'ai appris par cœur la date de
naissance que tu nous as dit tout à
l'heure 15 novembre euh
2002 2004 2004 oui 19 ans n'importe quoi
euh
ok retour chez les filles
ouais allons voir allons voir les
joueuses attends qu'est-ce que je fais
allez on recommence par popo donc popo
quial est blanc elle était très bien
quand on l'avait quitté est-ce qu'elle
est toujours très bien ah un mauvais
coup de son adversaire c'est cool on
s'était quitté ici on avait parlé de cet
échange en B2 auquel on s'attendait fou
3 c'était le coup que tu avais suggéré
rock faut prend C4 on avait parlé de
cavalier D2 aussi mais visiblement pas
besoin de protéger le P4 parce que c'est
un mauvais coup alors reste à savoir
pourquoi c'est un mauvais
coup peut-être parce que tout ça c'est à
la maison et qu' un moment il faut
sortir ses pièces mais alors après les
échaces sont un jeu concret on vient de
donner notre pion
centrale qu'est-ce qu'on fait
maintenant et ben il y a un petit
qui se présente le thème du clouage ma
cher
yocha il av tellement de
condescendant de
commentateur mais le thème du CL sur la
colonne A mais
[Rires]
ou ça que tu peux me dire exactement oui
thème clouage et thème fourchette un
double thème en un seul coup menace et
donc ou menace B7 et menace prise en A7
donc on peut pas parer les deux menaces
et c'est si grave que ça
waouh la tu imagine tu laisses ton
adversaire avoir un pion un pion passé
protégé sur la
7e mais en fait j'ai l'impression que
c'est même même pas que ça c'est comment
on fait pour pas
perdre de piè juste parce que si on joue
prise on a le cavalier il faut attaquer
c'est
désagréable alors on n pas encorequ mais
je vois pas de thème
ouais c'est
désagréable je plus ou c'est
désagréable B6 donc là on est là c'est
la partie B6
il y a une menace il y a des autres
menaces qui sont alors potentiellement t
prend un C f d'ame
aussi ah bon là je crois que les Noirs
vont parer cette menace de tour 7 mais
c'est vrai si prise ça attaque la tour
et surprise prise on menace de faire
dame de deux manières différentes donc
il pourra pas parler les deux elle
pourra pas parler les de cavalier des 6
qui Fa regarder D6 qui protège la cas B7
et qui attaque le fou
C4 OK calculer oui donc c'est c'est le
coup critique
ouais puis on prend A7 et sur k prend C4
on peut peut-être jouer B8
l'autre aend aend est
possible tu veux prendre ok aend B bah
visiblement c'est le coup mais alors ah
oui parce que sur surprise on reprend
dame prend tour
ouais dame prend tour oui exact et tu
contrôles la cas pas ça parce que oupsi
a mais dame prend et ici c'est que un
échec et on a une tour de plus
oui uneour de plus ça devrait
aller ok donc c'est quand même chaud
alors prise en A7 prise en C4 prise en
B8 et a priori il y a pas d'autes coup
que cavalier prend dame donc ça ça
gagne
euh pris 7 si on prend pas en C4
peut-être qu' availler C6 cavalier D7 C
c'est6
ou on a plus de Mo mais non ouais on a
une bête en7 ouais alors après c'est
vrai que parfois on le perd cetion quand
même pour l'instant on a le F attaquer
on le bouge ok est-ce que
ouais non en fait
mc7
attends non
c'est la Jae dis que c'est totalement
gagant pour les blancs donc on va la
croire
euh humement je dis-moi mais en fait
l'autre difficulté des Noirs c'est
qu'ils n'ont pas bougé le fou C8 donc
les tours ne sont pas lié donc il y a
encore la possibilité de profiter par
exemple sur une prison à du clouage sur
après un coup comme il prend a 7 il y a
des thèmes de clouage sur la colonne 1
hm hm il permet de rajouter une pression
supplémentaire sur une pièce en a donc
oui petit rock alors peut-être que
d'ailleurs aller en C c'était pas le
plus malin mais par que c'est un coup
logique peut-être tourc1 ouais
bon du coup on regrette d'avoir mis la
dame ici mais
euh une dame 7 il y a absolument tout
qui est cloué quoi c'est ouais ok mais
c'est
je peux comprendre que que ça saute pas
aux yeux non plus que
P est vraiment fort et pas et pas jamais
vraiment prise
quoi donc c'est jouer B6 pas encore
joué mais c'est vrai que si c'est c'est
très tentant et si c'est fort il faut
que ça soit joué et donc là c'est le
coup et prise en à 7 avec le pion ne pas
avoir peur de la prise en en
C4 mais après bon Pauline prend son
temps pour rfléchir c'est c'est vrai
qu'elle nous a montré un un très haut
niveau de jeu sur ses parties sur les
parties précédentes et euh bon on la
sent plutôt en confiance elle prend son
temps elle elle calcule bien elle a
senti qu'il y a quelque chose à faire
ouais elle calcule bien elle a senti
qu'il y a quelque chose à faire vu
qu'elle s'est arrêté elle s'est posée
sur la
position ah oui moi je fais elle réfléch
clairement à ce coup là parce que sinon
c'est qu'est-ce qu'on joue si on joue
pas B6 on peut rockerin il y a un de moi
mais il y a forcément il y a forcément
du jeu bah d'ailleurs
l'ordi dit que c'est c'est pas forcément
moins fort ce qui est plutôt une bonne
nouvelle du coup parce que bon j'ai du
mal à l'imaginer jouer un coup autre que
B6 ou rock et a priori les deux
une position gagnante mais B6 ça rend
vraiment plus tangible l'avantage parce
qu'on a plus de pion de moins et il y a
le pion à 7 qui a une case de la
promotion dans la variante principale
qu'on a ditite alors que là on a
toujours un pion de moins
potentiellement si on commence à faire
n'importe quoi on a un pion central de
moins et on est mal mais en attend ah B6
joué et ben bravo ouais comme nous dit
yanut ouais B6 a été joué ok super ben
voyons comment surtout comme tu as dit
que un coup comme fou B7 directement B
PAF une de banane puis on prend la 7 et
ouais là c'est c'est la pièce
OK et ben cette bonne augure Mitra elle
était mal est-ce que c'est encore le cas
sûrement la question c'est à quel
point
alors c'est trop défétiste ah Z non non
mais ah bah ça va déjà mieux non alors
il s'est passé des choses était revenu
ouais
on s'était quitté par là E5 était joué
des5 on l'avait mentionné dame on
l'avait pas
mentionné c'était pour repasser la 3 ro
quand même plutôt une bonne nouvelle
parce qu'on voyait aussi des cas où on
narrivait pas à rocker avec les Noirs
donc au moins on l'a fait H4 visiblement
pas top H5 fou
C3 et l' n'aime pas
F5
mais F5 paraît assez particulier parce
qu'en fait le fou en C3 il est bloqué
par le P F5 alors pourquoi autoriser
mais je crois que c'est
TR je crois que c'est très concret il y
a cette menace qui existe avec sur G6
ensuite à
H5 attends est-ce que c'est donc
c'est-à-dire si on joue un coup euh bon
sur Mo A4 paraî non A4 ça paraît
complètement logique
ouais quand même ça mais là tuas est-ce
que tu as ah tu veux prendre est-ce que
tu as pu prend al non non je pense pas
que ça marche mais je regardais par cont
bien sûr il faut regarder
euh mais là je pense tuas juste ouais ça
Mar et en fait
Swan si on fait le bilan on a que tour
est fou et on se fait quand même
attaquer donc c'est ce tour des 4 en
fait qu'elle a voulu parer h tour des 4
ce tour des 4 si on bouge la
dame je sais pas là donc c'était ça
l'idée ah c'est juste un
échec mais oui c'est ça en fait c'est
juste un
échec l'ordinateur est cruel il prend et
il y a même pas d'échec
perpétuel par que je pense que c'est ça
qui qui l'a gêné alors
peut-être peut-être qu'ici on n'est pas
obligé de
faireine tuas la possibilité aussi de
jouer dame C7 au lieu de de dame C6
l'idée c'est que là si tu veux ne pas
faire r à jouer k D2 je peut-être qui
est possible ou pas dans cette position
non peut-être pas vu que le pion F est
cloué ok mais c'est chaud
ouais c'est hyper chaud c'est compliqué
de voir que tour D4 tour G4 en fait
c'est juste un échec c'est pas simple
à à
évaluer
ouais non mais après c'est bon c'est F5
c'est un coup qu'on joue avec regret
aussi hein parce que clairement dans les
CADR opposés bah voilà les Blancs jouent
à l'roi regarde à l'roi nous on do jouer
à l' dame on regarde à l' dame et chaque
coup qu'on fait nous à noir à l' roie
c'est un coup potentiellement
affaiblissant et c'est un coup qui ne
sert pas à attaquer le roi blanc donc
c'est un coup qu'on joue à regret donc
si elle l'a joué c'est vraiment qu'elle
penser alors visiblement à T que tour D4
tour G4 était plus grave qu'il ne l' en
réalité mais c'eston c'est vrai que le
côté mais c'est pas grave vas-y joue
tour des4 joue tour G4 joue même tour
prend G7 moi je m'en fiche je suis
sereine c'est fais ce que tu veux moi je
en attendant je joue ça et je gagne mais
donc
F5 mauvais coup prison F6 prison F6
prison F6 prison F6 à nouveau tour de
quand même et on en est là alors le fou
C8 n'a toujours pas joué oui et au final
tu jou tour g si tu joues tour G4 ou tu
sur un coup comme G6 tuas H5 ouais mais
oui donc là surtout pas pas plus de coup
de pion de devant le
roi chaque coup de pion c'est une
faiblesse et là les blancs on profit
tout de suite donc on protège avec la
tour mais on a encore ce fou C V ça
serait bien qui qui finisse par se
réveiller
[Musique]
euh le hérisson se réveille enfin
ouais mais là c'est c'est plus le Risson
tout mignon qui qui où tu vois le ventre
et puis il est comme ça avec ses petites
pâtes et ses yeux encore à maendormi
c'est il pique pas trop pour l'instant
surisson mais bon c'eston jamais à 4 à 3
ça peut venir vite et puis la petite
pique du hérisson là une fois qu'elle
arrive en à
3 euh ok bon en tout cas ça va mieux que
euh quand on l'avait quitté ça va
peut-être moins bien qu'il y a trois
coups mais bon c'est quand même pas si
mal au moins une partie une partie avec
trois résultats possibles même si
l'ordinateur préfère les
blancs Sophie
au 2èe échiquier la sextuple championne
de France à les pièces
blanches on avait parlé de cette
faiblesse en E5 on s'était
quitté par là d'AM de touc touc tour 1
met la tour sur la colonne fin libère
cette tour
h est-ce qu'on veut jouer roi h F4 pas
sûr est-ce qu'on veut jouer un coup
comme ça pour échanger ce fou et donc
libérer cette colonne
peut-être ce qui est certain c'est que
j'ai du mal à trouver un plan libérateur
pour les
noirs
et le fou F1 je vois que tuasas la
souris sur ou sur le pion B5 mais en
fait le fou F1 il vise le pion A6 ça
veut dire que si tu veux un jour jouer
B4 tuaibl encore plus ton pion à
d'ailleurs elle a fait le de oui pardon
de ce de ce plan ouais ben elle a joué
tour a C V et donc du coup la tour qui
protège 6 et maintenant sur la colonne C
alors que toute façon on aurait joué
avec tour B8 si on voulait jouer B4 donc
je crois que tu pour la raison que tu as
tu as expliqué elle veut juste pas jouer
avec B4 mais c'est vrai que du coup si
on n pas de perception on n pas de plan
souvent mais vas-y je te je te rends la
parole je t'avais interromp
oui oui c'est vrai que oui comme comme
tu étais en train de commencer dire si
on n pas de Percé de pion mais en fait
c'est c'est difficile tout d'un coup ben
de de d'ouvrir la position et d'avoir un
plan
entre guillemets de de jeu ouis dans la
position avec les noirs on a
l'impression que les noirs sont plus
dans une situation défensive
d'attente attentive et de réaction au
plan des blancs donc on est toujours
dans une situation où les blancs Sophie
est confortable elle va améliorer sa
position petit à petit elle a
des les noirs ont des faiblesses sur le
long terme ils ont ce pion E7 ils ont le
pion
A6 et donc ben en fait c'est très bien
parce que très très bien son adversaire
avec 18 minutes à la pendule donc pour
jouer 22 coups ouais donc Sophie
tranquille pour le moment tranquille oua
ouais ouais c'est
euh c'est agréable très AGR très
difficile à jouer et ça c'est depuis le
début en faitin c'est la position là
elle est pas du tout surprenante à
partir
d'ici à partir du chat qu' allit
prendre5 c'est la position ou le type de
position auquel on s'attendait
totalement
et et donc maintenant l'avantage
visiblement ACC crru d'après
l'ordinateur et en pratique c'est
toujours les mêmes problèmes comme on le
disait on veut quasiment jamais jouer E6
avec la noir en cas r prend E6 et il y a
pas de bonne recapture chaque recapture
d'une pièce ou du pion F engendre de
nouvelles faiblesses donc c'est pas du
tout une amélioration sépare de son pion
arriéré mais pour secret de nouvelle
faiblesse et donc c'est très difficile à
jouer avec les noir surtout que comme tu
l'as dit le mieux c'est sûrement de rien
faire mais ça humainement on n arrive
pas à rien faire on n'arrive pas à rien
faire l'ordi il peut juste attendre et
puis pendant que les Blancs consolident
la position alors je sais pas qu'on va
jouer tranquillement un petit coup de H3
la tour moi elle doit protéger à 5 mais
peut-être même H4 à un moment un petit
coup de prophylactique de roi peut-être
voir ce qu'on fait avec le fou est-ce
qu'on le met ici est-ce qu'on le met là
est-ce qu'on prépare F4 et donc ne rien
faire pendant que l'adversaire a plein
d'idées c'est trop difficile et souvent
on finit par jouer un coup comme eussi
et c'est là où l'ORD dit s'affolle et
nous dit qu'on aurait mieux fait
d'attendre on passe à premère jquier
ou ou
oui
donc
TCC et TC alors ou là l'ordi aime
beaucoup la position de P on était ici
ah non elle a joué prend c'était le coup
qu'on avait mentionné parce que
potentiellement ça gag un pion mais on
avait dit que c'était pas bon du
tout trop trop dangereux sur a le RO enc
en plus maime maim chagve nous avait
rejointe et eu euh expliqué que ici il y
avait du cavalier B5 qui était
euh ou vraiment dangereux mais donc
heureusement peut-être il des pr 4ement
c'était pas le mieux H4 F5 un bon coup
fou C8 C B5 ouis donc là on voit t tous
les coups blancs qui sont des coups
dynamiques qui prennent l'initiative à
chaque coup à une pièce va vers l'avant
et entraîne de nouvelles menaces ro
cavalier C7 un bon coup cavalier
D5 là on regrette vraiment d'avoir
capturé C option tour à 8 bon al
évidemment pas de match nul mais la tour
est en prise c'est le fou qui vient C7
et non pas le cavalier dame G5 alors
matériellement toujours un pon de plus
pour les Noirs mais si les blancs le
veulent
ils peuvent déjà le regagner par fou D6
suivi de fou pr
C5 alors attention fou D6 tour8 fou
prend C5 on a peut-être tour prend4 en
profite du fait que le soit cloué et
tutre peut pas le manger immédiatement
un se vous dépeuplé
ou C c'est une fourch m' expliquer le
clouage tout à l'heure moi je vais
t'expliquer la fourchette nana
merci j'aime bien parce qu'on se
complète pardon j'aime bien on se
complète
dans chacune son
domaine on verra qui qui maîtrise de nos
deux l'enilade qui
maîtrise qu'est-ce qui reste aussi le
coin intermédiaire
allez objectif de thèm chacune d'ici la
la fin de de la journée donc dam G5 on
est là ouais alors la jauge est vraiment
bah affiche gagnant pour les blancs hein
on va pas même pas parler d'avantage à +
2,60 c'est c'est gagnant
mais ça reste quand même compliqué pour
l'instant donc
ouais on espère que que les Noirs
puissent trouver des ressources de toute
façon est-ce
[Musique]
que sur F6 on a F H3 aussi ça c'est
peutêtre marrant
ou d'un coup le le fou qui a joué
rejouer qui se retrouve horrible en C8
et libéré après
F6 cela dit je suis pas certaine de ce
qu'on là c'est quoi le prochain coup
c'est tour
je pense que
enfin déjà fou des6 gagne gagnant une
qualité je pense que ça peut être le
plus simple pour les
blancs h parce
qu'après attends d'ailleurs fou D6 a été
joué hein fou D6 a été joué ou par les
joue allemandes fou D6 a été joué oui
c'est le coup
for en fait toute la question euh résite
sur fait est-ce qu'après cavalier C7
tour prend E4 est-ce qu'on peut avoir
suffisamment de contrejeu je pense pour
euh pour la tour vu mais là c'est une
tour parce que si on joue ça c'est une
qualité mais du coup on on se retrouve
avec la pièce
passive si on joue t tour pr 4 c'est une
tour mais du coup on a peut-être du
jeu bon cela dit
[Musique]
euh je vois pas trop l'attaque de Ch
une tour c'est cher une tour c'est très
cher après un coup comme F pr
F5 on joue à la CASP
ok vas-y go
girl c'est ton domaine
là peuttre
Mme si on joue
vraiment voir un truc comme ça non là je
donne la dame AE a aïe a a
a j'ai failli me me prendre une nouvelle
tactique euh ah mais non c'est
math vas-y vas-y
joue
euh mais non mais je fais dame F2
échec et je pense que ça doit être dam F
ouais ok ah oui donc en fait c'est c'est
pour ça qu'il faut aller en C2
ici je contrôle ça et donc là-dessus il
y a toujours le même thème Taure 1 ne
gagne enfin g la dame mais perd le roi
ok on préfère les dames
non chacune s
goût c'est je sais pas ce que tuess ce
que tu essayes de N dire mais
euh pas de jugement pas de jugement euh
ouais c'est toujours marrant cette
calculer un coup plus loin C ou ne pas
ne pas s'arrêter trop tôt
ok bon bah à voir mais en tout cas euh
bon dilemme dilemme si on joue si on
s'attend quand même à ce tour8 qu' C7 et
donc si on joue ça c'est triste parce
que là on a une qualité de moins que une
qualité de moins entre guillemets mais
on a aucune
compensation là on a des compensations
mais c'est pas les qualité c'est une
tour après qu'elle est prend vite donc
ouais objectivement ça
pu donc si on fait le bilan très bien
chez popo un Mitra on va dire compliqué
plutôt avantage blanc très bien enfin ou
bien
chez chez Sophie ici
obactivement gagnant pour les blancs
mais rien n'est fait et donc c'est un
match très équilibré ils sont grands
maintenant ils sont grands ouais plus ou
moins mais fraess par exemple il fait
tellement jeune qu'on croit qu'il est
mais en fait il est adulte il est adulte
il y a que marquan ou qui est encore qui
est encore jeune ouais
mais alors non Maxime à les blanc toc TC
je le mets également sur le petit
échiquier cette carocane alors est-ce
que les dames ont été changées oui ah
mais il y a eu a B3 on naimait pas ça
prend B3 on aimit ah oui mais parce que
là il avait pas le choix ok en fait les
dames on été échangé mais plus tard ici
fou des v ah quel artiste donc si tu
veux échanger la dame avec les Blancs ok
mais bon courage pour protéger ah il y a
un autre
thème B3 je protège je m'attendait à 5
mais en fait c'est pas à 5
t
le thème du clouage merci le thème du
clouage j'prends
vite tu es une très bonne prof tu vas
prendre clâge tout de suite
ok donc
is ça c'est joli quandme F8 c'est c'est
le coup de grand maître c'est le coup de
classe du coup F4 l'ordi n'aime pas du
tout mais paraît pas bête parce que
c'est vrai que ce pion F3 de toute façon
moi je préférais l'avoir en F2 ça c'est
clair ça ça éviterait de se prendre qu'
prend5 mais maintenant qu'il a bougé ah
autant qu' qu'il soit actif quoi mais
cavalier F7 cavalier F3 et donc on
expliquait que en cas de prise en B3
mettons ici on reprend non pas du pion
parce que l'ouverture de la colonne A ne
sert pas grand-chose le pion noir est en
A6 et en revanche les pions sont faibles
on reprend du cavalier et puis là on
peut même se diriger en C5 ça peut être
sympa pour taper sur ces pions mais
maintenant que le cavalier et en F3
prise en B3 à tempo et
[Musique]
euh ouais ça ça a l'air pas mal pour les
Noirs ça fait vraiment penser à une
Française de rêve ce qui est en fait une
Française de rêve c'est quand la
carocane se passe bien c'est une
Française de rêve en tout cas dans la
varand d'avance et donc là c'est ça fait
vraiment penser à ça c'est peut-être pas
là où où euh ces combats positionnel sur
des structures très fermées c'est pas
forcément là où Maxime la garde arrive à
exprimer le mieux son son talent
tactique
ouais oui c'est un c'est un très très
fort joueur d'attaque on a déjà vu des
parties où il lançait des attaques
explosives avec
sacrifice on est sur du purement
positionnel donc ouais doneno a réussi à
l'amener là où il voulait ouais et tu
sais ça me fait penser à en fait la
partie de Jul qu'on va voir dans un
instant
où après fouétis on voit les trois
pièces mineures le fou et les deux
cavaliers attaqué là aussi de manière
concentrique le pion faible des
blanc face à de fous cavalier et donc ce
fou cas blanche lui il peut pas
participer à cette bataille donc
d'ailleurs peut-être est-ce qu'on doit
jouer un coup comme fou de 3 fou prend
F5 pour enlever un attaquant ça serait
quand même une grosse concession pu on
reste avec le mauvais fou on reste très
passif mais au moins si ça peut éviter
de perdre le pion ça peut être
bien F6 aussi ça peut préparer G5 et
donc potentiellement c'est toute la
chaîne de PION blanche qui qui saute et
même le roi derrière il peut après fou
B6 on peut tout à fait envisager même
des che m mat tout de
suite on se prend on met le roi en Hin
après un échange comme ça juste pour
montrer un MATD puis on se prend
cavalier G3 échec et ma avec le fou qui
contrôle qui contrôle g évidemment c'est
du MATD mais c'est c'est pour dire que
tout ça c'est dans la la case 4
potentiellement si un cavalier arrive on
sait pas trop comment ils Bont dire un
jour bref je suis d'accord complètement
d'accord avec toi sur une fois que le
fou arrive en B6 avec cette diagonale A7
ouverte et la colonne
h on n'est pas non plus hyper
serein notre roi notre roi en gé avec
les Blancs ouais ça c'est la très
mauvaise nouvelle
euh alors évidemment l'ordinateur reste
relativement confiant pour les blancs ma
0,50 mais
si l'homme en
forme le buteur de cette équipe de
France
mixte se met à perdre avec les pièces
blanches dans le moneytime ça serait
assez horrible mais dans tous les cas
peut-être même pas grave pour l'équipe
parce queil y avait d'autres parties
prometteuses pour les blancs euh pour
les blancs pour les Bleus pour les
blancs pour les Bleus
euh alors notre tech fress qu'est-ce que
ça donne son Gambi
dame
au trè é chic
la les
noir mais non j'ai pas réussi à mettre
fress alle fress VI
là on sétait quitté par là on avait
expliqué que tous les pions étaient
faibles à le pion à 3 et 4 pas
bête il est moins faible protégé par la
dame la dame se recentralise
euh attends qu'est-ce qui se passe
là-dessus tu ma 3
juste j'aime pas avoir pas de C pour
Madame mais là on arrive
à ça c'est un coup non
oh
oh ah non il y a il y aura dame de
6 bon et ben ok B6 sans crin tour B5
bravo te fresque à calculer fou D3
H6 cavalier de C il y a eu des
échanges et on en est
là al une structure qui a qui a bien
changé quand même après prendre les quat
hein ce petit coup je suis pass assé
vite mais ça a bouleversé la structure
le pion C3 n'est plus isolé mais il est
arriéré sur la colonne ouverte c'est pas
beaucoup mieux le pion des5 est toujours
isolé mais il est plus sur une colonne
ouverte et ça c'est mieux euh le pionin
on en parlait comme d'une faiblesse
quand il était en à 3 mais maintenant
c'est lui qui va s'échanger pour
infliger un nouveau P isolé au noir
après il reste pas beaucoup de
pièces je pense que ça
va je pense que ça va pour le noir
ou un équilibre au niveau des faiblesses
oui on
peéqu de
Fabl blan quand même totement
ob bien les blanc mais après est-ce que
c'est suffisant pour pouvoir gagner la
partie
OK yanck yanck il était dans le chat
mais sinon il est sur
place le sélectionneur de l'équipe de
France il est sur place
et il sélectionné maintenant il
secondde mainten il secondde et parfois
il vient dans le
chat diminuer qu' doit être en gros
stress tu
Méton il vient se détendre avec nous
tu MT c'est stressant pour les joueurs
et évidemment mais encore plus quand on
quand on est que spectateur spectatrice
capitaine et cetera ou on a tout le
stress sans sans avoir le focus entier
qui qui permet d'évacuer ce stress alors
place à Jul Moussard qui a les blancs je
vois que ces pièces sont un peu ont un
peu quitté
là la cible en5 pour s'orienter vers
l'roie alors on était parti à C2 B5 bien
joué parce qu'on expliquit à quel point
C C4 était grave B5 c'est toujours un
peu bizarre de pousser ses pions mais là
c'était nécessaire et du coup Jul
switch change de
plan et place ses cavaliers en direction
du roi
adverse tin je suis pas tout à
fait certain du but de ce coup que jeid
c'est juste que quand il joue cavalier
F5 prends F5 prend F5 la tour est sur
une colonne
oui d'accord ok
tour
F5 parce que c'est juste ça l'idée
mais
alors mais après c'est vrafin ouais
cavali F5 les ns sont pas obligés de
prendre F5 donc c'est la difficulté on
peut imaginer un coup de de repli de la
dame mais attention
faut faut quand même voir comment on
protège au 5 donc après c'est concret
aussi est-ce qu'on
joue comme ça pour enlever ce fou qui
met quand même la pression
[Musique]
h mais bon ça ça donne des ça donne des
cases parce que par bon là maintenant
c'est vrai qu'on s'est éloigné de la
case C4 mais on peut on peut y revenir
c'est pas forcément définitif
donc je sais pas B c'est un coup qu'on
regrette aussi en
final ordinateur aime
bien
bon est-ce que sur attend
B4 j'essaie de refaire
marcher problème c'est que quand tu
joues D44 qui qui est faible alors je
sais pas à quel point
c'est c'est embêtant peut-être tu
reprend 4 tout
simplement alors si je prends ah oui non
C H 4 n'est pas on a un problème
cavalier
H4 concrètement j'arrive pas
ah mais de moins en fait
oui oui ça c'est relou
et un pion doublé mais
ouais mais en tout cas oui c'est ça
prendre en
considération
5 après bon peut-être juste fout de deux
aussi parce que le coup
B4 il y a plus de pression sur5 mais
c'est un coup qu'on regrette aussi comme
on l'a
dit bon l' aime bien les Noirs mais
ça me paraît juste compliqué et
équilibré comme position et notre by
alors est-ce qu'il va scorer avec les
Noirs parce que on adorait sa
position il y a quelques temps qu'est-ce
que ça donne cette ce gambidam accepté
qui se transforme un
peu en
semilave je su en train de regarder la
position je suis désolée je regarde je
garde quand même un il sur les partie
des filles
[Musique]
et la partie de démter l'évaluation est
revenue à égal wouh Elisabeth P n'a pas
trouvé le moyen de de prendre l'avantage
OK et ben juste après juste après ouais
on pourra jumper là-dessus donc on
s'était quitté ici grand Ron joué dame 2
roi B8 profil si cavalier F3 donc quel
quel aveut d'échac de ce cavalier E1
hein c'était vraiment le le premier coup
hor prépa et l'ordinateur a tout de
suite puni bon on n pas vu l'idée vu que
le cavalier est revenu en F3 il y a eu
ce F5 qu'on avait
mentionné prise en passant et non pas
coup illégal je vois la mention les gens
le voient pas mais donc petit point
informatif de Chess.com qui nous
explique après que tu nous as expliqué
le clouage et que j'ai expliqué je sais
plus la fourchette c'est la prise en
passant priseon F6 et maintenant la
colonne G est ouverte et conjointement
avec ce fou B7 une tour en G8 pourrait
faire des gros dégâts sur le P G2 et sur
le rock de manière
générale ça a l'air très facile à jouer
pour les noirs et on sait vraiment pas
quoi faire avec les Blancs on voit pas
le début d'un contrejeu sur le roi
noir je sais même pas à quel point le
coup prophylactique était nécessaire
mais ça sera jamais inutile on peut
imaginer qu'un jour un prend un jour
lointin coup ça fait pas Échec un prend
C toutun coup ça fait pas Échec donc le
roi est mieux placé en B8 si considère
que ça vaut un
tempo grand bien en on va le
croire je suis en train de regarder un
coup qui en fait est juste
catastrophique je regardais les coups
comme cavalier des de par exemple
cavalier e D2 aveidée je menace ce pion
6 et je menace ce pion C4 mais en fait
le problème c'est que le cavalier D2
déjà il bloque le contrôle du Fou C1 de
la case F4 et et ouais et libère le fou
on joue tour G8 cavalier F4 c'est c'est
juste la
catastrophe même t pr G2 ah non pas du
tout si si t prend G2 aussi il y a tout
qui ah ouais non parce que au début moi
je voulais juste faire ma fourchette
c'est moi la spécius fourchette mais
j'avais pas vu de en fait c'est pas
grave ah c'est ça ah c'est génial on a
réussi à placer même si tu te trompes
même si je me trompe ah c'est génial ah
c'est génial
euh bon on peut rien faire on peut pas
interposer quelqu'un
sur sur la la diag
c'est
atro on peut pas bon cavalier de de on
va juste juste t G8 et puis
voilà il y a même pas de coup ah c'est
génial et as Vista ça c'est mat matant
ouais trop beau trop
beau oh non oh non mqueen ah non c'est
vrai le clouage le
clouage je pensais pas que ça te
servirait autant mais tu vois non mais
moi je après tu es une excellente prof
mais je suis une bonne élève aussi tu
vois l'application direct de la leçon
non non non ah oui je oui très très bon
élève je suis d'accord donc donc by est
bien mieux que N mal
Maxime la garde au 4e donc ça fait plus
que compensé Laurent je suis assez
confiante Jul aussi donc un match très
chaud mais qui se présente pas pas mal
pas mal pour les Bleus quoi c'est un peu
le bilan de ce match non qu'est-ce que
tu en dis
ouais je suis complètement d'accord avec
toi c'est pour le
moment les Bleus sont les Bleus ont le
liad après ben comme tu disais on arrive
un peu sur dans le on arrive bientôt
vers les eight notes
donc tout peut t' arriver tout peut
t'arriverarriver allez un petit coup
fill alors à chaque fois on faisait 4 3
2 1 est-ce qu'on ferait pas un le 3 4
parce que tu mentionnais la partie de de
DD
ouais oui on peut on peut oui allez
allez là je compte très bien à l'endroit
à
l'envers donc l'ordinateur disait que ça
n'allait pas du tout qu'on allait perdre
une qualité F D6 elle a dit à B6 on
avait pas mentionné ce coup ah ouais qui
a perdu une
qualité pourquoi ne pas la Perre comme
ça pour retrouver un
fou un fou billesque en
B7 et là coup tour et rien n cl parce
qu'on a un pion pour la qualité donc les
blan n' pas vraiment d'avantage matériel
mais après
cavalier5 est-ce que je peux prendre en
D4
réflex ouais tu peux on prend
des4 tu peux tout à fait est
il y a des histoires sur la la case 3
mais pour
l'instant pr 5 ne va
[Musique]
pas
h Pr
ça c'est une menace avec peut-être même
plutôt que cavalier 3 dame 3 écheac
c'est peut-être encore plus grave pas
certaine
[Musique]
h bon c'est une bonne nouvelle ça tu
d'un coup l'ordi ça faait tellement mais
ça on l'avait quand même dit hein que
l'ordi ça faait énormément mais que en
pratique ça resté très compliqué euh et
en plus elle a l'avantage la pendule
dis-moi c'est ce que j'allais dire elle
a l'avantage à la pentil démonter c'està
dire que tout d'un coup ben la joueuse
allemande ben réalise
que H elle a peut-être pas pris les
meilleures décisions donc là on est dans
un match clé un match important donc et
euh d'une position où on sent qu'on peut
faire la différence tout d'un coup on se
retrouve dans une position où on est
plus très très confortable on est moins
bien autant euh j'imagine la joue la
joueuse allemande qui doit commencer à à
stresser quand même un peu dans cette
situation and on sent que ça nous nous
échae ouais ouais ouais c'est c'est
horrible et puis on sait pas à quel
point alors après évidemment ici il y
avait la jauge he donc nous on disait
que c'était plus compliqué que ce que la
jauge laissait penser mais les joueuses
ne l'ont pas donc sûrement qu'on sent
avec les blancs qu'il y a quelque chose
mais on voit pas on tourne on tourne en
rond dans S calcul et et tout d'un coup
on prend le matériel dit que ça doit
aller et puis en
fait en fait ça va déjà plus trop alors
après c'est vrai aussi pour le petit
avantage Corel noir d'après
l'ordinateur c'est tellement compliqué
que qu'il va y avoir spoiler il va y
avoir des erreurs dans cette partie
encore qui en fera le plus ou peut-être
qu'une seule joueuse en fera mais il va
il va qui fera la dernière erreur
surtoutou fera l'avant dernière erreur
du coup qui fera l'avantdernière erreur
comme disait Tart cover et
ouais c'est une position trop compliquée
pour que un joueur humain une chose
humaine ne fasse pas d'Ar
juste trop de Ch ok un coup assez
logique dans cette position et qui n'est
pas mauvais enfin qui évite de rentrer
dans les complications comme à la place
de cavalier E5 ça peut être juste tout 8
on garde la protection sur le pion D4 et
on met une tour sur sur la faiblesse E4
ça peut être tout à fait cohérent la
jauge à à
yoyoté ouais c'est pas mal c'est le
genre de coup que pourrait jouer c'est
pas mal avec l'idée là PE
reprendreou et tout va
bien moi j'aime bien puis en plus ça
c'est une manace non oui oui oui c'est
un coup plutôt
tout
ça exact menace de pion en un on reste
sur les basiques parfois les basiques
font gagner ouais fondamentx B quand tu
regardes les parties de Carls he c'est
ouais alors moi en ce moment il gagement
en ce moment mais euh mais ouais ok ben
du coup on a vu notre première échquier
on va voir la deuxème
ouais ouais ouais faisant un petit tour
rapide des joueuses françaises et après
peut-être un petit bre avant l'in
ouais alors
Sophie on aime bien sa position depuis
l'ouverture en fait fou 3 adore son
choix d'ouverture ah mais regarde
regarde on avait parlé de pardon je t'ai
coupé de coup mais oui je te disais oui
oui je disais on adorait son ouverture
on a de on adoré le choix d'ouverture un
petit avantage euh un petit avantage sur
la duré sur la longueur comme on dit un
massage en bonnet du forme et donc on
pas de risque on disait que le truc le
plus difficile chez les Noirs c'est que
il y a pas vraiment de plan que le seul
bon plan c'est d'attendre
paivement en espérant que les Blancs
puissent pas trop améliorer leur
position petit à petit même si c'est ce
que
Sophie veut faire on parlait de la
possibilité B4 seulement on disait deux
choses le pion ass
très
faible le F lui met la pression dessus
et la tour mal placé en C vite et donc
là elle s'est dit il faut absolument un
plan
donc mettons la
T8 le pion et peut-être qu'un jour je
vais réussir à faire à faire du
B4 fou B6 plus de B4 possible on
pourrait prendre ce pion tout
simplement la T est revenue là
et
OK et en fait c'est alors un plan qui
m'avait absolument pas
euh j'avais absolument qu'on avait
absolument pas envisagé Sophie en joue
en tour AC1 en fait elle peut elle veut
pousser C4 et elle veut jouer sur la FIB
S6 je pense elle veut aller pour C4 et
ensuite jouer sur la faiblesse du pion
en A6 et si elle arrive à gagner le pion
A6 mais en fait a juste un pion a passer
éloigné un peu comme dans la partie de
Paline qui est juste monstrueux et c'est
vrai que c'est assez surprenant comme
plan un plan pas du tout j'avais
absolument pas envisagé mais qui a l'air
tout à fait
ouais ouais non c'est vrai que parfois
même on voit
euh un coup de B3 aussi B là je pense
c'est pas du tout de l'idée mais h c'est
vrai qu'on a une majorité en faitin
c'est c'est on parle souvent l'attaque
de minorité justement jouer B4 pour
infliger un pion faible et tout mais
parfois même souvent d'ailleurs un jouet
là où on a une majorité de pion c'est
c'est pas bête
h ok donc C4
envisager et fou D7 estce que c'est pour
aller en B5
après
peut-être c'est possible ouais sur
protection du pion
B5 mais même si le fou va en B5 au final
même si on
échange monstrue ch sur un truc comme
çaci on échange et le pion à 5 à un
moment il va faire la différence et puis
tu vois si on arrive à jouer un coup par
exemple comme comme B4 finalement on a
un pion passé éloigné protégé ouais
c'est c'est bien quand un pion a plein
d'objectifs comme ça il est passé il est
éloigné il est protégé euh il est beau
il est mignon c'est plus un objectif
c'est c'est ça
euh enfin en tout cas ça reste une une
for les Noirs ne peuvent pas transposer
dans une finale de pion roi et pionû euh
voilà donc en fait c'est c'est quelque
chose que les Noirs vont devoir toujours
avoir à l'œil et qui ront des
transpositions dans des finales
perdantes donc c'est hyper hyper
important alors je me dis aussi
peut-être en plus de s B5 qui donne un
pion pass protégé éloigné euh il y a
aussi l'idée de faire E6 malgré tout moi
je l'aime pas depuis le début mais c'est
peut-être l'idée de replier le fou pour
pas qu'il se retrouve par exle en qure
pris pour PR6 pas qu'il se retrouve tout
seul en F5 et pouvoir jouer fouser 6 un
jours mais mais j'aime vraiment pas
cette idée en fait et d'ailleurs
concrètement ici on peut pas jouer au 6
parce que on va juste prendre les tout
cassé donc une autre idée qui me vient
en tête c'est de préparer la poussée C4
c'est par exemple de jouer B3 C4 ouvrir
la colonne B et ensuite jouer tour B1
bouger le fou et jouer tour B6 et allit
faire pression d'une autre façon sur le
pion à 6 ok bon admettons là-dessus
ça donc là peut-être qu'on on a la
possibilité de jouer C4 je pense c'est4
puis on prend
ouais on est sûr que ça c'est parce que
là je me suis débarrassé de ça ah tu
reprends là
ouais je regardais la prise en B5 la
prise croisée j'ai oublié
euh les croisés Yosa
ouis les genoux oua ligament je me suis
fait les croiser ok
euh on pourit oui ça pourrait être un un
vocabulaire de joueurs d'échec punaise
dans la partie je me suis fait les
croiser ben
non tu tu t'es blessé au j croiser ou
mais non c'est juste que j'ai pris pris
un D5 je m'attendais à ça et puis en
fait c'est prend B5 les croisé et là
c'est à TR si évidemment c'est prend D5
c'est at TR pour les pour les blancs
d'avoir échangé le pion C contre le le
pion e non non disait que c'était la
faiblesse des Noirs depuis le début mais
c'est prend B5 et les Noirs vont se
retrouver avec des pions certes passés
mais doublé isolé pas terrible et nous
on va avoir notre pion passer protéger
éloigner tout ça tout ça en à
5 bon et ben B AUG ouais de très très
bon augur pour euh pour les blancs et
euh bien s avec cette écart
est
ble et cet écart de temps à la pendule
quand même qui est 7 minutes pour euh
pour les joueus allemande pour jouer 18
coups c'est juste énormissime alors
metra ça allait pas du tout puis c'était
compliqué puis c'était pas
terrible c'est une Sicilienne ultra
complexe
elle a les noir Mitra on s qué par là on
av expliqué surtout pas jouer G6 parce
que ça donne un point d'ancrage au blanc
on défend le pion sans créer nouvelle
faiblesse on part
h6 il faut quand même essayer de se
développer à un moment
A4 attaque dame C4 attaque
tourage4 c'est pas mat le roi
s'échappe mais du coup elle ne fait pas
écheac tout de suite elle joue d'abord
tour à
5 que c'est
compliqué alors
là mais tout à l'heure on disait qu'on
s'en moquait mais on va peut-être pas
s'en moquer à chaque fois quand
même à noter que damf échec ou c'est
juste un échec ouis là il y a pas de
suite du tout et il y a plus d'échec
ensite ah c'est c'est marrant ENF c'est
marrant du coup non parce que ça se
passe pas très bien pour pour mais mais
c'est original on va dire
ce de prévoir ce roi des deux et puis en
fait il se passe rien le cavalier
contrôle tout il y a pas d'autre
échac mais donc et tu as vu cette pièce
en C8
ouais ben ouais ouais lui on en parle
depuis long C en C8
H lui on en parle depuis longt après
ouais après tour agg4 on a le seul coup
possible pour protéger la pour empêcher
la prison G7 c'est de jouer tour G5 hein
il y a pas d'autre choix
est-ce que ro c'est un
coup je va me faire
mat tu vas te faire mat après tout
reprends
G7 oui i
ouious tu t' encore fait
mat donc on peut pas laisser prendre7
pas comme tout à l'heure tour G5 mais
donc le problème c'est que on prend et
on joue à 6 non non là là ça va là le
cavalier va vraiment être en prise je
dis n'importe quoi ça y est ça y est
c'est l'heure de la
pause on va allez ciao non non non non
on va Reger cette partie puis salelle de
popo avant de faire la
pause euh mais donc ici là il faut quand
même passer un tempsou
se défendre
non oui il faut protéger le cavalier D4
alors on a pas envie de le bouger de
cette case parce que il est juste
magnifique il est magnifqueçon il en
prise partout où il
va donc la seule on a la possibilité par
exemple de jouer des coups comme dame 5
le problème c'est qu'on
a maintenant la fable de la première
peut-être a dame F1
[Musique]
D2
r vololant à la
Jul que c'est
compliqué mais d 5 c'est clairement un
coup candidat et tu disais un autre coup
c'est TR tout simplement c'est TR je
protège le
cavalier et ce qui est dur dans la
position c'est de se dire ben on met un
petit peu le le pied sur le frein
oui temporairement
oui il faut passer un coup de défense
avec avec les Blancs
ouais ok
euh bon je je me suis faite attaquer par
un chat aussi mais il y a un chat chez
toi trop bien euh Pasu bah c'est charade
je pas je pense que tu la connais
charade le chat peut-être tu l'as déjà
vu il y a longtemps je pense pas l'avoir
déjà vu non je penseavoir jamais je
pense pas est vieille he 18 ans charad
ah oui ouais mais bon
de fou oh oui et de
sagesse donc ok c'est très compliqué à
priori si les Blanc joue tous les
meilleurs
coups Joséphine gagnerait mais la
position tellement complexe qu'on
s'attend pas à ce qu'elle joue tous les
meilleurs coups après est-ce que Mitra
va reconîre des erreurs et cetera on
verra mais c'est pas du tout aussi perdu
que la barre d'évaluation le laisserait
penser
donc c'est c'est charade le chat mais
c'est pas c'est pas c'est pas ma chatte
c'est c'est celle de mon
ami donc assez parler et et toi en fait
elle va bien minette minette on l'a pas
vu encore elle est là mais si elle était
sur mes genoux de C ah
okci elle va bien
c'est un chat heureux c'est un chat
toulousin
exactement un chat qui marque les essais
qui
alors popo notre popo qui a joué B le
coup clé de tout à
l'heure non c'est pas du tout ce que je
voulais faire allez dernière partie
avant la pause Yosa donne tout ce que tu
as dans 2 minutes tu as un
euh
là on avait parlé de ce
B6 punissant C PR4 profitant de clouage
du pion A7 menace B7 fourchette dame 7
etub prend à 7 cavalier C6 on a rétabli
l'égalité matérielle et on a ce pion à
une case de la promotion alors il y a un
monde où on finit par per ce pion et ça
serait horrible mais ça va être
difficile parce que la tour à8 pas
protégée à cause du fous C V serait
souvent source de problème pour les
noirs des petits placements de pièces
fou B6 E5 pour finir par
se se libérer le le fou C8 mais c'est
lent tour C met la pression sur lesqu
C66 oui menace fous
C5 att6 et menace F C5 une petite
enfilade euh ouais ouais non mais tu
fais bien le dire parce que du coup sur
F ça protège en se développant B fou C5
abandon donc dam
F6 fou D3 pour aller en 4 voilà le fou
il va tour C vite alors c'est marrant
parce que la position est toujours aussi
avantageuse qu'après PR7 même peut-être
plus d'après la jauge mais justement ça
ça pas fond mentalement changé il y a eu
des améliorations de pièces de part et
d'autrre mais il y a toujours l'égalité
matérielle il y a toujours ce pion en
ass à la fois très fort monusement fort
c'est la raison pour laquelle les blancs
sont gagnant d'près
l'ordinateur mais qui s pas pas traduit
par un gain de pièce par exemple donc
c'est pas encore décidé toujours gagnant
mais pas du tout pas du tout terminé
cette partie
encore oui oui oui ouais tout à fait
d'accord il faut il faut trouver le
moyen de de de concrétiser de de
transformer de transformer cet avantage
écrasant positionnel avec ce pion à 7
trouver un moyen de gagner du matériel
tout simplement pour que la position
devienne gagnante mal du couloir et puis
on verra après ce qu'il en est mais
c'est c'est vrai que c'est c'est aussi
frustrant quand on sait que alors
évidemment il y a pas il y a pas la
jauge en enfin en direct à côté de la
lchquier mais on sait qu'on est gagnante
mais on aime on préfère quand ça s
traduit par un ponade de plus par une
qualité de plus par quelque chose de
très concret là ça ça reste encore un
peu un peu abstrait cet avantage oui ou
c'est vrai ouis les joueurs d'échec ne
sont pas des poètes il faut il faut du
concret il faut du concret alors si on
fait le un petit bilan de ce match
français Allemagne chez les joueuses on
a popo on espère une future euh victoire
Mitra c'est compliqué mais pas du tout
perdu Sophie très bien et did après être
passé par la case perdante c'est
maintenant compliqué voir avantageux
donc là encore un match qui n'est pas du
tout joué mais qui tourne à l'avantage
des Bleus
donc on se
retrouve après la pause pour suivre les
les Denes là on voit encore 15 minutes
chacune donc d'ici des minutes ça sera
vraiment tendu et et et passionnant très
bien OK et bien su tout de suite quel
est le meilleur moyen de suivre
n'importe quel événement échikien Surp
du monde au tournois des candidats en
passant par le speed chess ou les
titleesday
chess.com/eventsc tous les plus grands
tournois d'échec se déroule en
présentiel ou en ligne vivez et
comprenez en direct les parties des
meilleurs joueurs de la planète avec les
commentaires en français de nos experts
notre moteur d'analyse l'explorateur
d'ouverture et les tables base retrouver
toutes les infos essentielles comme le
programme les horaires des rondes les
prix les résultats
[Musique]
les
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et nous
revoilà pour cette ex note des deux
matchs France Allemagne au Championnat
d'Europe des nations on reprend avec les
joueurs de la section open Maxime lag
garde avec les Blancs toujours une
finale compliquée on va moins s'attarder
sur chacune des positions parce que
c'est le jackn on a encore nos huit
parties euh Natacha a une erreur on se
reconnect on voit
l'erreur en direct F4
F5 alors l'ordinateur n'aime
pas mais ça a quand même de mérites ce
coup gêner le fou de3 qui tapait sur G6
et potentiellement un
jour prendre la case 4 pour y transférer
le cavalier qui est pour l'instant très
loin qui a son rôle en tapant sur le F
de 4 mais en4 ça pourrait être sympa on
a jamais envie de faire fouprend parce
que ça donnerait un pionasser protégé au
noir donc l'ordinateur naime pas c'est
une bonne nouvelle mais humainement ça
saute pas aux yeux que c'est pas un très
c'est pas c'est pas un très bon coup
euh vas-y tu as un petit mot à dire sur
cette position oui oui en fait là c'est
euh comment est-ce que les blancs
peuvent créer du contrejeu c'est la
question
que que Ben que Maxime doit se poser
est-ce que je vais attendre juste
passivement ou est-ce que j'ai la
possibilité de me créer des occasions de
d'ouvrir le jeu d'activer une pièces
alors donc là il y a pas qu' aller
prendre les qu parce qu'on prend
et fou prend H4 mais donc ah il a joué
fou i il a jou fou et donc l'idée c'est
de transférer le fou en F2 pour défendre
toujours le pion D4 parce que ça va être
nécessaire après un coup de tour mais il
veut non pas avoir le fou en C3 mais
avoir le fou en F2 peut-être euh son
idée c'est de pouvoir utiliser la
colonne C quand même et pas que le fou
tape tape dessus
euh qui sait si le s'en va il peut de
vous prendreass mais bon
objectivement c'est très difficile pour
les blancs c'est difficile depuis
longtemps et comme on a dit on va pas
trop s'attarder sur chacune des
positions V qu'on a les h parties à
suivre qu'on est en Z note 2 partout tu
as encore un mot à dire un truc ou on
passe à la partie suivante non allons
voir les autres parties ok allons voir
les autres
parties donc
oh trè échiquier c'est Laurent qui a
fait nul mais voilà une partie de
moin bravo te fr on s'était quitté par
là et ça a pas traîné donc dans le rôle
de de blour avec les pièces noires t fr
l'a parfaitement
joué allons voir la partie suivante
c'est Jul avec les Blancs
contre
Rasmus span
ou là
ou là what is happening on s'était
quitté par là là il y a eu B4 F on en
parlait G5 bon coup d'près l'ordinateur
bravo
rasmous F5 pas trop le choix ENF il y a
toujours le sacrifice mais bon si l'ordi
les sacrifice ne marche pas c'est qu'il
ne marche pas prise prise je vais aller
vite au
direct4 c'est vrai que là toutes les
pièces noires sont bien centralisé la
tourin est totalement en jeu il prend
l'ORD n'aime
pas bon au moins avec les Blancs on a un
P de plus pour
l'instant
attends sur du ouais c'est qu'en fait on
a un gros problème sur la case sur la
case F2 et finalement nos pièces qui se
qui se protègent le fou G5 qui protège
le fou H6 c'est assz peut-être c'est un
peu
superficiel c'est ça que tu veux dire
mais faut prend F2 ouais en fait fa
prend F2 c'est fini
ouais même un coup par exemple comme
tour 2 aussi
c'est
oh oh
ouais faut prendre F2
oui
ici ici on peut peut-être prendre et je
CER G4
bon tu me diras euh
ouais il y a toujours le même
problème bon donc après a priori là
c'est une question de est-ce que Rasmos
va se tromper ou convertir
mais objectivement là c'est pas une
question d'être mal c'est une question
d'être perdant donc il faut absolument
que by qui était très bien quand on l'a
quitté
l'emporte avec les pièces noires ça
serait
l'exploit face à Vincent CER je le mets
sur le petit échiquier également avec
les Noirs
tout
donc alors on s'était quitté par là même
avant
prise prise on avait vu il a sacrifi le
pion F6 il récupère le pion F2 en G3
proposition de répétition des coups
what c'est vinan qui refuse la
répétition peut-être que c'était avant
l'erreur de Jul mais ou alors peut-être
qu'il pensait que ça faisait pas trois
fois encore si une non de non mais non
non ça faisait pas tr fois donc
peut-être que Étienne avait prévu de
changer sur mais bon ok en tout cas on a
ça et dans le direct on en est là
waouh c'est une position à double
tranchant
ouais alors double
tranchant ou c'est même il y a beaucoup
de tranchant triple quadruple tranchant
là toujours les r opposé toujours jour
les deux rois qui ont pas beaucoup de
pions devant eux même plus du tout ici
il y a des échecs possibles il y a des
prises enfin c'est chaud il y a un pion
de moins que c'est
tendu que c'est tendu euh bon F prend un
ch c'est une petite menace quand
Mme petite oui donc dit que ça va mais
oui il dit que ça va mais il propose un
coup quand même qu'il faut jouer qu'il
faut poser jouer il propose tour prend
F5 donc c'est pas non plus une position
si
simple pour pouvoir maintenir
l'équilibre on peut pas protéger le
cavalet
G4 qui peut pas s'en aller parce que il
y a mat en G2 et sur cavalier 3 on
prend donc oui donc en fait il donne les
deux pièces pour la tour mais avec le le
pion H6 qui va tomber et donc on se
retrouve avec deux piè pour la tour pour
tour et de pion de pièces contre tour et
de pion
[Musique]
et il y a pas un truc où on peut jouer
non je voulais faire l'artiste mais je
crois que ça va pas marcher sur prend ch
mais je vouis jouer ouais mais ça ça
marche
jamais si prend des qu
ah chque miam c'est ça ouais ouais
plutôt comme ça
oui S et là je dois pouvoir bouger mon
cavalier avec ou même un tour pr G2 ça
se calcule ah oui tourpr2 plus simple
écheac écheac
double BIM BIM BIM de partout ok échec
double à la
découverte qui fait une fourchette
y c'est l'exercice final
pour passer dans la classe supérieure en
fait l'exercice n'est pas de résoudre
les positions c'est de trouver les
bon qui vont à la position de nommer les
tactiques ok donc by très bien mais rien
n'est fait Jul il faut de la chance il
faut voir reprend F5 c'est ça qui est
difficile qui est difficile pas
forcément mais enfin pas forcément pour
lui oui mais après oui c'est oui après
bon si on joue pas trop la bonne
nouvelle c'est que si on joue pas trop
PR5 on est peut-être foutu donc en fait
il va y penser et et s'il y pense bah
d'ailleurs il a joué de points
d'exclamation bravo bi ouais
bravo alors après c'est la victoire
n'est pas acquise loin de là mais en
tout cas l'espoir renaitt
ok place au fille
ouais
placeopie commençons par popo qui était
super bien
al elle est toujours alors attends fou
des4 attaque la dame TZ vite
contreattaque sur la dame
blanche et donc il a toujours cette
égalité de matériel toujours ce pion 7
en fait la position il a un échange mais
la position n'a pas fondamentalement
changé il va toujours falloir convertir
un
peu ce pion à en avantage matériel
attends là c'est très blanc une
plus je reprends comment ça
pass'estce qui se passe gagner une
qualité ou fait c'est très
bien mais juste pr une pièce alors
ok4 sur 4 on peut aussi juste bouger le
cavalier en fait ok j'ai oublié de
compter les pièces
d'accord non c'est j'ai compé les pions
mais pas les pièces non pas pensé que en
fait ça explique pourquoi la jauge est
si bien que ça mais bon donc là c'est
juste une pièce de plus
ouis il y a juste le temps à la pendule
qu'il faut surveiller 3 minutes 54
versus 7 minutes
50 12 coup
Open en open on peut abandonner par
équipe bon on aime faire durer parce que
c'est difficile de pour les autres quand
on est mené mais normalement une pièce
de plus ça doit aller alors Mitra
c'était chaud pas pas terrible mais
encore tendu qu'est-ce qu'il en est
désormais au cœur de
zckn
Al voilà on avait prédit tout ça B enfin
un coup
euh
pour libérer le fou H6 l'ordinateur
n'aime
pas euh mais bon c'est tellement humain
CIT le coup qu'on voulait jouer à chaque
fois
et va savoir pourquoi il n'aime pas
alors il y a un truc quand même c'est
que après fou
6 c'est une vraie menace d'échec
perpétuel jusqu'à présent quand on
faisait l'échec en F1 genre
ici on disait même roi des deux ou ro
c'est de mais même quand le pion est en
C2 on Fa des2 et il y avait pas d'autres
échec si là on joue fou A6 bah qui est
joué ce qui vient d'être joué si par
exemple les blancs prennent menace de
prendre en G5 et mat mais c'est échec
perpétuel comme ça ce qui serait une
excellente nouvelle pour Mitra et pour
les
Bleus C chiquier m avait fait quasiment
le deuil là alors après la question
c'est oui dis-moi je disais la bonne
nouvelle c'est qu'on peut aussi jouer
dame F1 échec roi bouge et fou à6 on
peut peut-être créer la ah oui non mais
FO a 6 ça été joué oua F 6 a été joué
d'accord mais oui oui tu as raison non
je vais le montrer je montrer on peut
commencer par écheac roi des deux ou roi
C2 et FO 6 là
ouais oui oui c'est sûrement qu'il y a
des petites différences donc la question
c'est est-ce que les blancs peuvent
jouer un coup de défense pour empêcher
l'échec perpétuel ça a pas
l'air pas l'air évident quand
même parce que après bon il y a même des
coups comme à TR ou quoi donc c'est bon
plutôt la Bonne Nouvelle
euh encore quelque chose à dire on passe
à à Sophie
on ouais on va la partie de Sophie surt
je crois que la partie de Sophie c'est
ce qui est compliqué je crois qu'elle
est en Z not je sais ça se dit en
profond
ouais
ouais ouais on a compris je sais
pas mais en tout
cas alors c'est chaud à la ou là ah non
non non c'est juste ma retransmission
qui bug alors il y a eu des coups
colorés pas forcément la couleur ici on
parlait ah oui non on parlait de B3 C4
B4 finalement euh ah oui la pas fan du
changement de structure parce qu'on
expliquit que le P 7 était faible
finalement structure symétrique et là je
regrette surtout moi d'avoir joué F4
mais finalement elle elle s'en sert F5
je prends F5 elle a sacrifie son pion
pour l'attaque F6 et ok un pion moins
mais maintenant c'est les noir comme
structure catastrophique le fou qui il y
a pas longtemps éta actif maintenant il
se retrouve en muré en G7 bloqué par son
pu
F6 l'ordinateur aime bien les blancs à
nouveau après
c'est c'est la crise de temps peut-être
pas aussi grave que ce que tu avais tout
à l'heure j'ai eu un bug de
retransmission au bug maisépu j'étais là
oh mais après quand même pas beaucoup de
temps pour encore des coups on est que
au adversaire on enore ouis son
adversaire on a encore moins et surtout
ben tu m'as dit bon les Noirs ils ont un
pion de plus mais regarde la tête du
pion qu'elle a en plus quoi c'est pion
doublé isolé puis lui il est toujours fa
aussi fa on a les pièces qui sont
actives on a le droit de d'y croire on a
vraiment le droit d'y croire et et avec
le retour de Mitra dans la partie
on peut vraiment commencer à espérer à
nouveau en tout cas ce serait énorme
allez on y croit moi j'y crois B ouçon
on y croit depuis le début même depuis
avant le tournoi on y croit
mais mais mais là là ça ça tourne bien
alors faut juste confirmer au premier
échiquier
démonter la jauge est
blanche la jauge est blanche ce qui
n'est pas la bonne nouvelle
donc ça sera dans tous les cas très
tendu alors démter on avait on avait dit
que la position était tellement complexe
qu' il y allait forcément y avoir des
erreurs de part et
d'autres mais donc qu'est-ce qui se
passe ici le matériel à ces de qualité
de moins là maintenant ouais deux
qualités de moins il y a que un pion
pour deux qualités alors certes les
diagonales sont ouvertes mais les colins
aussi donc les tours vont être plus
forts que les fous et
ou bon on sait pas trop où c'est pas
vraiment la la question du direct en
plein de zacnot mais visiblement il y a
eu des erreurs de démter peut-être plus
que de ellisabeth
en tout cas qui ont eu un impact plus
ouis plus important sur la
partie je pense vraiment là Mitra est en
train de prendre le le perpè donc Mitra
va faire
nul je suis trop excité Pauline a gagné
Pauline a gagné alors juste juste
montrer la position
finale non pas que qu'on soit surprise
mais je pour montrer l'officialisation
mais effectivement on disait par là que
on pouvait abandonner ça a duré de coups
de plus il y a une pièce de plus tout
simplement et puis là on attaque la tour
et on propose é changer d'AM qui serait
synonyme de fin de partie la finale avec
une pièce de plus donc abandon ma très
très belle partie très propre il y a pas
eu d'erreur de de Pauline elle a été
mécanique dans dans son exécution de de
l'avantage
euh donc ça ferait un partout si Mitra
Mitra c'est pas encore officiel si si
c'est offici Mitra c'est officiel et
donc tout va se jouer sur les chiquier
de euh Sophie a
priori donc si on leur
met si on leur met en grand les chiquier
de
Sophie le résultat si on considère euh
que Démé va bien perdre évidemment fait
le miracle mais bon a
priori Elizabeth P devrait pouvoir
convertir ces deux qualités de plus le
résultat de la partie de Sophie va être
le résultat du
match et les joueurs sont en ja note il
y a eu les coups qu'on avait dit fou
des4 ro H8 donc fou des4
menacepr6 chute s'enlève de ce
clouage et c'est compliqué
et c'est
compliqué alors on peut on peut tenter
avec les blonds so on peut essayer de
proposer leschang des dames avec des
coups comme dame B6 sinon on a aussi une
manœuvre qui peut être assez
intéressante c'est de la tour en G3 de
la faire d'essayer de la faire passer en
C7 par exemple un coup comme tour C3
tour C7 tour C3 tour
C6 ouais non t C3 on l'aime bien alors
elle la joué f 2 l'ordin n'aime pas et
je voulais juste mentionner ton coup
c'est vrai qu'on a pas envie en soit
d'échanger les dames si là si on peut
enlever les deux dames de chiquier ça
favorise plutôt les noirs qui ont un
mauvais roi mais ton coup est
intéressant parce que là évidemment on
reprend du pion et c'est pas du tout la
même finale que si les dames s'échangent
sans modification de la structure et
donc faut de avec modification de la
structure avec le pion à 6 faible puis
en F6 puis en F5 h ça peut encore se
discuter maisavantage n'est plus aussi
grand oui et là oui tu disais le
problème de fou 2 c'est qu'après un coup
comme dame d5in qui donc propose échange
des dames c'est ce que tu disais he si
on échange les dames il y a pas eu de
modification de structure et donc ça va
être compliqué de passer avec les avec
les blan oui et puis les noir on
beaucoup de faible ass tôt donc les
blancs sonent pas moins bien c'est sûr
mais il y a toujours un P de moins donc
un moment même faible un pion de plus
c'est on on a envie de on aimerait que
garde l'attention sur les
chiquers mais c'est possible qu'elle
propose juste d'échanger les dames c'est
qu'elle échange les dames ou c'est
possible
ouais après je sais pas Sophie elle aime
bien quand
même elle a gardé les dames mais en
jouant dame BC
h ça peut garder la dame non il y a des
cases intéressantes mais c'est vrai ça
l'excentre un peu de bah ça l'excentre
du centre c'est un peu redondant mon
histoire est aussi de l'IT mais en fait
pas totalement parce que elle peut faire
des menaces de mat en en un
coup donc et il y a le pion à dont on
parle de la faiblesse depuis toujours là
puis en fait F3 c'est une vraie menace
ai et attends donc là les blancs les
noirs viennent de jouer F4 donc sur F4
si tour bouge est-ce qu'il y a pas pr H3
qui arrive est-ce que ce serait ça que
Sophia a raté
avec tu penses qu'il y a
des on arrive vraiment à le faire
marcher il y a jamais de problème sur la
je sais pas sur la
col si là il y a un
problème bon là ça marche pas ok donc
après tour
C3
donc la position c'est pas c'est ça il y
a F4 qui est joué là ça sie une minute à
la pendule que c'est tendu que c'est
tendu et donc on rappelle a
priori je vais mettre la la partie de de
démonter sur le petit échiquier
peut-être on espère le miracle mais qui
devrait pas venir
malheureusement mais démter à ces deux
qualités de moins vous la voyez sur le
petit échiquier et ici c'est donc la
partie qui a priori
décidera du résultat du match et Sophie
son temps ses graines moins d'une minute
maintenant avec plus 30 secondes par
coup le rajjoute temps 40e on en est
encore assez loin il faut jouer se
coups donc c'est tendu j'aime bien tour
C3 quand même j'aime bien tour C3 tour
D3 3 ok bon ça peut pas être mauvais de
mettre sa tour en face de la dame
surtout que sur fou pr H3 maintenant
c'est un autre thème c'est fou pr F6
Matth
en c'est l'heure où je me prends le ma
en un ok
euh pourquoi pourquoi tout à l'heure ça
a
marché ça marché sur tour pr sur tour F3
ah
je3 attends tour des TR
prage3 mais c'était quoi qu'on je
ah non mais je disais prise je disais
prise prise oui non c'est ça euh oui non
tout à l'heure je m'étais pas pas faite
je disais prise prise sauf que là prise
en de et on n pas tourite Échec donc ça
ça ça ça va pas ok donc quelle est
l'idée est-ce qu'elle a vu F H3 c'est un
coup qu'on peut rater
aussi dame 4 jouet oh là là que c'est
tendu ok fa F1 j'imagine F F1 j'imagine
FO
F1 surtout avec juste quelques secondes
à la pendule
c'est F1 jouet très bien non tour des
deux
jouet tour des de ça fait
artificiel ça fait mais bon ouais je
sais pas les pièces se protègent moins
j'aime pas jouer avec cette tour
pas
protégé alors que là F F1 ça protège
bien la to mais bon c'est pas du tout
concret ce que je suis en train de dire
mais c'est j'ai un mauvais feeling sur
ce est-ce qu' un coup comme F3 ça
pourrait être possible F3 pu que sur fou
prend F3 il y a
dame1 donc fa pr F3 n peut non jouable
et donc sur F3 est-ce qu'on est forcé de
ah non c'est chaud ah là là non le tour
des deux on aaime pas
ouais l'ORD n'aime pas ouais à cause de
F3
alors les noirs n'ont pas joué mais F3
c'est tellement vers l'avant c'est en
plus c'est notre pion faible on l'a joué
en F4 il y a deux coups à peine donc ça
vient ben toi ça tuit venu à tempo mais
je pense ça vient assez naturellement un
coup naturel c'est un coup naturel et je
pense pas qu'il va le rater ce coup HM
et ça punit vraiment la tactique est
basée sur cette pièce en l'air donc moi
j'étais pas du tout en mode concrète à
calculer pourquoi t des de tu es mauvais
mais le le feeling qui vient de là quand
on met ces pièces non
protégées c'est souvent un signe qu'il y
a une tactique et donc c'est pour ça
qu'on peut le jouer on peut refuser de
jouer tour des deux même sans calcul
juste en en par intuition non je veux
pas mettre ma tour en prise je veux que
chaque pièce soit bien proté
mais donc surtout que son adversaire
elle elle sent qu'il y a quelque chose
elle prend son temps h elle sent qu'il y
a quelque chose qui ne va pas dans la
position des blancs que l'équilibre
c'est c'est rempu enfin c'est remplu
dans le sens où l'harmonie des pièces
blanche n'est n'est plus n'est plus
présente donc elle se pose elle se pose
elle
réfléchit ouais il y a aussi ou f fou C4
F3 paraî logique
ouais non F par que oui c'est du mutuel
tu as raison de le dire mais si on pense
à F3 je crois qu'on on le joue alors on
nous dit B qui est totalement gagnant
peut-être un petit coup d'œil avant de
revenir juste je sais pas qui
vas-y juste la fenêtre parce que est
rentré maintenant il fa Frid
ok l'énorme partie de Baky effectivement
bah là c'est alors il y une qualité de
moins certes
mais regardez ces deux pièces qui n'ont
jamais joué l'UR blanc qui se fait
agresser donc quelle partie
extraordinaire de de by peut-être pas
exemple d'erreur mais c'était la
position qui était complexe en tout cas
beau style quoi grand rock
ouverture des des lignes
eu peut-être un petit passage à vie d'un
moment mais c'était B mutuel et c'est
quand même un signe de la complexité de
la position plus que
euh de d'erreur de de Baky donc ça ça se
présente très
bien est-ce que il y a eu un miracle
chez un autre chez Jul ou enfin un des
Français qui était position plus
compromise où la Jul c'est l'énorme
crise il est mat de partout et donc tout
pourrait se jouer sur les chiqu de maime
la
garde qui revit très
bien qui revit très
bien donc B voir s'il y a bien le 11
qu'on prédit tout va se jouer ici de la
même manière que chez les joueuses tout
devrait se jouer sur la partie de Sophie
raté
ah F3 é
raté t
mieux mais ou mieux une menace ah non si
il y a une
menace mais je peux quand même jouer F3
non tu peux quand même jouer F
tu peux tout à fait jouer
F3 un coup de prise en G2 ça va plutôt
activer la tour et donc là ça jus tout à
fait le coup tour de de ici on prend G7
prend G2 coup d'après et avec tour dame
en attaque ça va très très bien se
passer pour les blancs et donc la tour
D2 est tout à fait
justifié donc c'est compliqué oui
dis-moi ou oui je vouis dire on est au
direct là les filles on joué d'autes cou
là c'est ah il eu dame 1 tout rêve 2
ok que il y a pas sur sur le petit chiqu
c'est quoi ah oui c'est la partie de dem
Moné qui a toujours ses qualités de moi
euh elle se dans le dans le chat maius
ushiba nous dit que Baki aurait fait une
erreur et que la position est toujours
meilleure pour les pour les Noirs mais
que ce n'est plus aussi sûr
euh on ira jeter un œil après ok ouais
on peut alors dame prend B4 laisse faire
la prise en F6 mais maintenant les
finales
qu'on on disait qu'elles étaient à
chaque fois ou presque favorable au
blanc bon là c'est pas forcément le cas
maintenant que ce pion B4 est tombé que
ce pion B5 est pasez protégé est-ce que
il y a un coup autre que F prend F6 pas
sûr surtout avec là c'est 30 secondes
par coup ou
ouais faut prendre F6 ça paraît
complètement donc c'est jouer
jou qu'est-ce qu'on joue est-ce qu'on
joue un coup il peut y avoir des matchs
nuls vas-y je t'ai coupé mais oui c'est
ça la question que je posais c'est
est-ce que on laisse les nan prendre en
F6 ou est-ce que on prend en F6 je vois
pas l'intérêt d'échanger en F6 par
contre un coup comme tour6 je pense pas
que ce soit Cuse ouais moi je
m'attendais à T justement et je voyais
je voyais cette
possible ce possible ah non mais
c'estond je vois l'
perpétuel en fait ici on va jouer plutôt
F
vok j'ai une question sur tour G8 est-ce
que je peux jouer d pr à6 tout
simplement je récupère un pion quand
même c'est clairement c'est clairement
un coup alors après la question de ça
maintenant que la tour est est
ici de toute façon prend assist tu as
raison c'est si les noirs n'ont rien
tout de suite l'option A il peut faire
la
différence que c'est tendu que c'est
tendu alors il y a eu l'échange en G7
tuend
G7 si
maintenant maintenant
c'est le 40e
et je ne sais
pas je ne sais pas ma
chère n demande pourquoi ça c le live
mais on sait pas
pourquoi c'est pas c'est.com qui bug
ouais je sais pas
nous on s'entend donc a priori moi j'ai
j'ai internet ouais ben je je sais
pas déso donc Tam prend est joué et le
40e est atteint en tout cas par Sophie
alors peut-être l'occasion de revoir la
partie de B qui là on a dit qui qui se
serait
raté alors al il y a eu un point
d'exclamation mais qui ne mènerait qu'au
match nul il
cavalier3
ah c'est pas de chance oh là là si avec
là toutes les pièces comme ça qui
attaque le r
faible pas que le PERP c'est ouais ici
ouais donc cavalier3 a priori fou mais
donc pas M le perpè et d'ailleurs oui
bon le perpè il est là ça
ici
et s'il y a pas mieux c'est horrible
pour l'équipe de France parce que Jules
on voit
pas on voyait vraiment pas
comment renverser la vapeur HM
ouis bon d'ailleurs c'est officiel et
euh Maxime al il va tout tenter
évidemment si maintenant qu'il a égalisé
ou si il a égalisé mais il y avait
c'était solide he quand même en face oui
non mais là aucune chance enfin
aucune moi je je serais capable de la
perdre évidemment contre Maxime mais
donchenko je ne pense pas je ne pense
pas
ah ça peut être cruel ça peut être cruel
vu le déroul du
match
ok alors démter on l'a en petit
peut-être que maintenant que le 40e est
atteint on peut faire le bilan est-ce
que ça joue encore ça joue encore le 40e
est atteint
aussi toujours seulement un pion pour
deux qualités de moi le roi blanc
toujours
faiblein pas plus faible que le roi noir
mais il y a il y a ce facteur de hasard
ce facteur de chaos ce facteur d'erreur
potentielle que le roi blanc pas très
bien protégé donc c'est pour ça que Démé
continu mais objectivement deux qualités
de plus ça doit finir par faire la
différence
euh on retourne chez Sophie
ouais on va partie de Sophie donc son
adversaire a joué le 40e coup donc là on
est parti pour 30 minutes de plus à la
pendule pour chacune des joueuse on va
quand même rester du côté de Sophie
pardon et je vais la mettre aussi sur le
pechqu hop hop donc a
priori les espoirs de titre des même des
deux équipes de France si le
match la section mixte s'il y a pas de
miracle on va dire tout le tous nos
espoirs reposent sur cette partie et sur
les épaules de Sophie
euh l'ordinateur dit que c'est
totalement
égal enfin sur la jauge mais la jauge
non en fait la jauge il y a pas le égal
00 donc c'est juste la jauge qui ne
marche plus
euh ça peut être
éégal est-ce queil y a une menace
tactique ou
pas je pense que ça doit être égal
conètement je pense que Sophie doit
jouer d pr
B5 ah oua mais
ouais B après après le 40e on va tu veux
dire oua si elle joue pas dame prend B5
si l'adversaire ne trouve pas faut prend
G2 h c'est bon ça aurait été bien qu'il
ce soit le 36e ou 37 coup que ça aurait
ça aurait été facile à rater pour son
adversaire mais par exemple toi dame
prend B5 premier réflexe F3 F3 a priori
c'est pour les
blancs bon ça reste ça ça reste
compliqué ça reste compliqué quand même
ça reste compliqué mais bon au moins on
a un de plus pour l'instant point de vue
pratique après bon le problème c'est que
après fut prend G2 prend G2 F3 bon la
nulle devrait être signée assez
rapidement mais comment on fait
d'ailleurs comment on fait pour faire
nul en fait on j'ai trouvé nul mais
c'est c'est ça ah non je faire je faire
le C ou bon c'est pas grave je pense que
j'ai le temps parce que ok c'est en fait
je je va faire tour pr H4 et je veis
tour H3 tour H3 et terna mais c'est
match nul quand bien même je perds le P
à 5 mais la forteresse mais en fait si
on est obligé de passer par des
forteresses c'est trisque
qu non par exemple un coup comme roi roi
H1 ou roi H2 l'idée c'est que par
exemple r H2 admettons r H1 ro H1 l'idée
c'est sur
on fait cet échec ça ouais t perpétuel
ouais et dame dame 5 échec
perpétuel où
là-bas ok donc ce qu'on est en train de
dire c'est que dame prend B5 si les noir
jou F prang de ça sera match nul dans
très peu de coup sinon est-ce que
ça il y a vraiment aucune microochance
pr pr il y a même des rises de per en
fait ben non après fouprend B5 tu es tu
tu es ok ah oui au pire tuas fouprend B5
ben je fouprend B5 et il y a pas trop de
chance de gain ici
euh bon pas de risque de perdre
évidemment mais au mieux au mieux du
mieux on aura un de contre un totalement
nul
ok je pense que Sophie est en train
d'évoluer d'évaluer quelle est la suite
qui pourrait possiblement lui donner le
plus de de chance
il y a aussi des coups qui alors je
pense pas que ça marche mais est-ce que
non on n pas le temps je regardais dam
C8 avec des idées comme A6 ou des choses
comme ça essay de pousser le pon a mais
je crois pas que ça
pu du coup d c'estite il faut rebouer la
dame
oua se fou fr de
[Musique]
ouais donc là c'est toujours compliqué
quand après le 40e on fait le bilan on
souffle et tout quand on se rend compte
c'est nul est-ce que justement on joue
pour avant tout ne pas perdre ou est-ce
qu'on joue pour tenter la peau de banane
euh bon là fa son tout à l'air un peu de
de faire nul mais il y a il y a cette
question quoi c'est est-ce qu'on met
toujours une part d'aléatoire ou est-ce
qu'on veut vraiment garantir le résultat
et on en parle plus parce que match nul
évidemment pour les espoirs de
tites c'est pas une bonne nouvelle pour
les pour les espoirs de podium la
défaite est
catastrophique
donc est-ce qu'on veut jouer à fond pour
pour le gain ou est-ce qu'on veut jouer
avant tout pour ne pas
perdre sachant que la Bulgarie prend une
grosse option sur ce match sur son match
ah
elle mène déjà 2-0 ah oui avec position
mais d'ailleurs ça ouais tu fais bien le
dire parce que ça fait partie décision
tu joues ton 4 tu fais un tour pour
décompresser mais tu regardes également
le résultat des autres match après la
question voilà match nul peut-être que
si les blancs font la France fait match
nul peut-être que le titre n'est pas
encore perdu hein dire faut que la
Bulgarie gagne son dernier match et que
la France si France gagne son dernier
match et la Bulgarie ne gagne pas il me
semble est-ce qu'un matul serait
suffisant non il me semble que
non la France peut repasser devant ça
dépend du résultat de l'azerbaïidjan et
de la
grissceut tout façon ça ça dépend de
tout quoi ça dépend de tout et tenu les
victoires les portes sont toujours enfin
rien rien n'est encore fait rien n'est
fini rien n'est encore fait
et mais mais donc ok cette partie qui va
on on l'avait dit déjà il y a bien
longtemps qui va décider du résultat on
joue toujours pour le gain c'est tout
non ben non non non là je suis pas
d'accord avec toi Sky lato par équipe on
joue pas toujours pour le gars on joue
pour pour l'équipe si ça passe par jouer
par l'annul individuel on joue pour
l'annul hein c'est on joue pour ce qui
est de mieux pour l'équipe si le
capitaine nous dit prends enfin il n'a
pas le droit de nous dire prend prend
pas de risque évidemment hein euh mais
si s'il nous dit de faire nul même avant
le match comme là par exemple c'était
sûrement la consigne texess évidemment
euh ben on fait nul quoi c'est le
résultat de l'équipe avant tout
ça on en connaitt un des très bons
joueurs qui sont incapables de respecter
les les consignes de capitaine qui sont
pas repris
dans dans des équipe je pense j'ai des
exemples sur Richard rapporte en club
qui marquait des points mais qui n'a pas
été repris parce que bah il en faisait
qu'à sa tête et justement il joue
toujours pour le gain
euh et donc si bleu qui confirme ce que
tu
disais le titre n'est pas compromis en
cas de nul de Sophie
oui quel autre consigne que faire match
nul peuton donner à T dis-moi nana
pardon non je voulais proposer d'aller
jeter un petit coup d'œil rapidement sur
les autres
résultats les autres parties je sais pas
ce qui reste je suis du côté des des
garçons je pense qu'il reste les
chiquier de de
Maxime faisons un petit
check Maxime ouh là Maxime erreur
alors déjà le match
nul ah oui non mais on se dirigeit pas
du tout vers match nul alors peut-être
qu'il a fait
ouais non ben je sais pas ce qu'il a
fait
h bon en tout cas on ne voit pas gagner
ça hein les Noirs ont un seul bloc de
pions dont lui qui est passé protégé en
F5 les Blancs ont trois pions isolés
donc c'est c'est pas la bonne nouvelle B
qui j'imagine que c'est
officiel
euh je ne sais pas je ne sais pas
non allons voir allons le voir pas
encore officiel mais
bon alors tu tu me diras tu me diras ou
pas est-ce qu'on peut pas jouer pour le
gain est-ce que
on peut même
pas tu te fais contre
perpétuer moi je me fais contre
perpétuer d'illeur c'est horrible qu'il
y a pas de parce que parfois parfois a
avec dam fou il quand même pas
bon nul officiel ou c'est tombé dessus
en fait leème c'est si tu vas chercher
la tour tuas Dame des qu dam des8 d B6
tu te prends un échec perpétuel ouioui
ça on va le
montrerandme
ouais et celuilà aussi c'est parfois
c'est pas perpète ah bon mais là là ça
allit totalement mais parce que mais
parfois tu as tu as ça tu sais et en
fait là ce qui est horrible c'est qu'il
y a pas seulement la case
desb c'est que tu as aussi tu as aussi
toutes les cases en fait toute la
diagonale ou c'est c'est vraiment à
trace quoi qu'il a pas réussi à mat
enfin pas réussi que ça matait pas tout
seul quand ça euh quand il y avait
vraiment toutes les pièces en attaque
par
là et après que il y a cette histoire de
perpétuel quand on on mange la tour et
tout mais c'est vrai que c'est ça les
risques du Z not c'est que au final tu
te retrouves à devoir prendre à prendre
les mauvaises décisions
ou les décisions qui coûte cher sur et
tu r des victoires qui peuvent coûter
cher à la fin sur le plan comptable ah
tu là ça ça peut coûter cher à l'équipe
aussi ou d'ailleurs pas tant que ça si
et si jamais Maxime euh finit par perdre
cette finale alors qu'il sera passé par
un beaucoup de stades mais dans ce CASL
ça serait une parfois enfin c'est c'est
pas ce qu'on souhaite à Maxime
évidemment mais parfois la défaite
d'équipe 2-0 et donne un peu moins la la
responsabilité se dilue entre les
joueurs qui ont perdu quand tu es le
seul à perdre
euh c'est tu t'en veux tellement ou tu
refais le match et tu te dis ah si
j'avais gagné moi enfin voilà
euh après je pense que c'est aussi ça
l'importance d'avoir un bon groupe
d'avoir une une forte équipe c'est que
tu arrives aussi à ne pas prendre cette
responsabilité seule et en tout cas ton
capitaine tes coéquipiers te font sentir
que c'est une une responsabilité
collective parce que au final tu les
décisions que tu prends dans ta partie
dépendent aussi des positions de tes
collègues c'est V donc tu peux très bien
prendre un peu plus de risque dans une
position un instant T parce que tu vois
que ta collègue à droite ou ton collègue
à gauche il est peut-être un peu moins
bien ou du moins tu l'évalues un peu
moins bien et donc tu te dis il faut que
je il faut que je contrebalance cette
situation oui oui donc après voilà c'est
comme dans tous les spurco c'est pas à
cause d'un joueur ou d'une joueuse ben
qu'on perd un match c'est une
responsabilité collective
je je suis entièrement d'accord avec toi
et bah l'exemple type c'est la partie de
bcky je pense que bcky avec les Noirs
face à Van Ker à la base il est pas comp
de faire une petite nulle et c'est du
coup c'est plutôt un bon résultat là on
est horriblement déçu parce que vu qu'il
sentait que les espoirs du match osé sur
lui bah il a il a fait Hine alors
peut-être la POS le demandé aussi mais
il a pris à priori plus de risque que il
l'aurait fait en tournoi individuel face
à un joueur à 2700 plus avec les pièces
hisoire et donc cette partie elle dure
ce qui est plutôt bon signe ce qui est
plutôt bon signe euh vu que c'est la
partie qu'on a pas encore perdu pour
l'instant on même toujours un zéro et
donc certes cette partie est totalement
perdante
mais jamais c'est frustrant quand tu as
deux qualités de plus que tu peux tu
puisses pas en rendre une simplement
hein si on se dit ok là c'est j'ai de
qualité de plus mais c'est compliqué à
gagner les gen rend une et puis on
simplifie en finale par exemple si on
peou avoir une finale avec une qualité n
de plus la tour contre le cavalier ça
serait facilement gagnant mais il y a il
y a pas ça on peut pas jouer je sais pas
tour PR6 un tour pr G5 ou un tour point
H4 qui qui simplifierait et tout
et pense que les les blancs adorerai
pouvoir échanger les dames ah bah ouais
mais encore fautil pouvoir le faire
parce que une fois que les dames sont
échangées ben le pion 6 tombe le pion
il galope he il galope jusqu'à jusqu'à
la dame jusqu'à la promotion mais voilà
est-ce qu'on a un moyen de le faire de
manière plutôt
concrèteon tour D1 je pense que l'idée
oui c'est de c'est de jouer dame
D5 on espère que l'idée de d'Élisabeth
c'est de jouer tour des7 parce
qu'près mais non il y a il y a peu de
chance quand même il a de
chance
euh un petit coup d'œil chez Sophie
ouais je regardais
le le chat aussi mais on va plutôt
regarder Sophie on va plutôt regarder
Sophie donc a priori
ah donc nul signé qu'est-ce qui s'est
passé dame dam PR6 proposition nul oui
bon on en parlait de cette finale pas
d'espoir donc ce qui est bien c'est
qu'on peut plus per ce mat V qu'il reste
plus une partie et qu'on mène à0 ce qui
est beaucoup moinss bien c'est que la
partie qui reste c'est celle où on a
deux qualité de
moins tour des vient d'être joué la
menace et dame D5 qu'est-ce qui est
terrible c'est qu'il y a la menace dame
G8
ensuite la menace l'idé G8 et donc
refuser d'échanger d'AM va être
difficile ben c'est qu'un échec hein dam
G8 tu ah il y a là ben je pense tu as
pas le choix en fait tu as pas le choix
que de garder les dames etespérer que
les Blancs jouent un cou précis qui te
permett de revenir dans c'est le seul
eSport une fois que tu es changé d'âme
la partie la position elle est c'est
c'est linéaire pour les blancs on va
chercher le piomb même si on doit
sacrifier donc la tour une
qualité on va chercher le piomb on ah on
fait dame et c'est fini ououi mais mais
même just en fait concrètement c'est
difficile parce que il y a il y a il y a
pas de coup en fait B c'est le problème
d'avoir autant de matériel en moin c'est
que tu es presque en Z ouais c'est
marrant c'est c'est presque un chaque
coup de dame déterriore la
position et dame H5 dam G8 mat mat dans
un coup bravo c'est c'est est-ce que
c'est le seul je pense c'est le seul
parce que sur ro H5 dame F7 c'est pas
mat cabali G6 donc c'est le seul maté en
un coup bravo
nana c'est le nouveau nouveau concept
alors nen abusez pas trop
euh mais c'est un
exercice un exercice qui existe aussi
comment trouver le seul coup pour se f
matatterer non mais ça ça va être dur ça
va être ça te dit qu'on qu'on a jeté un
coup d'œil sur les parties des des gars
qui restent parti rest benah il reste
plus que le pauvre Maxime la garde si je
dis pas de bêtises hein mais je crois by
c'est nul officiel Laurent ça fait
longtemps qu'il a quité la salle
et Jules a perdu donc il reste cette
partie pour sauver le match nul il
faudrait gagner àve cl blanc
ouais non match nul ou ou défaites de de
Maxime a priori on voit pas vraiment
pas vraiment pas comment il pourrait
gagner et donc ouais salut salut à tous
et toutes dans le
chat poursivre cette fin
d'avant-dernier match de ces
championnats
d'Europe donc très mauvaise nouvelle
pour la section open avec nos bleus qui
faisaiit une remontada de défaites en
début de parcours mais sui d'une
remontada qu'on espérait voir jusqu'au
bout et finalement contré par
l'Allemagne et ben voilà Alexander
donchenko a assorti son tourage de d'une
proposition que Maxime tout combattif
qu'il est tout champion de France 2019
qu'il a été n'a pas plus
refuser à propos je pense que donchenko
a raison certaine façon parce que demain
il reste une dernière ronde ça sert à
rien de s'épuiser sur sur cette partie
l'Allemagne est toujours seule en tête
demain il y aura un gros match euh
c'était exactement ce qu' que ma réponse
au chat non par équipe on ne joue pas
toujours pour Le Guen évidemment dono
c'est quelqu'un d'ultra combattif vous
inquiétez pas en Open pour lui il euh
enfin en Open ou enfermé en tant
individuel il propose jamais nul par
équipe il assure le gain de l'équipe
comme tu l'as dit le facteur repos pas
négligeable parce que il y a rien de
plus important que la victoire d'équipe
et donc retournons chez la seule partie
qui reste celle de dem alors il y a une
la dernière r
elle est à 15h elle à 15h aussi ah ouais
d'habitude il les faisait un tout petit
peu plus tôt ça a changé euh quand
j'avais regardé c'était 15h alors euh
15h on va checker donc je parlais de
cette idée de rendre une qualité pour
euh pour simplifier la position le seul
truc qui est un peu surprenant c'est que
j'en parlais quand ça forçit le change
de dame là il y a pas d'échange de
dame je pense qu'on reprendre la dame
quand
même attends est-ce que démontter va
pouvoir donc la menace H4 menace
concrète de la part des blancs qui
profite du clouage du fond donc il faut
parer la menace et la question c'est
euh est-ce
que les nos peuvent essayer de créer du
contrejeu en poussant le pioncé est-ce
que c'est possible ou pas à quel moment
après avoir paré la menace on j H5 du
coup H5
7 les de
sonti en tout cas la partie
Durre encore donc ce tour G2 c'était dû
à quoi bon après c'est vrai aussi que le
cavalier H4 il était désagréable hein
donc pourquoi pas mais bon donc la
partie devrait se prolonger encore il a
cet
échange si les blancs arrivent à forcer
l'échange des dames c'est d'ailleurs
est-ce que c'est si fini si on joue ça
ça ça
j'arrive pas qu'est-ce qui se passe en
fait je voulais le gros problème c'est
c'est la possibilité des noirs de des
blanc de se créer un pion passé en
1 je pense c'est ça le problème
principal de la
position s'il y avait pas ce pion a on
pourrait espérer nul mais là avec ce
pion h
ouais puis si on se retrouve à défendre
un truc comme ça le fou il est
totalement jeu et puis un moment joue
avec une tour de moin euh donc l'échange
de dame a priori c'est bel et bien
catastrophique donc du coup peut-être
pas trop F7
euh ça mais est-ce que les blancs
peuvent forcer l'échange de
dames bon ça pue mais on a envie
oui on est toujours en vie tant qu'on a
envie il y a de l'espoir doncant qu' y a
de l'espoir le stream saute
régulièrement il y a de l'espoir ça
vient de chez toi toi ah ben je je ne
sais
pas enfin non non non pardon ça vient de
chez toi c'est quelqu'un qui dit c'est
un réponse à l'autre euh ben je ne sais
pas je ne sais pas non ça ça saute moi
aussi il saute ok je sais pas d'où ça
vient peut-être que c'est lié ouais
alors normalement j'ai j'ai des
techniciens ah oui bah du coup je peux
dire pourquoi je suis pas chez moi c'est
un truc
surréaliste c'est Orange là je vais
faire une petite publicité pour Orange
te faisait régulièrement la publicité
pour pour SFR allez moi c'est pour
Orange donc je déménage
j'emménage il y a un technicien qui
vient premier technicien après 2h il me
dit bon pas de chance madame ésias il
faut un technicien expert je dis bah
d'accord faites venir un technicien
expert il le rendez-vous pendant que je
suis au tournoi en cdide ils font le
truc à distance enfin moi je gère ça à
distance et tout il repasse je reviens
chez moi moi j'ai la fibre je télécharge
à 500 m secondondes c'est génial merci
le technicien expert quel expert
eTTH et 3 jours après euh j'ai plus
internet j'appelle et là quelqu'un me
dit ah ben oui madame islisa c'est
normal il y a encore un technicien chez
vous ah bonok dans dans les parties
communes de de l'immeuble bon d'accord
mais c'est bizarre parce que ça vient de
sauter il y a y a de minutes quoi et et
en fait je sais pas pourquoi ils ont pas
su m'expliquer ils m'ont rappelé 3h
après ils m'ont dit en fait la mauvaise
nouvelle madame Ilia c'est que le le
technicien est revenu enlever internet
je dit pardon
mais ça marchait avant oui oui mais là
il est venu et maintenant ça marche plus
et et donc il faut reprendre rendez-vous
et j'ai rendez-vous demain matin voilà
donc j'ai eu trois techniciens qui sont
venus un pour rien faire un pour mettre
internet un pour l'enlever ce qui ce
quiétait pas une demande de ma part et
là j'en ai un 4è qui va venir
pour peut-être j'espère remettre
Internet et donc si j'ai la fibre depuis
chez moi peut-être que ça marchera mieux
voilà bon ben c'est c'est ouais c'est
bien tu as des tu as des j'ai plein de
pépéciire c'est on dirait on dirait des
Lego quoi tu tu mets un Lego tu un Lego
tu on remet un autre euh ok ok bon ben
ça donne très envie d'aller chez Orange
mais n'hésite pas c'est le plus
cher spécialiste c'est c'est on paye
plus cher mais en même temps on
contribue à au travail de de
beaucoup beaucoup de technici je vois
que le service service àprèsvente est
réactif mais après est-ce qu'il est
efficace ah non mais j'étais tellement
mais c'était tellement CFC que
j'arrivais pas au téléphone il mais je
je comprends pas enfin j'ai l'impression
que je comprends ce que vous me dites
mais on est d'accord ça n'a pas de sens
oui on est vraiment désolé madameia
c'était c'est un
technicien j'aurais voulu enregistrer
quoi cette conversation
surréaliste bon alors d déjou des
déjou 15 minutes à la pendule est-ce que
est-ce que tu prendrais en G2 ton
adversaire vient de te faire cavalier pr
euh viens de te faire tour G2 parce
qu'elle l'a toujours pas joué
elle se dit aussi peut-être vu que
euh mon adversaire se galère avec mes
deux pièces mineures et qu'elle me
propose elle
même sa tour contre mon cavalier
peut-être je veux pas simplifier la
position mais je préfère jouer avec
jouer dame pr B6 au prochain coup en
fait en non elle veut jouer tour G1 et
dame prend B6 ouais ouais parce que si
on not sur un coup est-ce que il y a un
coup neutre est-ce que tu as vraiment
des coups possibles oui non je peux
jouer ça et sur dame pr B6 dame F3 et
donc ça ça ça va ça ça serait bien ok
mais elle va pas jouer ça ouielle va pas
jouer dans
Prem alors il y a des fans d' Orange qui
elle réfléchit à B5 nous dit
choise avec l'idée d'ame pr M5 dame F3
ah non ah non mais là il y a dam ouais
non non il a une dam D3 qui oui oui oui
tu as raison tu prang2 en fait tu qu'
prangé2 et pourquoi de et sur dame D3 ah
c'est ça mais toi tu dis qu'elle est pr
2 dame ouais mais Dame des 3 on
a le matériel ça va tu as deux pièces HM
ouais oui oui i non non non moi j'avais
du mal à comprendre pourquoi c'était nul
mais visiblement il y a il y a cet échec
précis et toutun coup on peut même
gagner hein en fait c'est rigolo parce
que tuas tu as le droit de perdre en
fait ah c'est donc tu peux prendre
autant de risque que tu semble qui te
semble possible pour essayer de gagner
quoi il y a beaucoup de positions qui
sont pas gagnables mais elles sont
toutes perdables euh exemple voilà Yosa
je reviens juste dans 2 secondes mon qui
veut tout à l'heure et et ben
occupe
occupe-t
euh donc évidemment d' pr B5 ne sera pas
joué en 4 B5 mais du coup c'est un coup
du coup c'est c'est un
coup c'est que les pièces blanches sont
pas coordonnées ouais je sais pas ce
qu'on ferait ah bah finalement elle a
pris
ok il prise un gel d'e on voit qu'il
commande à la maison bah c'est toujours
le chatin quand quand on on a un
chat c'est le chat qui
commande donc on en est là on en
parler de cette position dans laquelle
le blanc menace H4 profitant du
clouage mais bon donc deux possibilités
en fait est-ce qu'on bouge le roi si on
bouge le roi est-ce qu'on bouge le roi
elle a pris finalement pas B5 ou quoi
elle a pris donc est-ce qu'on bouge le
roi si oui ou est-ce qu'on bouge la dame
pour empêcher H4 il y a pas d'autre
possibilité me regarde avec des yeux non
je tiens juste à dire que les chats oui
c'est toujours le chat qui décide quand
il a soif il faut lui donner à boire
quand il a faim faut lui donner à manger
quand elle est devant la porte faut lui
ouvrir la porte 2 secondes après faut
encore lui ouvrir la porte après elle
veut rentrer après elle ve sortir même
temp le plus indéc qui existe sur Terre
quoi c'est insupportable tu vis chez
elle donc elle te laisse enfin elle te
laisse vivre chez elle mais voilà il y a
des contreparties quoi tu vois
c'est tout ça pour avoir une peluche
vivante quoi
ok on en est
là alors est-ce que peut-être quelqu'un
peut nous dire est-ce que il y a des
parties sympa
autre parce que on peut peut-être jeter
un coup
d'œil je vais je vais faire les
Petitier
ici c'est vrai que une seule partie en
plus un avantage quand même bien bien
décisif ça sera pas le truc le plus
rig faire une pause je sais pas quand
est-ce qu'on a fait la dernière pause
comme ça on on s'approche un peu du
quand même parce que ok ben ouais je
fais une pause mais je reste devant
l'ordi comme ça si jamais il y
[Rires]
aux parce que ça ça peut aussi se
décider vite quand même la position est
bien gagnante mais ouais on peut on peut
faire ça faisons tu veux tu veux rester
commentter non non non je vais je vais
juste regarder la partie quand même
c'est je va pas faire une pause ou je va
pas aller me balader dans Paris quoi
mais ça me marche petite pause et on
revient pour la fin de cette partie si
matchul miraculeux il y a on gagne le
match euh et sinon ça fera match nul un
partout donc on se dit à dans quelques
minutes ciao quel est le meilleur moyen
de suivre n'importe quel événement
échikien Surpat du monde au tournoi des
candidats en passant par le speed chess
ou les title Tuesday
chess.com/events couvre tous les plus
grands tournois d'échec il se déroule en
présentiel ou en ligne
vivez et comprenez en direct les parties
des meilleurs joueurs de la planète avec
les commentaires en français de nos
experts notre moteur d'analyse
l'explorateur d'ouverture et les tables
base retrouvez toutes les infos
essentielles comme le programme les
horaires des rondes les prix les
résultats les contre rendus quotidien
les bios des joueurs les règles des
partages et plus encore vous pouvez même
participer à la compétition en
pronostiquant les résultats pour tenter
de gagner des abonnements premium alors
rendez-vous dès maintenant sur
chess.com/events aussi bien sur le site
internet sur nos app votre passion comme
nul part
[Musique]
ailleurs
et on est de retour pour cette fin de
partie et peut-être le miracle ou pas de
démonter dolité cornz avec les pièces
noires toujours une position foutue face
à Elizabeth PE ça fait énormément de
coup qu'elle se bat avec d'abord deux
qualités de moins puis plus qu'une seule
qualité de moins pour un pion donc
matériellement ça va plus ou moins le
problème c'est que il reste plus
beaucoup de piè sur les chiquers et que
la différence entre la Tour Blanche et
le fou noir commence sérieusement à se
faire sentir bon là il y a dam F3 qui
une grosse menace ça devrait être
aisément paré par dame 2 de P et
la position est toujours compromise mais
il y a encore de la
vie
euh gr sur la place demande une base de
régime Mo mais c'était totalement gagant
certes mais c'est c'est pas facile alors
après il y a aussi des
positions qui demandent à ce qu'on se
presse pas alors c'est un peu frustrant
quand on sait qu'on est totalement
gagnante que ça tourne ça tourne que la
partie continue queil y a la
pression du stress le poids du match et
cetera sur ses épaules mais je j'ai pas
vu de gain net qu'elle aurait raté en de
trois coups
quoi alors pour l'instant on en est
là bon ne pas jouer d'AMO c'est bizarre
quand
même il y a pas r j'ai de c'est l'autre
échec
donc on s'y attend vraiment se dame 2 et
ça a une menace
dis-moi sin il peut avir des coups comme
c'est ou d à 8 mais
bon c'est pas non plus ah mais en fait
il y a un coup pardon il y a un autre
coup c'est
ça
ah parce qu'on veutchanger les dames
depuis longtemps mais là le
problème c'est que ça ch d mais ça donne
un protégé mais après c'est très concret
parce que si ici on peut manger jouer à
5 c'est
terminé donc tout d'un coup ça devient
une course mais à la différence de la
position tout à l'heure tu te rappelle
tout à l'heure tu disais si j'arrive à
échanger les dames h euh si même si le
Fou vient défendre en A5
euh bon tu disais bon je jouerai avec un
un une pièce avec une tour en moins
ouais si le Fou est est lié à la
défense du pion euh du pion A4 du pion
B6 mais le problème c'est que là
maintenant le roi il est en H4 donc la
position des des Noirs le roi est
beaucoup plus actif il est
pas il peut bloquer le ouais il peut
bloquer le roi noir le roi blanc il y a
des coups qui ont été joué ouais elle a
joué dame 2 parce que donc dame 4 elle a
lui pensé mais ça ne marchait pas on
échange et le pion court et visiblement
d'près la jauge le contrejeu suffit à
sauver le match nul dame c'est le plus
naturel elle a dû quand même penser à
Dame à4 quichange les dames et B5
sacrifice de pion pour jouer C4 et
obtenir le contrejeux évidemment ce
option est imprenable là c'est pas gain
noir mais c'est au moins match nul après
dame F3 suivi de F 3 échec donc pr B5
impossible a priori on va pouvoir jouer
C4 au prochain
coup donc je ouais qu'elle a prévu B5 ça
empêche dame C4 aussi parce que autant
dame A4 l'échange des dame ne marchait
pas de manière exceptionnelle autant là
on est plus dans l'exception dame C4
c'est la vraie Mace donc B5 très bon
coup est-ce qu'on pas des idées avec
tour F1 CELI de dame F2 échec
al je
tour c'est c'est une idée ouais
donc oui en plus c'est c'est pas simple
de protégerion
ouais al il y a ça pour aller un peu
vers l'avant mais ça ça
ressemble à une vraie position foutue
quoi est-ce que tour F5 est pas mal
pour aller choper
pion ça ressemble à un truc vraiment
gagnant
mais la jauge a AB
bondi par contre l'Azerbaidjan est en
train de gagner son match donc ça serait
vraiment bien de Cornat sauve la
nulle sera incroyable si elle arrive à
sauver la nulle ce serait
alors mais
d'ailleurs on va mettre le remettre le
petitchi est là on regarder les autres
parties on va remettre les chiquier
d'analyse donc on est là dame de B5 tour
F jouer elle a joué ton coup et donc là
a priori les blancs force changer d'â
parce que si on met la dame sur une trop
mauvaise case où elle est pas en prise
certes enfin elle est pas échangeable
certes mais elle est trop excentrée on
se prend ton dame F2 échec dame prend F5
fin de partie donc tI a échangé les
dames autant jouer dame 4 mais je crois
que c'est c'est fini malheureusement
ou au roi G2 tout simplement on
rapproche le roi de du
centre blanc ensuite oui les blancs
ensuite vont jouer juste A4
et et direction
ouais alors on peut jouer B4 si j'ai si
on avait le temps de faire un truc comme
ça on peut espérer une espèce de
forteresse mais parce que sinon tu as
raison si si on joue genre parce que ça
et ça ça peut être sympa aussi mais en
fait il va y avoir ro F3
et alors A4 peut-être pas trop tôt non
plus mais ad mettons un truc comme
ça le problème c'est qu'il y a des plans
avec C4 et le P ouais ouais non c'est
alors donc là tu tu te mets en
difficulté après on a le droit qui peut
être excentré aussicentré oui
mais bon en tout cas elle a toujours pas
joué dame 4 mais a priori
c'est le coûp du moindre mal en sachant
que ça doit être perdant quand même dans
tous les cas enfin nous on le sait elle
elle doit elle doit le sentir
aussi bon ça devrait s'accélérer quand
même puis qu'elle a plus que 3 minutes à
la pendule donc
ou fallir qu'elle prenne une décision va
falloir prendre une décision dans cette
position
ouais mais je vois vraiment pas de coup
parce que dame G4 au minimum même dame
F2 en fait dame point F5 c'est seulement
plus fort et sinon je vois pas en fait
je vois pas un trou que
dans
et après au moins on peut espérer des
problèmes techniques mais ça en
fait
IL4 mais non enfin le souci c'est qu'il
a juste A4 et et le pion a qui court à
nouveau là tout de suite ou après t oui
même après oui même après roi G4 roi B2
enfin à tout moment en
fait et même à 4 maintenant mais c'est
pas mal de le
faire une fois que le pion est attaqué
parce que comme ça le fou doit le
défendre
et et ça paraît
compromis V que la seule chose qu'on
peut qu'on puisse espérer c'est que la
joueuse allemande oublie qu'elle a un
pion a mais bon ouais pas trop même là
A4 immédiatement est très très fort en
tout
cas on en est là dans la partie de
beaucoup
de de beaucoup de de force de
d'abnégation bah ouais ou elle a
vraiment pour son équipe tout donné dans
cette partie chaotique dans laquelle
elle était très bien après la je puis
fout puis c'était compliqué puis fout et
CETA il y a eu un gros combat c'est
parti où il y a beaucoup d'erreur ça
montre pas forcément un enfin évidemment
ça montre un mauvais niveau de jeu dans
l'absolu ça des erreurs mais c'est
souvent plus une un indice de la
complexité de la position il y position
où n'importe quel joueur humain fait des
erreurs donc là la position était ultra
complexe CIT on savait qu' allit d'
avoir des erreurs de part et d'autres il
y en eu plus du côté de démonter bon
c'est le jeu c'est le jeu et maintenant
on a cette finale perdante dans laquelle
ellisabeth doit encore
convertir malheureusement la Grand
Maître qu'elle est ne devrait pas avoir
trop de
mal voyons si elle prend bonne
direction ben restons oui de toute façon
on va pas maintenant qu'on est là
maintenant qu'on est là ma chère nana
mais
on peut espérer qu'elle joue vite quand
même surtout qu'elle joue vite une
erreur par exemple mais c'est là ce qui
est horrible c'est qu'on voit même pas
je crois pas qu'il a de mauvais
coup peut-être le tour5 que je sugéré
tout à l'heure
mais non il y a le stress c'est là alors
peut-être qu'il est retombé parce qu'on
a surtout beaucoup de stress après le
jackn ou quand on se rend compte que la
partie décisive et tout mais là c'est
les positions simplifier c'est pure
descendre mais bon quand même on sait
que on n pas forcément à son top donc
tour E3 et donc là on s'attend à
A4 créer un pion passé la 3 n'est pas du
tout dans le
carré pas trop de
manieuvre il y a tout
qui oui parce que de toute façon sur
A4 bon prise prise admettons ro G4 on va
pas laisser faire ro
F3 on pourrait P que sur A4 prise
faudrait plutôt tenter la course C4 au
lieu de G4 je voulais juste je dire que
même ça un peu même ça ouais donc en
fait les Blancs ont tous les plans qui
gagnent ouais prise prise C4 ouais mais
là pareil non on essaie on Essie ça a
l'air
oui ça l'air fortement compromis je suis
d'accord alors
ouais en fait même ici bon les Noirs
vont pas échanger les les pions mais
quand bien même ça serait foutu euh
c'est le fou de la la mauvaise couleur
on aurait pré enfin je veux dire si on
fait ça juste ça ça gne c'est pas le
plus malin pour les blancs mais même ça
ça
g donc euh
ouis E3 on en est là r g de jouer
ok on peut pas laisser faire F3 par on
parlait de B4 pour empêcher à4 mais ici
F3
et il va même y avoir peut-être pas trop
tôt quand même lesciidé de 3 parce que
le P peut être faible
Mme
dur dur r G 2 R G4 jouer on s'attend
vraiment à4 ici mais sinon tu as des
prochains tournois prévu nana
euhou pas encore pas immédiatement pas
immédiatement je
ouais peut-être à partir de avril
reprendrai du service et et tu as joué
en en N1
ouais j'ai joué en N1 avec le club Dex
en Provence joue pour le club Dex ouais
pour le moment ça marche bien après on a
fait que de weekends donc
oui ok mais pas suffisant pour non on a
fait qu'un seul weekend en fait on a
joué qu'un seul weekend OK et l'équipe a
gagné les deux matchs
oui on a gagné les deux matchs ou
l'objectif ou c'est c'est
mon en première
divisionêes les favoris de ce group moi
j'ai
unye dire quandme on l'équipe de grâce
qui qui a déjà une équipe en Top 16 une
équipe qui est pas mal du tout aussi en
deè division
national ça reste quand Mme un gros
match oui mais du coup il me laisse pas
de
monter ça dépend
ça dépend ça dépend du résultat de leur
équipe des récupines ah maintenant il y
a il y a plus la règle de du passement
de jambes interdit là euh parce que
pendant longtemps on pouvait
pas c'était c'était la règle anti Noyon
je crois qui faisait ça souvent qui qui
délaissait totalement le le top mais
c'est à un moment il parlait de
l'enlever mais pendant longtemps
peut-être quelqu'un dans le chat sait
pendant longtemps quand bien même
l'équipe une mais je crois que c'est ce
qui s'est passé pour P d'ailleurs cette
année si je dis pas de bêtis V éit
première de son de son groupe de N1 est
descendu du Top 16 et puis ça fait le
yoyo quoi pas ça fait la le wagon quoi
ah l'équipe 2 est passé en National 2 en
term en première quoi ou
c'est chaud quand même ça ouis oui du
coup c'est dommage mais bon c'est
c'était pour éviter il y avait un club
l'impression CIT Noyon mais peut-être je
me trompe c'est il y a quand même
quelques années qui
euh qui
préférait souvent délaisser quelques
années de suite avait délaissé la
première division pour se concentrer sur
la deuxème et comme ça alterner ses
équipes et puis un moment ils ont dit
non non on peut plus faire
ça oui oui ça c'est pas ça c'est ouais
c'est anti c'est antisport de toute
façon je pense tu as le droit tu as pas
le droit d'avoir une équipe deux plus
fortte que ton équipe une non ça devrait
être interdit je pense
ça si ça pas changé ça encore interdit
ouais je je veux proposer dans la
position de
démter qu'on peut pas tenter un petit
piège avec genre fou H4
ou est-ce que je me fais direct non mais
ça on menace de gagner donc c'est
bien malheureusement il y a juste H3 et
F3 ok bon dommage
ouais et ça va être dur
ouais qu le CO mais c'est ce tour
F1 un
[Musique]
peu un peu superflu quoi c'est vrai bon
ça coupe le roi et tout mais bon on
voyait que à 4 gagnait tout simplement
mais bon après H3 c'est l' de toute
façon oui en fait c'est pas
jouer H3 hos F3 donc non mais c'est très
bien ouais elle veut jouer H3 100 hos F4
et c'est vrai que là c'est difficile de
de proposer le moindre
coût mais je pense que en en en avril je
me referaai bien je ferais bien sa je
peux pas jouer sijs HM et euh et sij
c'est vraiment un tournoi super super
super fort cadre génial en décembre
quand tu fait froid partout là-bas
tuas le soleil fait 19 20°gr le soleil
la mer tu tu es pas trèsis quand tu dois
faire un peu de sport tu dois marcher
une demi-heure tro quart d'heure pour
aller à salle de jeu ben tu es tu es
dégoûté tu dis ça va me fatiguer pour
rien et là B c'est du plaisir hein tu
longes la mer pour aller jouer ouais
c'est hy tourno ou ouais et donc bah
s'ils font l'édition à forment terrain
c'est l'Î à côté d'biza pourquoi pas on
en avril mai ça peut être ça peut être
sympa ça
les mêmes organisateurs qui font ça OK
et ben ouais ouais c'est toute façon l'
Spagne on l'aime mais oui mais trop on
aime
l'Espagne non prochain tournoi ça sera
ro à Noël je vais faire un tournoi à
Noël pour la première fois depuis au
moins 10 ans j'aime pas jouer les
tournois de ronde par jour j'arrive
vraiment pas mais là j'avais envie de
jouer
donc h donc voilà fa de la
chance du bol bah on verra on verra
parce que de rond par jour c'est pas de
mon
âge mais après il faut se dire que c'est
c'est la même chose pour tout le monde
en fait oui alors c'est ce que je dis
comme ça qu'il faut penser he faut dire
c'est pareil pour tout le monde et c'est
celui qui a c'est la personne
qui qui reste qui qui croit en elle le
plus qui peut-être pourra passer
quoi plus de chance d'y arriver ce petit
mais ça a l'air très charmant j'ai pris
mon petit
rbnb c'est en plein centreeville on
verra allez B4 jouer H3 échec jouer roi
H4
bon donc ellizabeth n'a pas voulu jouer
à 4 maintenant elle ne peut plus on
disait que tout à l'heure que s'il fou
pouvait se téléportter sur des qu il y
aurait peut-être des espoirs de
forteresse pas dit d'ailleurs
dit du que ça ça suffise parce que
parfois on peut jouer à 3 B4 et CETA
quand on a le des TR ou quoi
mais là le fou de toute façon n'y va pas
n'y est pas on est
loin après comment gagner au plus
précisément ça c'est pas mal s'il y
a il a pas
de il pas de par Ch et
ça
ah mais non il y a pas
si si
si pardon je commence à avoir des des
alus après 5h de
jeu 5 de jeu et rondes c'est normal de
fatiguer B ouais ouais attends moi je
suis plus à fond enfin peut-être pas
plus à fond mais je suis pas moins à
fond je peux dire d' toimême tu sais
parce qu'on a on a souvent on s'est
souvent échanger des des messes
pendant les parties avec d'autres
joueurs également il y a vraiment cette
ulation dont on
parlait bon là c'est difficile quand
même de d'y croire à cette partie là
mais il restera un match demain pour
pour la médaille peut-être la plus belle
des mé bien sûr on noublie pas que que
bon que que le match si démoné par cette
partie c'est qu'un match nul et la
Bulgarie doit quand même encore gagner
demain faut que l'Azerbaïdjan gagne
demain en fait il y a encore pas mal de
conditions enfin bon c'est vrai
que hier avec le défaite contre la
Bulgarie en fait bon les Françaises ont
perdu entre guillemets le le contrôle de
leur destin ont perdu le je sais pas
comment on dit c'est quoi l'expression
c'est ça où
on ouais non plus le mais après ça
n'empêche pas que il y a toujours des
des fois il peut y avoir des
circonstances qui font ben qu'on finisse
première et quoi qu'il en soit ben
l'objectif c'est la deuxè place et c'est
pas la deè place ce sera la 3è place
et voilà c'est un podium ou rien peu
importe la marge du podium ce qui en
soit un résultat assez c'est un résultat
extraordinaire c'est je pense pas qu'on
s' attendait à avoir les
Françaises mener cette compétition je
pense pas qu'on s'y attendait oui oui
mais alors après dans non je suis
d'accord avec toi c'est l'ensemble de la
compétition mais je p je pense que on
peut faire un on fera il y aura un bilan
qui sera fait c'est le bilan des points
h gagn et je pense que ça sera ça sera
très important en terme de point H
galier pas que par popo hein je pense
que sur l'ensemble des joueuses c'est
plus que positif mais on joue pas pour
les points et l' c'est compétitions donc
si à la fin il y a pas de médaille et
s'il y a pas la plus belle des
médailles il y aura quand même de la
déception c'est sûr mais en tout cas ça
fait plaisir de voir nos joueus bien
joué et après on on est là enfin elles
sont là pour pour remporter ce
championnat je pense qu'il y a un point
important à mettre à mettre en avant
c'est que là on est sur une une équipe
qui est en train de se former une
nouvelle équipe tu as dit avec l'arrivée
de de nouvelles joueuses il y a pas très
longtemps ben c'est Anastasia Savina qui
est arrivé puis Mitra puis et démonté
mitraille démonté on a une équipe
avec je sais pas comment dire on a un
nouveau
gr dans on a un nouveau groupe un
nouveau souffle et j'ai vraiment le
sentiment que cette équipe en fait c'est
pas un coup du hasard là cette
compétition c'est pas un coup du hasard
que les que les filles jouent pour les
premières places h je pense vraiment
qu'on commence àir on a une vraie équipe
compétitive française on a des joueuses
très très compétitive pour et puis très
solidaire quoi c'est c'est pas que la
somme deindividualité des individualités
quoi c'est vraiment l'équipe donc tu
imagines donc Championnat du Monde 3e
place championnat d'Europe un tournoi
exceptionnel j'ai envie de voir les
Olympiades j'ai envie de voir les
prochains championnats d'Europe
prochains championnats du monde en fait
c'est pas juste cette compétition là
qu'il faut regarder il faut regarder ce
qui est en train de se construire
apprendre à jouer des matchs avec
un avec un avec un enjeu un match voilà
enfin je veux dire quand il y avait les
équipes russes et cetera elles elles ont
appris à gérer la la pression faut
laisser le temps aussi à nos françaises
ben d'apprendre à gérer cette pression
et je pense qu'on peut aller
mais je pense que les joueuses que
l'équipe de France féminine peut aller
très très loin et je pense que
maintenant enfin je le dis vraiment avec
conviction que l'équipe de France
féminine d'échec est en train de se
créer sa propre identité sa propre
histoire et c'est ce que vraiment enfin
je l'espère j'y crois vraiment puis non
mais c'est c'est ce qu'on ressent c'est
ce qu'on ressent alors en attendant il y
a eu des des coups joués et certes des
mon réussi à mettre le fr des ques on
disait que c'était excellent mais ça lui
a coûté un pion et euh pas n'importe
lequel le pion eu et donc là ça va
gagner facilement l'roit
inarrêtable va aller en C4 et puis à un
moment les blancs vont sacrifier la
qualité par exemple
ou même d'ailleurs on peut faire tout le
tour ENF mais ça ça gagne
tranquille magique nous demande par
rapport à à Marie n demande si elle n
plus sa place dans l'équipe non en fait
c'est juste que Marie ben elle a elle
est elle est psychologue et tu disais un
peu plusutôt Yosa qu'elle a ouvert son
cabinet de psychologueelle fait ses
consultations donc voilà elle se
concentre sur sur son métier oui oui
parce que effectivement il y a l'effet
groupe après si jamais Marie voulait
décider là aujourd'hui tien finalement
j'en ai marre de mon cabinet de
psychologie je me remets à fond aux
échecs a priori elle sera elle sera en
équipe de
France là c'est c'est c'est la grand
maîre pour l'instant c'est encore la
seule grand maître
française mais bon si c'est c'est elle
aussi qui a fait ses choix de vie de de
se consacrer un métier civil
quoi je pense quelque chose qu'on on
oublie assez souvent c'est qu'on parle
d'équipe et
euh donc équipe de France c'est vrai
qu'on a souvent cette impression ben en
fait que les échecs ben oui c'est un
sport individuel mais à partir du moment
où on joue en équipe il y a des choses
qu'il faut prendre en compte et
notamment la cohésion d'un groupe
et ce qu'un groupe Ensemble peut faire
parce que bon il y a souvent cette
phrase tout seul on va plus vite
ensemble on va plus loin on pense des
portes en pense Desportes mais voilà
faut faudra voir si le groupe marche
très bien comme ça enfin est-ce que ça
vaut le coup de rempprre un équilibre
juste pour un résultat enfin c'est donc
c'est vrai que c'est une question qui se
pose est-ce qu'on est juste sur
l'individuel ou est-ce qu'on est sur la
création d'un nouveau groupe et d'une
équip mais en fait je crois que faç la
question se pose pas enfin pardon je
t'ai coupé je crois que la question se
pose pas parce que Marie a a décidé de
de toujours jouer aux écheac un peu mais
de mettre les écheacs en retrait pour ce
qu' sacr à son activité professionnelle
et on l'avait mentionné en début de
stream Marie a été championne d'Europe
avec les enfin cette équipe de France en
2001 c'était il y a il y a 22 ans
euh voilà ça fait 22 ans qu'elle qu'elle
joue pour ou peut-être plus d'ailleurs
cétait pas sûr que ça soit sa première
compétition au moins 22 ans qu'elle joue
pour l'équipe de France elle a le droit
de de faire autre chose en plus du
facteur cohésion groupe et ce et mais
c'est c'est pas voilà çaelle est encore
relativement jeune he plus jeune que que
Sophie par exemple mais mais
elle a le droit d'en avoir d'en avoir
marre et puis de s'épanouir ailleurs que
dans les échec la même manière que et
Maxime ont le droit de faire leur
tournoi à Saint-Louis euh bon c'est
c'est des
choix alors ça joue ça joue
le fou va revenir en D4 se coup pour
protéger le pion pe Jer un petit coup de
tour
C6 pour attaquer le
page c'est assz marrant quand comment ça
fait des heures et des heures qu'il y a
pas vraiment de suspense la partie se
pourç encore peut-être la gâche à un
moment là on voit vraiment
pas on voit vraiment pas
quoi
un tour magique si si si si tour magique
je crois que Natacha a très bien
expliqué les phénomènes de groupe ils
existent
vraiment si si ça existe oui ils
existent il existe vraiment d'ailleurs
tu l'as vécu il y a pas
longtemps
pour je joue en équipe à chaque fois que
tu joues en équipe c'est c'est vraiment
oui tu es tu es seul laisser les
chiquers mais tu as une responsabilité
qui n'est pas juste individuelle tu as
une responsabilité commune et euh c'est
hyper agréable en fait de jouer en
équipe c'est super sympa mais je le vois
pas ton chat pourquoi je le rate à
chaque fois non elle se cache elle se
cache elle se fait entendre mais elle se
cache elle se cache sous la
T pumpkin the cat il a entendu oui ça
fait venir pumking the cat euh alors R 5
donc la question c'est est-ce qu'on peut
vraiment tout le temps sacrifier parce
que c'est pas sûr qu'on puisse sacrifier
dans n'importe quelles condition aussi
euh c'est-à-dire que si on joue un peu
naïvement ce genre de coup bon à un
moment euh les blancs vont prendre le
pion
h donc
oui mais qu'on
faitir les les blancs veulent d'abord
contenir le roi noir pour l'éloigner le
plus du pion h avant de sacrifier dans
des bonnes conditions juste de jouer une
finale
avec avec des pions en plus tout
simplement un Chen qui on s'attend
a joué tour des6 elle a joué tour des6
ouais piège
R3 et on gagne
on s'y attend pas peut t'arriver
ouais après 5h et demi de jeu parce que
sinon c'est je veux faire
ça
alors après il y a il y a des histoires
de Tang aussi potentiellement
oui et surtout après ro H4 si par
exemple joue la tour en D5 ouais mais
j'ai ça encore seul
coup hein c'est j'ai pas de coup droit
j'ai pas de coup de fou qui parle le
pion à part ça et donc est-ce que il y a
vraiment de fant ou est-ce que je peux
juste jouer
ça c'est ass marrant parce qu'après un
coup par exemple comme tour5 fou D4
tour4 roi G5 attends attends attends
quand on était
pardon ici quand on jouait genre ça ça
ouais et par exemple tour 5 fou des4
tour échec parce qu'on n pas
l'impression que les Blancs a fait des
des progrès juste le P H6 est passé en
H5 on pas impression que les blanc est
progressé en fait h non puis il y a
toujours ce
ouais c facteur stress pression quoi
H5 jouer
ouais c'était le coup qu'on
disait allez ro G3 on parle plus allez
on a fa non mais on a fa donne ta tour
allez donne ta tour mais
oui e dépêche-toi
quoi le problème c'est qu'il 6 minutes
bon ouais non
mais on croit pas VO je TR
mais on dit la photo d'éliisabeth
n'est pas récente non plus ouais oui
depuis cette photo elle a un peu vieillé
c'est sûr après ça se voit pas forcément
de de loin
je sais
pas oui on la reconnaî pas sypa to
ouais avec Elizabeth j'ai un peu plus de
mal qu'avec d'autres
mais mais je voulais juste balancer ma
petite CR que personne relève tu sais
avec l'espir que tout le monde entende
mais tout le monde se pose la question
de mais cé fait
exprès cétait juste un vocabulaire mal
choisi mais oui cétait fait exprès
ou mais sûement ok t de 5 H4 jouer mais
attends en plus tu es même pas forcé de
jouer ro G2 parce que sur roi prend H3
et tour prend H5 mat donc là il faut
jouer un coup avec ton fou fa jouer un
coup avec ta tour admettons joue tour
F5 tes forcé de jouer faut jouer
F bien
ouis bon et puis d'ailleurs juste pour
expliquer que T prend ch c'est grave si
ça fait mat mais c'est grave aussi si ça
fait pas un truc comme ça maintenant
c'est fini parce que là on va vraiment
pouvoir sacrifier et
gagner donc obligé de le fouger et la
question c'est comment on gagne parce
que là on pourrait sacrifier
éventuellement mais ça va jamais gagner
parce que il y a le point H3 donc c'est
pas si
simple est-ce
que j'ai une idée on joue ton ton coup
de tour F5
ouais et je veux faire
ça donc fou G1
ça fou D4
ça c'est pas mal non
ouais ça a l'air
[Musique]
complètement complètement suffisant
sachant que même si par pur hasard ben
tu prends H3 que ton roi il arrive à
temps à l' dame
ouais non mais là ou peut-re
sacrifier non je regardais si tu pouvais
pas jouer tour G5 et tour même oui ah
oui oui d'accord ouais oui oui c'est va
c'est la la version tactique de truc
ouais ah ouais donc ce plan il estign
j'aurais pas pensé si tu avait pas dit
tour F5 t F5 ouais mais ton idée elle
est géniale merci géni non mais c'est
vrai en fait c'est ça non mais c'est
c'est cool c'est c'est parce que donc en
fait non j'éis en train de me dire je
peux pas jouer au 4 3 F5 parce que là il
aurait prise mais du coup je prends ton
coup et puis hop là et tourner les
manigge
ouais alors des gens qui arrivent j'ai
pas suivi les Françaises on sont où on
mène à zéro le problème c'est qu'on est
foutu ici
euh la bonne nouvelle c'est que c'est la
dernière partie donc si mir lia on gagne
s'il y a pas de miracle on fait mat Chel
on en est là
ok mais je te l'ai dit on pourrait
presque dire que
ouais mais là après H4 je pense que
c'est fini H4 3 G6 3 D5 on peut
sacrifier
tranquillement parce que le temps que le
roi il a cherché le pion h
c'est et là
on et
malheureusement les blancs font dame la
première
et comme toujours quand c'est la course
despiontour
êre la première à arrivver
euh ok donc 3 G5 ça joue toujours à un
temps et après ce qui est affreux avec
ce genre de finale c'est que tu te dis
si j'avais eu un temps en plus oui en
fait à 3 au 4è coup ouverture on se dit
ça en fait oui ça c'est c'est souvent
comme ça que les position totalement
gagnantes qui ont plein de possibilités
de gain passe par je gagne un temps près
quoi
mais c'est vrai que d comme ça d comme
ça ah j'ai perdu un temps près on se dit
ah c'est pas de chance en fait non mais
tu étais totalement foutu depuis le
début tu avis trois qualités en moins
ouais j'ai j'ai eu ça à mon dernier
tournoi au CAPD contre anathan blackos
voà à la fin pareil une finale bah
qualité de moin d'ailleurs et ça gagne
un temps près mais en fait c'était il y
avait pas de suspense depuis B un peu
comme là c'était vraiment le même gen de
finale pas de suspense depuis 50
coups alors il y a eu ça l'UR est tout
de suite venu mais ça change rien
fondamentalement
enfin le pion h en H4 maintenant
donc elle a encore pas choisi le truc le
plus simple
si pr ça gagne ou
pas ah oui je pense ça gne comme ça euh
Yosa je reviens ça tembête pas non vas-y
toute façon je pense que ça va finir
enfin je dis ça je te dis à demain je
dis ça depuis
monde je dis ça depuis 2 he au revoir
tout le
monde allez dis au revoir tout le monde
désolé non vas-y vas-y vas-y si tu dois
y aller
euh bon alors du coup évidemment j'ai
pas de scène toute seule mais
euh ça devrait pas trop durer j'ai quand
même maintenant qu'on est là j'ai j'ai
envie de rester jusqu'au bout on va pas
on va pas abandonner la pauvre des mé
qui se bat toute seule
euh dans cette position désespérée mais
donc là ah oui mais d'ailleurs il y a
même la possibilité de sacrifier la
qualité en H4 je pense que c'est ce
qu'elle va faire c'est le plus simple et
après fou F2 roi G4 il peut y avoir un
abandon immédiat
oui c'est ce que tu dis Quentin je sais
que etit sur H ouais c'est le plus
simple
ici bon ENF c'est le plus simple tout
est simple
mais autant ne pas avoir de course à
calculer quand bien même là on la gagne
avec plusieurs temp
d'avance donc c'est juste paint qui
prend son temps pour faire durer encore
et encore fatigué les commentatrices ah
j'ai mon four qui qui est
chaud
euh mou Lokman et ben c'est c'est très
sympa ça écoute tu peux tu peux t'en
aller salut belle soirée
euh si tu as d'autres commentaire avant
vas-y comme ça tu seras ban et puis ça
sera un bon moyen de tu seras pas venu
pour rien quoi au
moins les mé courageuse ouais bah tenace
et puis surtout par équipe hein c'est
peut-être que la
elle aurait peut-être pas fait durer
autant la partie en en résultat
individuel mais là
bon donc la tour est attaqué mais tour à
ch et on voit vraiment
pas tour H5 ro F6 on va même pas prendre
la tour on va prendre du roi pour éviter
toute histoire de auquel on croit pas
mais toute histoire de roi 4 B2 ou je
sais pas quoi
mais
donc ça semble réellement
fini tour des
5 bon je peux pas m'expliquer ce coup
qu'est-ce qu'elle veut sur FO F2
j'espère qu'elle veut quand même jouer
ah peut-être qu'elle veut faire échec
c'est ça qu' technique sur échec ça et
sur ça on y va avec échec bon ça change
strictement
rien
[Musique]
mais c'est ça qu'elle
veut courageux c'est discutable non mais
c'est indiscutable de manière générale
après c'est peut-être pas dans cette
finale qu'elle l'a montré
bon on n jamais rien en abandonnant tout
ça mais bon là je crois que c'est ce
qu'elle va
faire non elle a pas voulu faire échec
et prise elle joue tour F5 là gagne un
pion allez je pronostique l'abandon ici
dans cette
position bon peut-être
[Musique]
que c'est c'est ma fin qui parle aussi
mais non non des mental est noir euh
malheureusement
on mène d'un point ce match mais il ne
reste plus que cette partie dans
laquelle on s'attend à l'abandon non fou
des4 roi prend H4 va être joué bon et là
ça
devient ça devient un peu superflu de de
de jouer
encore le Roi peut se transférer là
enfin tout gagne en fait ça gagnerait
s'il y avait pas l'histoire de la
qualité de plus
donc donc bon avec la tour contre le fou
ça gagne à for sie
euh merci Chel bleu à à demain
normalement demain à 15h Natacha et moi
on revient pour voir sur quelle place du
podium les françaises vont
terminer euh
ouais tout le monde qui euh qui va
manger ben oui c'est l'heure moi aussi
mon mon four est
chaud allez dmter il faut savoir faire
le deuil et garder un peu d'énergie
surtout je crois qu'elle a joué toutes
ses parties Démé et donc
elle doit être elle peut être fatiguée
aussi
maisci voilà
maintenant on peut sacrifier la qualité
ici
pas
d'espoir tout façon il y a même pas un
coup ici il faut jouer coup droit parce
que sur fou G1 il y a tour ici et donc
là ro
D5 C4 bon là ça devient vraiment superfu
de de continuer cette partie quand même
mais
bon tant qu'elle met pas fin au
stream
démter notre vice-championne de France
qui avait perdu la la finale au
départage contre
Mitra qu'elle décide de continuer on va
suivre le derniers coup aussi superfl
d'ailleurs ça peut intéresser certains
d'entre vous qui parfois sont frustrés
de voir des abandons dans les position
où il le comprennent pas pourquoi moi je
suis pas certaine de la gagner et CEET
bon là au moins je CIS que on obti i
dans laquelle tout le monde est certain
de la gagner et je vois le roi venu en
carte j'imagine que c'est dû au
placement des rois sur les chiquers et
donc que le résultat est
officiel donc victoire d'éliizabeth P
match nul pour l'équipe de France qui va
se battre pour le podium demain et ça
sera un match à suivre avec Natacha et
moi-même à partir de 15h bonne soirée à
tous et à toutes